Õpetaja: Olen maininud.
Õpetaja: Ee, disain, disain, stiil, et. Ee. Kui me räägime nendest akronüümidest ka, mis ee, Css võiks olla, See Siis
Õpetaja: ei ole veel. Me ei ole maininud seda siin.
Õpetaja: Kuidas? No jah, mainisin korraks. Aa, okei, proovime teistmoodi. Html ajar Ex konkreetne projekt, Aitäh,
Õpetaja: jah, täpselt. Ee. Ja ka. Noh, kuskil
Õpetaja: Styling Sheets. Ee, seda loodame juurde täna. Nagu ka vaadata, et nagu, mis see tähendab, jõuab kindlasti. Ja Ja avaski, et mis tema roll on
Õpetaja: nende ruumi interaktiivsus. Ee, funktsionaalsus. Action No Funktsionaalsus on tehniline. Õige termin.
Õpetaja: Natuke kohe.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ei, ee, sellepärast selle eest vastab Cs Ss andmed seal taga võib olla kokku kuidagi arvutada või panna. Jah, potentsiaalselt programmiliselt.
Õpetaja: Ee, see, et ta sinna ette tuleb. Võibolla see, et sa saad seda vajutada Ja midagi niukest. See on juba. Jah,
Õpetaja: aga lihtsalt põhimõtteliselt see graafik ise Otseselt. Ee, tegelikult.
Õpetaja: Ee, väga kuigi. Noh, ütleme niimoodi, et Javascriptiga on võimalik kõike teha jaoscriptiga on võimalik põhimõtteliselt veebilehele juurde lisada Cssi Html Elemente. Noh, ja programmeerimine niikuinii, et temaga saab kõike. Teha Ee, ikka ja jälle mult küsitakse, seda. Et Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, ma vaatan kas Jabra On Ikka Jah, on igastahrad.
Õpetaja: Ee rekordil ka on. Kuulge, kas rekordil läks kohapeale või Siis oli juba peal. Siis Seal oli veits On Mingi tühja Space. Kes iganes esimesena läks, on ju. Kes läks? Esimesena Seda saame näha. Videost.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma pean selle maha võtma, et ta kohe rekordima ei hakkaks. Peab hoidma meeles, et ta rekordima ikkagi lõpuks hakkas.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on tähtis.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei, räägime siis natukene veel Html Ist ka.
Õpetaja: Mm, just selles võtmes, et, ee, et mis ta struktuur on? Millest ta koosneb?
Õpetaja: Nendel mingeid mõtteid.
Õpetaja: Ma Ma vaatasin, et ma Kuulsin, nagu sa midagi ütlesid. Aga sa vaatasid uksest välja et, äkki seal midagi hõikas vaata. Et, Millest, atm Meil Koosneb millest atm Meil koosneb Eile Me juba vaatasime seda Suht tehniliselt ja süntaksit. Ja
Õpetaja: on teil mingeid võtkeid?
Õpetaja: Laevastus Ei, ole ei saa öelda, et ei ole tekst.
Õpetaja: Aa, no see on juba midagi Parem Kui seda struktuuri võtta. Siis on meil see Niukene Suures suur jaotus on selline, et meil on Niukene Head Section, mis on poole? Ütleme, põhimõtteliselt on nähtamatu. Me ei ole veel väga seda kasutanud, aga sinna saab igasuguseid asju lisada,
Õpetaja: Näiteks kui soovidki kasutada mingeid ee, stiilisätteid. Mis on eraldi fail Css fail. Siis saad ära linkida. Vaata, vaata seda faili. Kui mingi eraldi Failid, script i failid. Põhimõtteliselt siis progemisosa, nagu eraldatud. Samamoodi neid saad linkida,
Õpetaja: Ee, ja nii edasi. Ja igast muid asju saab ka seal Teha stiili asju, kõike. Ee, aga ainuke asi. Jah, Ainuke nähtav asi on Seal siis on Niukene element.
Õpetaja: Kui me rääkisime, et meil on see head osa päis. Siis ülejäänud osa on Body. Väga hea. Ee, mis sinna Bodysse saab siis põhimõtteliselt ee, kirjutada ja teha
Õpetaja: kogu sisu Kogu nähtav osa on seal
Õpetaja: Ee, kogu nähtav osa on siis selles ee food I osas. Põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: nüüd, kui me räägime sellest süntaksist ee Ja Html struktuurist. Siis ta koosneb mingitest asjadest. Mis asjadest ta koosneb?
Õpetaja: Kuidas komponendid? Ev komponente ei ole midagi muud Võtan veel. Pakkuge midagi, millest ta koosneb.
Õpetaja: Me räägime nüüd juba. Noh, enamvähem siis sündaksist. Põhimõtteliselt kirjaviisist. Et
Õpetaja: Kuidas, meil on seal asjad, mille abil meil on seal Asjad Nagu ära defineeritud Tag Id.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee. Kui nüüd rääkida tag idest, siis need on laias laastus kahte liiki, mis ma siin võiks Mõelda
Õpetaja: ise turguvad. Ja.
Õpetaja: Jah, okei, okei, Ee. Skoobiga ilma. Põhimõtteliselt, aga võibolla lihtsam on siis nagu maamehe maa maamehe maainimese, Ma ei teagi Maamehe ee. Moodi Öelda lihtsalt, et meil on ühe tagiga.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis ongi nagu isesulguvad. Ja siis meil on kahe tagiga kus on siis Defineeritud Ee, konkreetselt alguse ja lõpp.
Õpetaja: Mis asjad need asjad, mis need on üldse? Kuidas need? On? Vaata, kui ma seal mingi ma ütlen, Mul on input
Õpetaja: või? Mul on mingi. Ee, ütleme siis. Mul on mingi heeder, Aga seal on nüüd sõna juures, et kuidas ma saan öelda, mis mis? Mille nad moodustavad. Mis see ühik on?
Õpetaja: Oli
Õpetaja: Konteiner on mõttes, võibolla, onju? Aga tegelikult, me tahame siin tehniliselt ee kasutada Niukest terminit nagu element. Need on Html elemendid.
Õpetaja: Ja need siis tag idega defineeritakse. Ee, kas te oskate tuua mulle mõnda näidet Ee, siis, Ee, mõnest sellisest elemendist. Mis siis on? Isesulguv ehk ühe tagiga Lihtsalt defineeritakse.
Õpetaja: Jah, Img Pilt Näiteks sest et pildil ei ole nagu niukest skoopi. Nagu, et vot siit kuidagi hakkab tulema mingi tekst. Justkui vaata või mingi sisu, Vaata ja siis. See kuidagi lõpeb et temal on Hoopis üks teine lähenemine. Kohe räägime sellest. Ka. Mõni näide Siis mis on näiteks? Noh, enamus nad ongi.
Õpetaja: Kuidas paragrahv näiteks? Jah, et ee, Tekstilõik algab. Nurgalised sulud. Noh, võtsin selle küsimuse ära. Kuidas Siis kirjapildis on? Kuidas saab kirjapildis Tag E ja siis koodis defineerida, on need
Õpetaja: Mitte nurksulud. Vaata, need oleks lihtsalt. Neil on lausa kant. Sulud nurgalised sulud on põhimõtteliselt see õige terminoloogia ehk Siis need
Õpetaja: need kes räägivad, Sokk hoppet, Ee, Okei,
Õpetaja: et Html elementideks, siis kutsutakse neid ee kõiki neid asju, mida me eile vaatasime. Seda ma kohe alguses ütlesin ka, et et ee, seal täna nagu põhimõtteliselt õpime Html elemente, et mis erinevad elemendid on seal Ee, html is ee. Ära defineeritud.
Õpetaja: Ee, okei, Ee, kui enamus elemendid on mingi konkreetse missiooni ja eesmärgi ja välimusega, siis on üks. Vaatame element. Neil ei ole välimust, millest ma räägin.
Õpetaja: Div, Mis see div Põhimõtteliselt teed?
Õpetaja: Sa paigutad üksteise sisse. Asju on ju nagu mõtteliselt või struktuuriliselt
Õpetaja: ee, ja siis tema tegelikult selles mõttes ei ole otseselt niiöelda nähtav element, aga saad väga vabalt teha ta nähtavaks elemendiks. Kui tahad.
Õpetaja: Kaks divi, ütled, et kogu see sisu on, Ee, ma ei tea. Sisu Background on. Ee, aqua vana hea. Ee, siis Nii on,
Õpetaja: et selles, mõttes, et, ee, siis kui kuskil on Mingisugune kast. Mingisuguse pikkusega. Siis kuidagi selle Tv moodustab. Ja kui sa ütled sellele tiivi le näiteks, et sa ole sina nagu helesinist värvi, Siis see nii on. Vaata, on ju siis järsku Tv muutub nähtavaks.
Õpetaja: Tahad ütle, et pane mulle see vilkuvad mingi vilkuva borderi ümber. Noh, Vanasti, jah. Tehti niukseid, Koledaid asju, onju? Mäletate neid? Esimesi veebilehti
Õpetaja: Olid niuksed väga Noh, värvide valik. Varjundid
Õpetaja: oli piiratud kuidagi, ja siis alati oli ee inimestel mõte. Vaata, et kui ma panen sinna nagu need vähesed võimalused, mis sealt kuidagi ise liikuma panna ja vilkuma mingisugused ääred Ja veel muusika ka veel taha.
Õpetaja: Siis on äge veebileht. Siit tulevad kõik Täna ei tahaks küll minna.
Õpetaja: Vot nii, okei, aga, ee, jah, Ma Mõtlen, kas mul vaatameili kohta veel midagi pähe? Tulge, et on. Hetkel vist mitte. Ee, Kütame. Siis a. Ei. Ole, üks tähtsais on, ikka rääkimata veel
Õpetaja: mõnel mõni Ee, niiöelda mõn, mõni tüüp, Mõned tüüpi. Aa, Html. Elemendid võtavad mingisuguseid sisendeid
Õpetaja: Kuidas me neid saame anda. Ja Kuidas neid asju kutsutakse?
Õpetaja: Okei, kuidas
Õpetaja: atribuudid Ja, ee, nüüd süntaksi mõttes on siis lihtsalt kokku lepitud nimed tegelikult tehnoloogiliselt nagu paika pandud, on ju, et kui mäletad. Meil oli seal näiteks kastikene, et. Noh, seal, varjundiga tekst, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, siis ongi see, et sa kirjutad sõna, paned võõrdusmärgi ja paned jutumärgid ja siis saad panna näiteks mingi teksti, Näete?
Õpetaja: Noh, see oli mingi Kui sa tahad kasutada näiteks image ee, image, Niiöelda elementi, siis. Ee, päriselt siis öelda? Jah, siin on pilt, onju? Aga Kus see pilt tuleb,
Õpetaja: Siis tema on Attribuut. Source Samamoodi võrdub Ee, siis on jälle need. Ee, jutumärgid.
Õpetaja: Ja. Ja siis see saab siis olla kas rada kuskile failile, mis on meil endal serveris, või Siis link kuhugi teise serverisse. Kus see pilt on,
Õpetaja: et jällegi autoripuua? Teid Nii, okei, nüüd sain küll. Enamvähem öeldud, mis tahtsin.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Esimene Asi, mis me täna teeme,
Õpetaja: on see, et me nüüd õpime kõik koos kuidas saada Rainile kiiret järgi,
Õpetaja: Mis ma selle all mõtlen, on See, et, ee, meil ei ole aega oodata. Ära absoluutselt. Ee. Iga inimese mingisugust ee, taipimist Okei, taipimist. Ta veel jaksab ära oodata, aga Siis, kui hakkavad juhtuma süntaksid vead.
Õpetaja: Mis see tähendab, süütakse. Vead tähendab seda, et kogemata kustutad ühe täägi lõputägi ära mingi. Näiteks, läheb kaduma Või lihtsalt mingi nurgeline sulg. Läheb kuskilt nagu kellegil eliiti. Või On seal midagi. Palju. Midagi on seal rohkem. Midagi on vähem sellisel kujul, Et asjad on katki
Õpetaja: ja tulevad errorid. Me ei ole sellel kursusel, et õppida seda. Vaata, et kus ajada taga mingisugust puuduolevad sümbolit, sest et sellel ei ole väärtust väärtust on see, kui me käime läbi kõik need teemad ja kõik need tehnoloogilised kontseptsioonid see on väärtus
Õpetaja: oma Nurgaga. Sa sulgusid asju saate oma töödest taga ajada küll. Ja küll. Aja jooksul õpite kirjutama. Muidugi koodi ka niimoodi, et ee, tegelikult ei Teki väga nagu neid süntakse probleeme.
Õpetaja: Ütleme, kui kogenud arendaja. Siis Nagu väga naljalt ikka ei juhtu seda et kogemata kustutad mingisuguse sümboli ära. Ee, Noh, hooletusest põhimõtteliselt. Noh, hooletusi.
Õpetaja: Aga see lihtsalt, kui kasutad pidevalt seda tööriista ka, kes saab seal korda teha? Võibolla
Õpetaja: ee või Cloud, Õigemini pigem ütleks siin
Õpetaja: seda niikuinii vähem ma arvan. Aga. Aga mõte on see, et kui kellegil läheb midagi katki ja tahab saada Rainile järgi. Ja see hakkab juhtuma niikuinii, Eriti sellel kursusel. Nüüd, kuna ma hakkan tegema ka päris palju asju, siis niiöelda Cloudiga. Vahepeal
Õpetaja: me kõik Vaatame, siis te tahate pärast seda ka saada Endale onju, et me ei hakka Kõik siin. Tulevad erinevad tulemused. Jäämegi ootama. Internet on ka Võibolla koomam. Me ei päris. Seda Ma ei usu,
Õpetaja: saate aru. Ee, teil on vaja jõuda ühel või teisel hetkel mulle järgi, siis reegel Ja kokkulepe on väga lihtne. Kui keegi hüüab klassist Rain T. Üks Commit,
Õpetaja: siis see minu jaoks tähendab seda. Vaata et keegi tahab jõuda mulle nagu järgi.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd me teeme selle protsessi läbi, et te saaksite aru, kuidas saab väga, väga kiirelt. Rainile järgi siin on mõned Sammud, mida on vaja meeles hoida.
Õpetaja: See peamine asi on see, et teil ei saa olla mingisuguseid lahtiseid muudatusi, mis ma võin, mis ma Ütlen, mis ma mõtlen sellele, mis te arvate, kui ma ütlen, et teil ei saa olla lahtiseid muudatusi,
Õpetaja: mis ma selle mõtlen, Muudatusi Changes Need nooled ei saa.
Õpetaja: No, nooled on teine asi. Sellepärast, et nooled ei tähista seda, et sul on midagi mingeid lahtiseid muudatusi Lahtised muudatused on see, kui sa kirjutad nagu mingisuguse mõne rea koodi või väitad entrit või Kas üks tähemärk kuskil koodis muutub,
Õpetaja: siis ta ei ole Ära kommititud. Aga Kit jälgib teda juba. Ammu, Vaata, onju? Või Noh, kui sellest hetkest Teate, see Kit, Ee, see kittöriist tööriist, sealt ülevalt, Vasakult teine
Õpetaja: sealt alt on. Näetakse ka mingeid lahtiseid muudatusi.
Õpetaja: Vot siin on probleem. Siin on probleem alati üldse, kui te kunagi vahetate haru, Sest et sellega see lõpuks päädib.
Õpetaja: Teil on vana haru. Ma ütlen, see lahendus kuidas mulle järgi päädib sellega, et te teete haruvahetuse haruvahetusega, on Selline pull lugu. Vaata, et ee, selles mõttes, et
Õpetaja: need ee, muudatused, mis sa oled kuskil klõbistanud. Oletame, et oled kasvõi oma haru peal mingi. Noh, ütleme Artur lihtsalt, onju? Artur klõbistab koodi oma haru peal. Nii, ja nüüd ta tahaks minna näiteks masteri peale või minna, siis uue haru peale. Mis minult ta näiteks niiöelda võtab, onju?
Õpetaja: Siis on niimoodi, et need muudatused, mis on lahti, ei ole kuhugi harusse Ära kommititud. Mis? Nad hakkavad nüüd tegema, on see, et nad hakkavad kaasa rändama.
Õpetaja: Sa ei ole öelnud. Ne ei kuulu kuhugi See, et Sa kirjutasid koodi sinna faili sellisel ajal, kus sul oli Näiteks Artur oli oma haru peal. Vaata, see ei tähenda Mitte midagi. See ei Ole seotud.
Õpetaja: Mis? Sest et see hetk, kui et. Noh, võtan mingi haru ette, kirjutan koodi, mõtleks justkui nagu tavainimesena, et see on nüüd seotud selle haruga. Ja kui ma lähen siit ära, siis see kuidagi jääb sinna. Ja see ei ole niimoodi.
Õpetaja: See ei ole niimoodi Need Muutused ei kuulu mitte kuhugi enne kui teed mille comeiti
Õpetaja: Nii, Ja nüüd. Kui sa vahetad haru,
Õpetaja: siis võib juhtuda see, et esiteks ei Tulegi mingit konflikti. Aga see on mingisugune vana aplaust. Vaata, mis sa tegid. Rändab sinuga teadmatult kaasas. Teine variant on see, et sa võtad uue haru. Seal on mingisugused teistsugused muudatused kui ennem. Ja saa aru, et kuule nüüd on mingi probleem. Vaata, et ta ta tatsub segadusse Tulevad mingisugused jamad probleemid.
Õpetaja: Kuidas me seda väldime, on, see, et kõige esimese asjana, kui te tahate minule järgi tulla, on see, et te Lasete enda. Te lähete lihtsalt sinna kommit. Tööriista sinna kommit. Tööriista peale.
Õpetaja: Kõik failid, mitte tik. Iga tikkimine on ainult kommitimise jaoks, et mille Sina ära commit Id, vaid selekteerid. Mis tähendab, selekteerid? Noh, teed siniseks, on ju Control all või valid ükshaaval. Vahet pole, kuidas
Õpetaja: lõpptulemus on See, et sa valid kõik need failid Ja sul üleval on Niukene nupukene. Nagu Roll Back Roll Back on see, et need failid lihtsalt Nagu keera tagasi
Õpetaja: viimase hetkeni. Kui need olid salvestatud, siis see eeltöö on tehtud. Teil ei ole midagi niiöelda lahtist.
Õpetaja: Kas te niikuinii tulete Minule järgi. Te Niikuinii võtate kõik, mis minul on Ülisavi, Mis teil seal pooleli on? Miks te üldse tahate ka järgi tulla Ongi see, et Teil on midagi katki. Lihtsalt teil midagi katki. Te tahate järgi tulla, et saaks Roniga edasi teha? Järgmist asju, siis mõte ongi ju See, et vaata mul ülisavi, mis seal on. See haru ja kõik, mis sa siiamaani tegid? Läheb niikuinii prügikasti.
Õpetaja: Nii kui ta mängime selle läbi. Ee, ma teen Screenshare I ka.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ma näitan, kuidas me teeme seda hästi efektiivselt, nagu selles mõttes hästi efektiivselt vahetama projekti
Õpetaja: Kogu aeg on need ee, Zoomi ühesugused menüüd ja asjad mul ees.
Õpetaja: Nii kui mina tulen praegu siia, mis mul Changes näitab mitte midagi,
Õpetaja: Aga kujutame, et on. Noh, näete, ma teen kloudi katki. Palun väga, mis ma tegin? Siin on Selecti tag.
Õpetaja: Näed, mida ei tohiks teha, No seda ei tohiks ära kustutada.
Õpetaja: Praegult ei ole. Ei ole midagi katki. Kui ma võtan selle asja ära, siis asi on katki, näete Seda punast
Õpetaja: sõidavad. Kuskil on üks herror.
Õpetaja: Ta Vahel oskab enamvähem aimata, kus see on. Aga tegelikult tal on pigem raske. Siin Frontis on Palju Palju keerulisem süntaks vigu leida. Javas on õnneks asi lihtsam
Õpetaja: seal. Ma õpetan, kuidas nad kuradi loogilise sulge asju nagu üles leida, et Kus nagunii on läinud. Seal on üks selline süsteemne, niiöelda lähenemine, mis on kuidagi tüütu protsess. Aga sa jõuad alati see lõpuks selleni, vaata, Et mis kuradi kohas sul mingi loogiline Sulg.
Õpetaja: Loogiline sulg. Ma mõtlen loomult seda. Bolšo. Ärge tehke talle kunagi elus häbi.
Õpetaja: Need siin ei ole loogilised sulud. Nendes ei ole mitte midagi loogilist.
Õpetaja: Nad on loogilised, Vildakad.
Õpetaja: Ma alati kutsusin neid loogilisteks sulgudeks. Ma ei tea, kui kaua Need ei ole loogilised sulgud.
Õpetaja: Nad on
Õpetaja: nii, et selles mõttes nagu väga piinlik oleks lihtsalt noh, kohe näed ära, et on mingi, Vaata, Et nagu
Õpetaja: vana progeja, nagu kõrv, kuuleks kohe ära, et ütleb loogiliselt. Sulub, sest et mu õpilased kogu aeg ütlevad, Sellepärast ma praegu stress On seda väga palju,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, ärge öelge, Ma ise ütlen ka kogemata vahel ikkagi loo loogiliselt Suled tuleb kuidagi üle huulte, et ee, Jaavas on? Noh, Niukene asi väga lihtne juhtuma. Kuidas Sul on neid seal väga palju
Õpetaja: Ja kujutage ette. Vaata, et neid on eelkõige ju tegelikult Reas.
Õpetaja: Kuskil. Nagu selles mõttes Niimoodi Tublid ei ka.
Õpetaja: Ma ei saa praegu teha. Noh, Põhimõtteliselt nad. Kujutage ette, et nad tulevad niimoodi Kuskil riburada pidi seal all.
Õpetaja: Noh, midagi niimoodi, näiteks.
Õpetaja: Noh, üks läheb kuidagi siit kaduma. Läheb ülevalt kaduma
Õpetaja: Palju jama. Nüüd ee, siis kuidas Rainile järgi tulla, on see, et te tulete lihtsalt siia.
Õpetaja: Teete siniseks. See ei tähenda siin mitte midagi. Vaata, kui ma ütlen, siis tuleb Aken lahti. Mida Okei, praegult oli? Teen ruttu veel midagi. Äkki midagi ei muutunud. Ee, ma kahtlen selles.
Õpetaja: Ma teen paar muutust, Ma vaatan, Sest ühe failiga ei tule see välja. Nii,
Õpetaja: mul on valitud. Kõik nad siin on. Tegelikult ülevalt. On kataloog valitud. Võibolla see midagi muudab.
Õpetaja: Mitu faili on siit valitud?
Õpetaja: Ei ole.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei. Selles mõttes, et tikid on ikkagi siin. Ma Vaatan kui roll back tuleb, mina arvan, et ta roll Back Ib. Ainult selle faili, mis on sinine. Nii vanasti oli vähemalt
Õpetaja: mõlemad.
Õpetaja: Aga ma vaatan korra, kas, ee, ma nagu mäletaks justkui. Ja vaata, kui. Kui ma panen isegi siia peale. Aga vot see on highlight Id, Ma pakun, et ma ennem olin kataloogi peal, nagu onju? Ma pakun, et nüüd ei ole.
Õpetaja: Näe, noh, vot hoopis niimoodi, tuleb et et selles mõttes, et, ee, teda ei huvitagi tegelikult need tikid siin üldse Teda huvitab lihtsalt see, et kas see on Highlight It? Kui see on Highlight itud, siis tema jaoks on kõik
Õpetaja: aga siin, jah. Siin on nagu nüüd tekitatud. Siin see nüüd juba töötab.
Õpetaja: Et nagu. Mida sa tahad Rolback ida? No selles eelmises tegelikult Ei, ole. Lihtsalt mäletage seda, et tehke see siniseks. Sellest on siin Ülisavi on? Ei, ole, no mängime läbi, Vaata, et ma mitte Midagi Ei, vajuta. Vaatan seda, vaitan seda. Kõik läheb minema.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd. O, nüüd on nagu need muudatused. Ei hakka rändama.
Õpetaja: Nüüd põhimõtteliselt ma saaks minna Masteri peale ja neid. Noh, pole.
Õpetaja: Aga Kui need muudatused on niiöelda. Ma korra teen, tagasi, võtan midagi, ee, mis on nagu kindlalt olemas. Noh, ma ei tea. Siis ma ei tea, mis asi see siin on. Isegi Ei, huvita, kui mul praegu on see siin kaasas. Näete,
Õpetaja: kui ma nüüd hakkan Ee, niiöelda minema. Peale. Ee, ta võibolla hoiatab mind ja pakub Smart checkout I või force, seda aga Ta võib ka täitsa vabalt lihtsalt minna sinna.
Õpetaja: Noh, läksime edukalt. Masteri peale. Läksime On see. See muudatus tuli kaasa, Kas ma seda tahan
Õpetaja: Kas seda, kas ma seda tahan? Vot siit siit tulevadki? Igasugused jamad.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et kui sul on palju just muudatusi asju, sa pärast ei Pane tähele lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Sa ei jaksa jälgida kõike Seal varem või hiljem juhtub. Siis ongi nagu, see, et iga kord kui sa, hakkad haru vahetama, Siis mõtle, kui sa soovidki. Vaata, näiteks täiesti tavaline asi, et kogemata hakkad Masteris tegema. Tööd.
Õpetaja: Uut haru pole teinud, Sul on mingisugune tuhat muudatust siin juba vaata, onju? Ja hakkad sa vaikselt kommitima ja avastad. Kurat, kui mitmes hetkel. Alati peab haru vaatama,
Õpetaja: Ee, eriti push Imisel peab kohe kindlasti vaatama, sest et võib, juhtuda, et sa lähed kellegi teise arenduse harusse korra üldse. Võib ka seda juhtuda. Igasuguseid asju Võib juhtuda kogemata. Ja see on nii vastik. Kui sa lähed, lükkad pilve kuskile teise harusse Mingisuguse staffi. Ja siis ma ütlen, aga mida Kurat, nüüd ta teab, et ma olen loll
Õpetaja: või tähelepanuuttav.
Õpetaja: Hoolimatu Vahet pole, kuidas ta mõtleb Midagi positiivset. Pole, et Bushi Ajal kohe kindlasti, Aga tegelikult juba tuleks. Niisugusel Hetkel Võib olla niimoodi Masterist alustasin tööd
Õpetaja: ja. Oih kurat, võtaks. Ee,
Õpetaja: ei teinudki aru. Praegu pole midagi hullu, Ma saan siit Masterist lihtsalt öelda. Vaata, New Branch.
Õpetaja: Ee, mida iganes onju?
Õpetaja: Ja ta võtab nüüd, ta läheb sinna uue haaru peale ja Muudatused lähevad kaasa. Noh, nüüd on nagu arendusharu, et on julgenis. Hetkel Olge nagu pigem tähelepanelikud.
Õpetaja: Kui te kogu aeg töötad ühes samas haarus, Siis sa. Sul ei ole vaja seda tähelepanu. Aga kui juba natukene žongleerid selle ise, nagu vahel seda on, ka seda juhtub igal juhul sa teed. Sa teed kogemata. Ee, sul on ühe arenduse taask lahti. Aa, Sa mässad mingi teisega. Siis Sa vahetad ära. Sul on sama Koodibaas sama projekt.
Õpetaja: Sa hakkad tegema oma lahendust
Õpetaja: ja siis. Aa. Sul on kogemata valeharu. Vaata, et üks haru on see, et tee nagu Mingisugune aken siia või mingi kastikene. Teine on hoopis kuskil kastika vaja mujalt teise kohta teha. Ja sa kogemata Lihtsalt teed selle lahenduse ära,
Õpetaja: Aga sul on vale vale haru seal ja sa komitid enda ühe teise projekt. Nagu teise arenduse taaski Vaata, nagu hoopis teise arenduse töö On see kuidagi arusaadav. Keeruline On see ka et on aeg rääkida, et kaks erinevat taaski
Õpetaja: ja teed seda tööd, aga selle sa arvad, Sa komitid. Nagu, ee, ikka juhtub,
Õpetaja: saab roll back. Ida saab alati, et kui oligi kogemata. Vaata, et nad siis saavad lihtsalt niimoodi ja Nii on?
Õpetaja: Kas sellest on abi, kui sa oled mingi loll, Aga ütled, et tegid kogemata?
Õpetaja: Ei, eks sa ikka. Käid vä? Inimesed ikka Üritavad kuidagi oma rumalust kuidagi välja vabandada. Vaata, et,
Õpetaja: ee. Ei, No selles mõttes, et ega, Noh, kui sa oled eriti veel alustanud, see Arendaja kedagi ei huvita.
Õpetaja: Saab parandada. Noh, kuidas saab näiteks parandada? Või kui on juba pussitatud pilve
Õpetaja: Davai, ma näitan selle ka, ma võin selle ka ära teha. Vaata on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, ma push an selle pilve Ära ka vaata, et siis oleks ta täitsa see olemas mingi Aa, mis iganes. Nagunii prügihästi kaob. Ma ütlen selles mõttes, te saate ka õppimise käigus nii mugavalt ennast tunda, saate alati võtta harusid, teha midagi. Ja mis te lõpuks teete?
Õpetaja: Kustutate selle haru lihtsalt ära. Nagu vaata, on ju? Noh, mässata. Ee, ma siis praegu teen eba, ma Teen niukse asja. Et Ee, mingi muudatus, mida ma ei soovi.
Õpetaja: Ee, selle muudatus ongi kommentaarina See panen ei soovi tegin kaka noh, midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Nii, Ja kui kui ma nüüd selle ära commitin. No ma panen meelega selle nime Praegu tegin kaka. Vaata, siis on nagu Ee, Ja push in selle ära.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma näitan, kuidas on kõige kindlam. Ma teen veel ühe muudatuse. Ee, ma panen siin veel neid natukene juurde.
Õpetaja: Tegin kaka kaks. Ma lihtsalt tahan näidata nagu rohkem kui mitte.
Õpetaja: Noh, Võibolla, võtan veel mingisuguse teise faili üldse. Näiteks, ma ei tea, Kustutan mingid tähtsad asjad ära.
Õpetaja: Ülisavi kontroll, K.
Õpetaja: Noh, niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Kui mitte ainult poiss, et nüüd mul vastab tõele, et nüüd on juba, noh, Ma võisin oma arvutis need kommit Id teha. Aga Push, Id ju korraga. Vaata ja läheb põmm. Mingi,
Õpetaja: et sellega, on niimoodi. Ka, vaata Ma rääkisin, et hea on kogu aeg. Push Ida, Vaata aga, noh, mingi hulluks ei pea minema. Vaata, kui ma päeval ikkagi teen seal Mingi paar komit I ma väga ikkagi ei muretse. Vaata, et kohvitass läheb. Peale. Vaata, on ju Muidugi, Parem On alati Push Ida, Alati On parem pushida. Ee,
Õpetaja: eriti kui sa sa teed seda oma arenduse Harus saate aru. Oma arendusharust teed ülisavi nagu mis sa teed seal Tee tuhat, kui mitte ka kui vaja.
Õpetaja: See on sinu arenduse aru. Vaata selleks hetkeks, Kui see läheb Sinna Masterisse, teeme sellest ühe komiti Ja ongi sa ja naera. Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, oskavad soovile ja vajadusele, kuidas kuskil kokkulepped on? Ma lükkan selle ära Oletame, et nüüd ee Nüüd Kui minna vaatama sellest. Ee, kit I. Niiöelda vabandust sellest konsol. Kuidas nad kutsuvad seda üldse. See on Kit ja see, on, vaata, Ma kutsun seda kuidagi. Kutsun ma seda logiks.
Õpetaja: Ee, et kui te logisse tulla, vaatame, siis. Remote Is on praegult Need kolm ee läinud. On
Õpetaja: nii, kui ma tahaksin neid Nüüd ta ee, selles mõttes ära kaotada. Jah, siin on igasuguseid variante. On mingisuguseid muid tegevusi Kuidas seda asja tegeleda. Aga kuidas on? Kõige kõige varem teha? On see, et sa teed ekstra Comiti Me teeme Committee juurde, kus me parandame selle asja ära. Nüüd,
Õpetaja: mida me tahame, teha. Et Kujutage ette, et teil on mingi siin kakskümmend kolmkümmend faili muudetud igast erinevaid rindu, Never ise seda ei suuda Mõni on nagu. Kui sul on mingi väike muudatus. Sa oskad ka ise selle nagu tagurpidi nagu lihtsalt ära teha vaata, et ma lisasin selle. Ma kustutan ära. Näiteks, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga siin oleks nagu see, et mina ei jaksa jälgida, et näed, siin oli indeksis. Midagi. No siin ka veel indeksis. Siin juba. Kujutage ette, et rohkem faile on.
Õpetaja: Siis. Noh, minul oli kunagi üks Ee, niuke mentor Muidugi, Ee, nagu õpetas selle triki. Ja ma sain ise ükskord näidata seda mingi ülikogend seenorile. Ta oli mingi karpajahti, mis asja, nagu ma ei tahtnud lihtsalt teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, siit saab neid. Kui mitte niimoodi niimoodi valida Ka Vaata, kui oled kontrollid peal, saad ka mitu valida.
Õpetaja: Siis saab teha niukse asja nagu kui teeb parema klõpsu
Õpetaja: Vaata siin lükke. On See Great Patch.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt Nüüd Ee, salvestab kõik muudatused muudatused, mis nende Komitega on tehtud. See on nagu vaikimisi, Mis ta teeb. Näiteks, ma tegin kogemata. Kujutamegi ette. Ma tegin kogemata. Need Kolm Kolm komitee tegin Valesse harusse
Õpetaja: Aga mul läks vale. See arendusarvusse. Täpselt see Case, mis me räägime? Ja nüüd on,
Õpetaja: ee, et nüüd on nagu see, et Okei, siit. Ma tahan neid ära kustutada, Aga kuskile mujale ma neid ju soovin. Mingi rämedalt. Tegin tööd, Tegin mingi lahenduse, läks lihtsalt valesse Harusse,
Õpetaja: Siis ma saan siin öelda, et. Kuule, need muudatused, mis ma tegin. Ole nii nunnu. Salvestan need kui näiteks failina
Õpetaja: Noh, ma võin ka failina teha. Ee, teeme failina kuskile.
Õpetaja: Ma ei päris koodibaasi ei paneks. Ta paneks ta praegu kuskile mujale. Näiteks siia. Samma grupp neljakümne. Alla Tegin. Kaka. Kolm, kaka, kaks. Kakach
Õpetaja: On ju see Praegult. Oleks niimoodi, et see fail on nüüd olemas. Kui usu ka Explorer is saad vaadata, on Niukene Special Patch File, mida oskab toimetada. Ma praegu saaks. Kuskile teise arusse minna. Noh Saangi minna? Ma Lähen näiteks sellest tagasi selle õpetaja peale.
Õpetaja: Panen selle õpetaja peale.
Õpetaja: Nii ma saaks praegult nüüd tulla ja öelda. Kit Pats, Apply Patch.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan otsin ülesse Selle faili kolm muudatust teeb siin ka. Ta Ütleb, et näed. Tahan muuta midagi kustutada. Ee, ja kit. Ee, indeksist. Tahan lisada nagu need Read on nii täpselt, mis tegin.
Õpetaja: No see on mingi väike Merch konflikt ka. Mida saaks lahendada? Ma saaksin need kommit Id nüüd siin ära mängida ja need muutuvad. Noh, siin on väikene,
Õpetaja: Ee, konflikti värk, Mida me praegu ei seleta ütleme, et võtame lihtsalt. Ee, accept, right, Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: põhimõte on see, et nüüd on need muudatused mul siin olemas.
Õpetaja: Sellest ma tahaks üldse närvar all. Pack Ida need
Õpetaja: nii saad endast lahti.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga kuidas me nüüd soovime seda asja teha? Ma lähen tagasi selle A peale ja nüüd näitan kuidas seda, korda teha. Me praegu tegime pätsi. Nagu selles mõttes, et kui ma tahaks teha neid samme, neid muudatusi
Õpetaja: ja ma sooviks kuskil mujal, ma soovin, ma Olen ka niimoodi teinud, et ee, mul on lahtised muudatused Ja ma teen nendest lahtisest muudatusest niukse eraldi faili ja panen kuskil turvaliselt ära
Õpetaja: Et, Ee, ma proovisin mingisuguse variandi. Ee, leidsin mingisuguse lahenduse, näiteks. Aga mulle hästi. Ei meeldi see. Ma tahan puhtalt. Lähed proovida uuesti alustada, Aga ma tahan, et mul see vana variant jääb alles, et kui uue variandiga midagi välja ei tule, näiteks,
Õpetaja: et ma saan siis teha? Noh, ma tahan seda tehtud tööd võibolla kasutada, aga ma ei tea pärast täna. Vaata, kas ikkagi tahan, onju? Nii? Aga nüüd me vaatame Seda, et te saate valida põhimõtteliselt need samad kolm ee faili. Näete, mis siin aas on? Teen Parema klõpsu. Vajutan,
Õpetaja: aga Vaadake nüüd, siin on Selline nupp, nagu see on. Siis keera tagurpidi.
Õpetaja: Mis iganes. Muudatused siin just tehti, et siit kustuta rida siia lisarida, siis tema ütles Reverse Patch I, et siia lisarida ja siit kustuta Rida, saate aru.
Õpetaja: Ja mõnus asi on see, et ma, kui ma kohe kavatsen, seda ka kasutada. Mul ei ole isegi mõtet seda kuhugi failile salvestada.
Õpetaja: Mis see tähendab,
Õpetaja: mällu? See on see kui kopid mingit teksti, vaata, kuhu ta, mis on? Teate küll, see on see, ee, täpselt. Inimesed ikka käivad. Vaata, on see väikene Niukene See paberi alus. Vaata ja siis On mingid dokumendid peas.
Õpetaja: Pane dokumendid korra siia. Saad kohe kuskil kasutada. Onju, et see on see mõte. Pane Need Copy to Clipboard reverse Patch, see on hästi tähtis.
Õpetaja: Nii, no ma tulen siia. Kit I tööriistade alla. Vaatan, kus on Patch? Valikud. Apply Patch From.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd Ta põhimõtteliselt ütleb, et. Kuule, näed, siin on need kommit. Id.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on niimoodi. Kui me nüüd vaatame, siis on just vastupidi vaata,
Õpetaja: et, Ee, mida ta tahab teha,
Õpetaja: et on see, et ei ole, siin. Infot, on nii?
Õpetaja: Tema tahab lisada.
Õpetaja: See on see Kitty Gnorist, mis Me ennem ära kustutasin täpselt tagurpidi. Okei, vaatame seda teist ka. Ee, nüüd peaks olema see, et ta peaks ära kustutama. Vaata, Tegin kaka, Üks, kaks ja kolm onju. Mis iganes siin olid, et hetkel on praegult see meil siin olemas
Õpetaja: saate mõttest aru, kes ei saa.
Õpetaja: Noh, Sa vaatad? Ei saa.
Õpetaja: Okei, ma räägin uuesti.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma panen kinni praegu. Ma panen Ee, ta praegult korra. Kõik Ee, mis asi ta siin näitab.
Õpetaja: Oota, kikoori. Sa oled sa maha?
Õpetaja: Okei, hakkame uuesti pihta. Vaata, onju Kuidas tulid need muudatused? Kui ma teen I lahti, siis See muutub visuaalseks. Vastab tõele, et ma Just täna praegult tegin. Need muudatused
Õpetaja: on ju ma. Te. Ma tegin konkreetselt need muudatused. Tegin nende Kahe komitiga.
Õpetaja: Kui ma klik klikin lahti vaatan, siis kõigepealt. Ma tegin ühe rea. Tegin kaka. Siis ma tegin järgmise kommiti, kus ma lisasin need juurde. Ja täna. Me oleme praegu siis sellises seisus Selles ee, indeksfaili mõttes. Vaata, oleme niimoodi, et nad on kõik siin, vastab tõele,
Õpetaja: Aga Noh, see viimane asi oli see, et nüüd kittignooris oli kogu see info. Vaata, mingi asjad. Hetkeseisus on nagu, et ei ole midagi, Ma teen selle Faili. Lahti. Korra
Õpetaja: teen kitignoori lahti. Peaaegu Tühi on. See on ju
Õpetaja: kolme. Ma tegin kolm committee, kus ma muutsin kahte faili
Õpetaja: Siia tulid need kommentaari Read. Siit kustus midagi ära. Nii, Ja mida mina teen? Nüüd on see, et ma selektin samamoodi, Vaata, et Hei, ma soovin midagi nende kommittidega Nagu teha.
Õpetaja: Ma valin parema klipiga ee vaikimisi. Lihtsalt teeb faili. Või Võtab mällu, et kui et tee, Need muudatused.
Õpetaja: Tee siuksed, muudatused. Ma võin mingi kuhugi teise arusse minna ja seal läheb laida ja ta teeb täpselt need samad asjad, nii
Õpetaja: Aga mina nagu siit valin. Esiteks, et et ära. Me ei hakka mingit faili tegema. Nagu me esimesel korral tegime,
Õpetaja: Tegime vaata faili Patchfili vanasti Mul oli see eraldi kaust. Oli Patches. Ee, enam ei ole seda kasutanud.
Õpetaja: Nii mina ütlen, et jäta meelde, aga siin me ütleme, Vaata, et ära salvesta mulle nüüd siia meelde, et vaata, et kuidas ta lisab
Õpetaja: neid andmeid vaid hoopis tagurpidi.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis hoopis, et kuskil on niuksed, read ja need tuleb ära kustutada.
Õpetaja: Teised saavad aru.
Õpetaja: Jah, okei, ee. Saad veel mõelda? Saame arutada ka vahetunnis, aga lähme edasi, See ongi see trikk. Vaata, et mul mul. Praegu on See seis.
Õpetaja: See juhtus Ee, nende kahe kommitiga.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd ma tegin, nagu Ma Tean ainult nendest. Teeme siis kordamöö Teeme kordamööda. Vaata, et ärme seda kittig noori üldse tegele. Tegin ju need muudatused vastas Tõele. Kogemata tegid Kaka kahega
Õpetaja: tegid selle kaka? Noh, ühega. Sa ei oska öelda
Õpetaja: nii kui mina praegu. Ee, teeme Step by step, Milline see esimene rida siin on.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlen, et kaks mõtlen kaks tükki kooriaga. Nii, on lihtsam. Vaata, et kui ma praegult võtan Ee lihtsalt copy,
Õpetaja: Ee, Vabandust, Greatch.
Õpetaja: Tubli, Board ja Reverse Patch.
Õpetaja: Siis ta saab aru et vaata, et
Õpetaja: mis iganes muudatused siin toimus, siis ta enda peas peab mõtlema nüüd tagurpidi, ma ütlen. Okei,
Õpetaja: ma tulen eraldi niiöelda tööriista juurde, et. Kuule, aga ma panen need
Õpetaja: nüüd. Ta näeb, et mul on kaks Nihukest, millel on niuksed. Kommentid, on ju Ja tema ütleb. Vaata, et niipea kui ma vajutan. Nüüd, Okei, mis juhtub, on see ma panen siia lähedale niimoodi,
Õpetaja: niipea kui ma vajutan. Okei, mis juhtub nende ridadega ja kustuvad ära?
Õpetaja: Põmm taastas selle olukorra, nagu selle justkui poleks olnud,
Õpetaja: Nüüd on mul see, kui me vaatame, mis me ennem tegime. Selle Kittignooriga. Kitty Knooris on igasugused tähtsad seadistused siin täiega puudu asju ma Kustutasin ära.
Õpetaja: Mustasin selle komitiga. Ära vaata selle kaka kolmega. Kui me vaatame, et mis juhtus Kaka kolmega oli Niukene Seis vasakul oli Niuke Seis Ja peale seda on Niuke seis, mis on ka
Õpetaja: praegult.
Õpetaja: Kui ma võtan nüüd siit kliki, jah, mis juhtus siis kui
Õpetaja: ja sihukestesse alusse, kus mõned näevad failid on nagu puudu.
Õpetaja: Ja siis tulevad mingid konfliktid. Ja siis on võimalik neid faile tekitada,
Õpetaja: et, noh, et vaata, Kui sul. Vaata, eeldus, on see. Vaata, et. Noh, mingid read. Vaata, muutusid mingis failis. Siis Ta eeldab seda, et selles uues kohas ongi täpselt Sama seis. Ja kui ei, ole, siis ta pakub sulle sellist akent. Vaata, et, ee, et, ee. Ütleme niimoodi et seal ennem oli Ee, niimoodi
Õpetaja: see. Need. See, kuidas sa nüüd sellest tahab tulla, on paremal pool ja keskelt. Sa siis otsustad ja ütled, et kuidas kokku jääb. Ja siis tuleb nagu mingi niukene asi.
Õpetaja: Aga praegult sellega. Kui vaadata onju, et siin ei ole midagi selle komitiga need ära kustutati,
Õpetaja: Kui ma praegu. Noh, siin ongi näiteks kustutamine. Kui ma läheks kuskile teise arusse vaata ja seal pole faili, mida kustutada, Noh, seal ei ole. Vaata, onju? Siis tuleb mingisugune jama.
Õpetaja: Aga mina tahan just tagurpidi teha. Ma ütlen, et. Hei, tee sellest kustutamisest. Ee, tee patch, aga Tee seda tagurpidi. Tee mulle see. Pane see lihtsalt mulle mällu. Ma ei hakka mind faili tekitama. Ma niikuinii teen selle pats I kohe ära.
Õpetaja: Mis tähendab Patch?
Õpetaja: Kuidas Parandus, Lappät, lapitekk, lappimine, parandus. Ja nüüd ma ütlengi Apply Patch.
Õpetaja: Tema ütleb, et kui ma praegu trikin, siis Ta näitab, ka, mis muudatused saab olema, et sinu hetkeseis on selline. Kui sa seda pätsi nüüd jooksutad, näed, siis tuleb selline kood tagasi,
Õpetaja: Ma panen siia kinni. Ma lihtsalt vajutan siin. Noh, vaatame, Hoiame silmad lahti.
Õpetaja: Üks, Kaks, kolm,
Õpetaja: tuli, tagasi. Tuli. See on see. Mõte. Noh, Nüüd vaata, nüüd on see. Vaata, me tegime nüüd kõik. Kaka tegime korda, on ju? Nüüd tuleb see. Vaata, et mis me teeme, et Ee, tegin kaka korda.
Õpetaja: Ee, selle ära. Ja nüüd see kõige tähtsam asi. Vaata, mis juhtub. Push. Ime ära.
Õpetaja: Jah, pilve jääb igavesti nagu Sinna kuskile harususse. Nüüd Ebavajalikud kommitid, millega midagi juhtus.
Õpetaja: Ja sinna tuleb veel üks komiitu otsa veel. Noh, kui me vaatame, mis see lõpp Sees on? Siis oli kaka. Tegin kaka. Tegin kaka. Tegin kaka korda. On ju
Õpetaja: väga väikse lapsega Puup me.
Õpetaja: Jah.
Õpetaja: Noh, vot miks? Miks on niimoodi, et ta iga kord. Vaata, kui sa hakkad seal üle punase joone minema pilve suunas. Ta alati küsib su käest. Üle. Oled Sa kindel
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et vaata, kas siis ei peaks olema, kui sa sellist asja küsib nagu on lenduritel? Vaata siuke Checklist, et okei, et Selline küsimus. Nüüd ma pean üle vaatama, kas ma olen selle õige raja peal? Nüüd ma pean üle vaatama, et kas mingi
Õpetaja: tahavad raha, mingid muud asjad. Ja kui ma teen checklist I enda jaoks nagu ära. Noh, see võib olla peas. See ei pea olema niimoodi, et Ma võtan kuskil mingit checklist I.
Õpetaja: Okei, nüüd võin vajutada.
Õpetaja: Ei, no kuidas? Iga kuidas iganes keegi teeb oma tööd niimoodi, et ta vigu ei teeks. Kas sul on checklist või mitte? Vaata, on ju. Ee, selles mõttes, et. Noh,
Õpetaja: õnnetusi juhtu. Pange vaim valmis. Ee, taski numbrid. Üks, üheksa, kuus, üks, kuus, üheksa, tead? Ja nagu
Õpetaja: kõigil juhtub ja see on okei. Ja mis nüüd on? Vaata ka seda, Nüüd jääb jälg maha. Oo, Meil on mingisugune projekt, mis on minust kümme aastat on arendatud mis. Te arvate kui, palju kui, mitte seal on
Õpetaja: kui, Palju on seal, kui mitte selles? Ee, selles. Noh, selles projektis tuhandeid.
Õpetaja: Oi, keegi näeb, et ma tegin paha. Ei, aga keegi näeb ka Seda, et ma tegin korda. See on lihtsalt probleem, sest et vaata, mida me ei saa. Meil on raske toimetada, sest et kõik on juba oma haru võtnud.
Õpetaja: Meil on seal. Seal on ka mingisuguseid muid, asju, et sa saad hakata mingi käskudega teliitama ja asju, aga sul on teised inimesed, kes töötab seal. Tuleb igal juhul. Mingi
Õpetaja: staffi tuleb.
Õpetaja: Kõige lihtsam on alati teha niimoodi, kui sa nii pea kui sa Teed selle vea ja kogemata pussid kuhugi Ära Mine lihtsalt tee Reversed Patch
Õpetaja: de Comit and mu von Kõik,
Õpetaja: nüüd üks asi ka siin Jälle ma ütlen, tahaks progeda, aga kohe jõuan sinna ka. Ee, väi, väikene asi. Veel üks õppetund, mis ma teile nagu ütlen, Ee, kitiga on niimoodi,
Õpetaja: kui te hakkate. Ee, ma mõtlen, kas ma ostan mingit Lhv tehnoloogiat, kui te hakkate mähkima.
Õpetaja: Nojah, eloeng.
Õpetaja: Kui te hakkate midagi mähkima. Ma kohe tuleb Argo meelde. Aa, kui te hakkate midagi mähkima Kitiga, See tähendab, seda, et midagi läks valesti. Te vajutasite mingit nuppu,
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt midagi kogemata. Vaikselt Sealt Mingi valikust, Mingit nuppu, midagi toimus. Saad aru? Kui midagi juhtus, ja siis, kurat võtaks. Oi, mis ma nüüd? Ma Ei, tea, mis ma tegin
Õpetaja: siis, kui juhtub midagi analoogset. Kus te Teete, midagi mida tegelt ei tea, siis kõige esimene asi, mis te teete, on see. Te tõstate käe püsti, lähete mõne targema kolleegi juurde ja ütlete, et ma tegin. Ma tegin kogemata mingisuguse vale klõpsu, Ma Ei ole kindel, mis juhtus. Vaata, kas sa palun tuleksid. Vaataksid,
Õpetaja: mida te ei tohi, teha. Mida Te ei tohi teha, on see, et te hakkate seda asja ise parandama.
Õpetaja: Miks, Sest et siis lähevad asjad hapuks ja ma. Ma kohe räägin, kuidas see läheb hapuks.
Õpetaja: Te Mõtlete
Õpetaja: ka? Vaata, Cloud. Ja igast asjad saate konsulteerida. Kusku mind seal ka mingeid garantiis ei ole. Vaata, võib proovida aidata. Võib aru saada valesti ka aru saada või midagi teha, peab täiesti tema peale lootma. Mina ei julgeks jääda. Ma igal juhul läheks küsima abi, kui ma Ei ole kindel,
Õpetaja: et mis ma tegin, kui ma olen sada protsenti. Kindel, et. Noh, ma tegin selle lihtne reverse. Vaata, Fine, aga kui Ma tegin midagi muud,
Õpetaja: midagi. Mingi lihtsalt mingit saab juhtuda. Siin on sellist võimalusi. Saab asju juhtuda.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis mida te ei taha teha, on see, et te hakkate Fixima. Sellepärast, et te hakkate Fixima, siis te näete, et see asi nagu ei Fix I.
Õpetaja: Sinna tuleb mingi Komite asju tuleb juurde. On Veel lihtne asi Mingid. Kägid asjad Mida iganes. Võib lihtsalt igasuguseid asju olla.
Õpetaja: Siis on niimoodi, et kui te Olete mähkinud seal nagu mingisugune. Kakskümmend. Kolmkümmend minutit Ja siis te ühel hetkel saate aru. Vaata, esiteks on kõik niiöelda repositaris seal pilves, Ee, Sa mähitas, et see on aja küsimus. Kui mingi mingi paha tuleb kuskilt välja Ja siis on nagu lõpuks on ikkagi teate selles seisus, et Te peate ikkagi minema. Ja Küsima keegi käest abi.
Õpetaja: Ja siis on. Niimoodi Mida see inimene teeb? Siis ütleb, Ah, Okei, väga hea,
Õpetaja: Ole hea, räägi mulle. Noh, mis sa tegid?
Õpetaja: Kui sul oleksid kohe alguses läinud. Käsi püsti. Vaata ja siis ütleks, et. Kuule, ma vajutasin Seda nuppu ja midagi tegin. Vaata, ma rohkem ei tea. Siis nagu uurime. Info on olemas
Õpetaja: kui sa oled seal mässinud mässanud ja mähkinud seal mingisugune pool tundi. Ja siis sa lõpuks pead nagu andma aru, et mida sa tegid, siis ma ise ka ei tea, ma ei tea enam, ma ma kuidagi niimoodi alustasin. Ja siis kuidagi asjad nagu läksid väga, väga halvaks. Vaata ja ma tõesti ei tea, mis ma Tegin
Õpetaja: neid asju investigatida. Ja nagu aru, saada, et mis seal on nagu toimunud, on sitaks keeruline. Sorry, et ma kasutan koledaid sõnu siin, Aga ausõna see. See inimene vihkab teid, kuni. Noh, südame põhjast vihkab siis seda, sest et see ei ole enam nii lihtne.
Õpetaja: See see Ilmselt Ei ole enam väga lihtne. Kui sul mingi algaja vend tuleb, et. Kuule, ma tegin igasuguseid asju. Ma ei tea, mida ma tegin.
Õpetaja: See on nagu. Seda on nagu see. See siin ei ole nagu siin. Ei ole mingit lihtsat lahendust. Nüüd hakkame alles Kit käskudest rääkima, Sa küsid. Küsid sõna Riho, onju? Kas peaks nagu nüüd Kitt käskude struktuuri mõistma vaata? Onju, ja? Nagu noh
Õpetaja: aru, ka saama vaata, ja toimetama. Vot siis, et seda asja uurida. Võibolla peab juba hakkama mõnusalt mässama ja. Ja see on võibolla väga keeruline.
Õpetaja: Ja Võibolla ikka midagi jääb sisse. Võibolla on kõik hästi. Vaata, et kui teil hakkate mingit jama tekitama, siis vähemalt alguses ka nagu ausõna, nagu valu. Lihtsalt tõstke Käsi püsti. Minge. Küsige, kui te isegi olete kodukontoris. Helistage kellegagi. Kuule, kohe vaatan, mis ma tegin.
Õpetaja: Kohe. Tule, vaata, sest et. Sest ühe asja suudad ära öelda. Ja kogenud inimene siis juba teab. Ja kui tema hakkas seal mähkima ja midagi jäi tuksi keerama veel thats is, Problem
Õpetaja: siis on nagu
Õpetaja: Ei, niukseid Asju ei ole.
Õpetaja: Ei ole, nüüd puudub.
Õpetaja: Ei ole. Tegin, mida Iganes Liigutus ei ole nagu repositoris, vaid Kui sa tegid mingisuguse käsu, siis jah. Seda saab korda teha. Mingi õige asjaga või õige käsuga. Võibolla. Või saab kuidagi liikuda õige tulemuseni, Aga nagu lihtsalt Control set ei ole
Õpetaja: Nii et, ee, mõelge.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga. Aga see on okei. See, mis ma näitasin, kui te ütleme Se sellega. Te võite suht kindlalt tunda, kui te lihtsalt kommit isite. Ja Push isite midagi pilve.
Õpetaja: Väga lihtne. Minge, tehke sellest reverse Patch, Pange.
Õpetaja: Ja kui mitte uuesti siin bussiga pilve. Ja ongi kõik. Jaa, see on kõige kindlam. Sellepärast, kui ma seda kunagi ühele seenior seenior seal midagi mähhis seal. Vaata ja läks kogemata valesti. Siis
Õpetaja: oli seal Aa selles mõttes, et ei. Ole. Nagu ma näitan, kuidas see on, Nagu vaatasin, teen ja ongi tagurpidi, Sest et kujutage ette, kui see on kogemata. Nüüd selline asi. Vaata, kus kaustu tõsteti. Ümber.
Õpetaja: Põmm, põmm, Põmm, põmm. Mingi Monster monster. Nagu süsteemis. Monster, Kuidas sa teed seda korda
Õpetaja: Ja jah. On seal mingeid variante, et sa hakkad seal pilves kustutama asju. Aga teised inimesed toimetavad selles samas asjas. Kellelgi tuleb ikkagi mingisugune jama.
Õpetaja: Jah, aga see võib olla noh, näiteks kui on vestluskood, Siis polegi olema.
Õpetaja: No jah, ei selles mõttes, et ega see. Noh, selles mõttes ega? Kõik on ju kit käsud. Vaata, ma mõtlen, et Kui teda sealt sealt pole olemas,
Õpetaja: Tähendab jah, see. Vaata, asi on võibolla funktsionaalsus. Ma jään vastusele võlgu ja kindlasti on seal ka olemas Siin ei saa olla niimoodi, et praegu kõik kasutaksid ja lehvitas kaabuku. Ja, noh, nad ikka võistlevad omavahel põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: kogu aeg nad on enamvähem, Ma arvan, ma ei ole ise veest koodi kasutaja. Mina ei suudaks seal opereerida lihasmälu pärast. Mul oleks lihtsalt raskusi sellega, arvatavasti,
Õpetaja: ee, ja Selles mõttes, kui keegi kasutab Ves Code, vaata siis siin kursusel ikkagi õppida Selles mõttes, et, noh, auru, Kui Ma saaksin kuskile kursusele minna, Kus nad ütlevad, et siin me kasutame Vscode, siis ma teeksin seda lihtsalt sellepärast, et siis ma näen, kuidas see tööriist töötab, Vaata ja Mismoodi seda kasutada? Aga Mul oleks kindlasti raskusi Sellepärast, et ma hakkaksin
Õpetaja: klubinaga, Saad tõmmata, et nagu enamus asjad mappingud, saad teha, nagu
Õpetaja: kus koodi kasutatakse Miks, üldse? Nagu ta on eelkõige mõeldud java gotline skaala. Ta toetab eelkõige keelt neid keeli,
Õpetaja: et Ee idee järgi sa saad ka vägistada ka püüytoni sisse, kui tahad, Aga neil on selle jaoks.
Õpetaja: Kui sa tahad teha Sharfi, siis sa seda ei kasuta, kui sa Tahad intelligse tootega? Mis feels like sama vaates. Neil on C ja trellid. On see Shar,
Õpetaja: See on. See on üsna Niukene kaine, nagu Jaava,
Õpetaja: nagu väga, väga sarnane. Ja ka mingid väiksed erisused on ka päris okei.
Õpetaja: Ee, et et selles mõttes, et, ee et kui on Nagu java jaavat saab ka loomulikult viies koodiga, et selles mõttes, et mõlemad saavad Vaata, nagu teatud teatud nagu keeltega, nagu hakkama
Õpetaja: enam vähem, Noh, see see mõttes ainukene, mis on natukene universaalne,
Õpetaja: et et kui sa võtad näiteks selle, mis on ka toode, siis ta on ainult mõeldud Sharp Ile Sellega näed sa Fronti teha saab siin jaavat teha. Saaks. Isegi püütonit teha saab. Saab vigast.
Õpetaja: Igasugust asju saab tegelikult teha. See on nagu natuke nagu nendele üldine idea nagu ongi. Tegelikult on nagu selles mõttes üldine ide. Ta ei ole nagu. Nagu, et
Õpetaja: see keel
Õpetaja: kusjuures, et selles mõttes, et. Ee, see, et see. Vaata, need kõlavad sarnaselt, et, ee, et selles mõttes, ee, neil on kindlasti mingid Omad ja plussid ja miinused. Näiteks praegult. Näiteks sellel Cloudil Plugin
Õpetaja: on mingi üheskoodis On mingi päris mingi Hea asi. Vist. Nagu mis? Nagu Parem huviga paremate funktsionaalsustega. Vaata, et noh antroopik ise on teinud selle, tundub et nad ei ole nii huvitatud sellest kuidagi,
Õpetaja: aga siin on ka erinevad põhjused. Ma ütlen, et. Noh, lõpuks need kõik on nagu siin, on ka ägedaid asju. Nagu selles mõttes, et siin on ka Nagu ägedaid asju, mida jälle. Neil ei ole,
Õpetaja: et ee, et see käib nii
Õpetaja: ee ja. Ja selles mõttes. Et seal on ka litsentsi küsimus. Ka Viies kood on tasuta. Minu meelest
Õpetaja: küsivad midagi. Ka. Või keegi teab.
Õpetaja: Minu meelest on tasuta. Noh, kui tahad ultimate kasutada, ma Ei, tea, võibolla on ka midagi ka midagi, et ekstrat saad. Vaata, et. Noh, et see Ultimate on, Noh, selles mõttes, et nad toote nimest on tahtnud selle ära kaotada. Ee oli kaks versiooni Community Edition.
Õpetaja: Noh, iga vend, kes tahab arendada, võib kasutada ja Ultimate Ultimate Is on kõik need mugavused kellad, viled, mida te praegult ei saa. Isegi, aru et on mugavus, sellepärast, et on juba peal, Teil on ju, Aga seal on natukene nagu rohkem
Õpetaja: vist ka nagu lihtsad asjad. Näiteks tõesti see, et. Vaata, et sa saad mingisuguse terminaliga oma enda play nupuga jooksutada kuskil ja nii edasi. Vaata,
Õpetaja: noh, nad on selles mõttes ega kõik üritavad oma toodet lõpuks kuidagi müüa, et sa pead mingi mingi mingi prääniku tekitama. Vaata, et ee, et sul oleks huvi. Vaata nagu ee. Maksta nagu seda iseenesest litsents. Vist ei ole, väga kallis. Ta vist viisteist eurot.
Õpetaja: Väga palju igastah programme on, kus sealt kas tasuta või väga soodsalt ja pidevalt on neile igast pakkumisi, ka, et et kui ma oleks päris arendaja, ma oleks näiteks oma ettevõte Noh, mingi oü või midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja mul ei oleks, nagu seda Ma kindlasti ei maksaks Nagu seda litsentsi, et mul oleks see tööriist Ultimate, mitte see, Aga
Õpetaja: sest, et ma ei tea pead
Õpetaja: tänapäeval, mis siin on? Jätad ühe korra mingisugune.
Õpetaja: Jätad siin kaks mingi korda Circle Case nagu mingi hot dogi ja kohvi vahele ja, noh,
Õpetaja: vanasti ma Olin ka tegelikult hästi Selline, et ma. Ma ei tahtnud kunagi maksta õppematerjalide eest
Õpetaja: tänapäeval Tegelt, see on lollus. Isegi kõik need udemid ja asjad Kus mingi kursus maksab? Sada dollarit. No mina ei tea. Käi paar päeva järjest vaatamas juba. Ta pakub mingi viisteist dollarit, või mis iganes onju, siis vaatad, mis sa sellest vastu saad. Mingi seitsekümmend tundi videomaterjali asju. Vaata, et, noh, et, tegelikult nagu maksta, nagu
Õpetaja: ma ei tea Eestis. Elu on niikuinii Nii, kallis, vaata, onju. Pead sellepärast kokku hoidma. Muidugi ee, aga nagu, et nagu maksta nagu mingit vahel raha Mingisuguse asja eest, millel on nagu annab sulle elu. Lisandväärtust.
Õpetaja: On nagu okei. Samamoodi nagu see Cloud Code. Mina ei kavatse isegi Chat I, Mul on kaks subscription It. Ma saaksin hakkama ühega idee järgi. Ma lihtsalt ei ole nõus loobuma. Ma maksan mõne. Just küsis et sul, on kaks subscription it. Tal pole ühtegi vaadata, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee ma ütlesin. Jaa, on küll. Jah,
Õpetaja: Ei, Cloud Code ei ole ee Tavaline Cloud on neil tasuta, kuni teatud mahuni nagu Chat I. Vaata, onju. Aga nende terminali tööriist ei ole.
Õpetaja: Ja, noh, praegu mul isegi on selle üle hea meel Sellepärast hetkel nagu sellega, et. Ee, mänd vist on päris suur. Need süsteemid ei pea vastu. Super user. Id lihtsalt kasutavad Token Eid nagu rämedalt.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kas sa saad. Ee, mitmes kohas sisse. Ma pole seda ise proovinud. Ma ei tea, nelja peale
Õpetaja: Kahesaja või Nice. Ta ei ole unlimited, aga okei, Aga isegi mitte nagu neid päevaseid limiite.
Õpetaja: Ma. Ma vist. Noh, ma ütlen, ma arvatavasti Mingi, et ka meie ettevõte on praegu Mina ja meelis kasutame. Vaata oma papi eest ka tegelt nagu Kind, on see nagu. Valikute küsimus, on alati see teema ka. Noh,
Õpetaja: ütleme niimoodi, et ma. Ma olen selle pro peal ja ma saan hakkama,
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes, et, ee, Kuidas ma kohe näitan ka, et seda saab vaadata nii nende kodulehelt.
Õpetaja: Ma ei olegi kunagi sinna. Käsitsi läinud Aga äkki mul on link Kuskil siin veel ees. Cloud Setting, Usage.
Õpetaja: On mul seitse protsenti kasutatud. Ee, kus ta seda resetti näitab, Millal see ee muutub
Õpetaja: ja nüüd on nädalane limiit ka. Mida introducisid Siis nagu mingi natuke aega tagasi, et ka nädala peale. Nad arvestavad. Ee, t tööriistast. Endast saab ka tegelikult väga edukalt vaadata Ee, kaldkriips. Usa käe
Õpetaja: data.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin all. Nii. Noh, et sa saad nagu sa saad nagu jälgida seda, et Mul Ei ole. Kuidas sul. Mis sulle näitab?
Õpetaja: Vaatame, oled. Sa nüüd näitab üks protsent vä. Mis teised seal teevad? Sa ütlesid nelja peale Jagasid vä
Õpetaja: Ee, kõik. Noh, töö töö ajal ka
Õpetaja: on. Kakskümmend kaheksa Nädal. Nelikümmend Research seitseteist, mis on kahe päeva pärast jah,
Õpetaja: ma oleks ka sellise diiliga nõus Tegelikult otse. On siis viiskümmend nägu vä, No näete. No problem.
Õpetaja: Jah. Et Ee, see See lihtsalt muutub elu osaks. Vaata, Siin mingi See vend. Vaata, nagu rääkis, et ma nagu tulevikus. Vaata, et palka ei makstagi, vaid jagatakse token. Eid, vaata, on ju
Õpetaja: ma Siis nagu naersin selle, peale et nagu lähed poodi, Nagu, et nagu vaatad. Kurat, piima hind on jälle tõusnud. Läheb kallimaks, et päriselt. See, mis on meie valuuta vä. Aga Aga Ma natuke. Hakkan nagu nägema. Lihtsalt seda. Vaata, et see. On elu osane, nagu
Õpetaja: mäletate, kui Ma, Mina, ee. Ma teadsin Google T ammu enne seda, kui see oli nagu mingi ee asi. Ma lihtsalt nägin juhuslikult mingi soome kanal. Kahest oli ka, et üle kaks
Õpetaja: nägin mingit saadet, Mis aegajalt oli mulle meeldis. Vaata, ja seal üks osa oli see, et sul oli kaks inimest. Vaata, neile anti mingisugused erinevad teemad ja nad pidid mingisugust nagu infot ja vastuseid leidma. Ja see oli, noh, kuhugile ei olnud Selline nagu ta täna on.
Õpetaja: Ja siis keegi ei teadnud. Google St. Oli mingid. Ja Jumal teab, mida. Vaata ja kasutati veel ka niuksed Otsinguprogramme, mis vaatas mitmest kohast vist oli, kui ma hästi mäletan. Hästi, põnev oli. Vaata, alati oli mingi asi, nagu, et, noh, pidin mingisuguse fakti ülesse leidma. Kumb ennem leiab sealt punkti? Midagi taolist oli.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ma vaatasin mingi vend seal kogu aeg nagu tuimalt pani mind Vaata ja siis vahel harva. Nägin mõnda teist enda ka. Siis ma vaatasin, mis asi see on. Vaata, onju,
Õpetaja: ma olin juba
Õpetaja: Okei, otsige kohalt. Ma alati räägin selle Story ka. Siis su viimane story. Siis peame veits tööta tegema. Aa, ma räägin. Kuidas. Aa, minu naine Aa, Googeldas. Kui me kohtusime, siis ma mõtlesin ka korra. Tegelikult, Kas on inimene, kellega ma soovin ennast siduda?
Õpetaja: Ee, see oli siis niimoodi. Ee,
Õpetaja: Tegelikult on selline inimene ka, keda arendajad vihkavad.
Õpetaja: Ee, tema esiteks kasutas sellel ajal, kui oli juba ka. Ee, see. Ehk siis mäletate, Kunagi oli internet. Explorer
Õpetaja: internet. Explorer oli juba Mina ei tea, Mina arvan juba. Mingi paar aastat olid toest maas, aga nad isegi ei toeta Seda
Õpetaja: oli juba ammu väljas. Ja, noh, normaalne inimene kasutas ka Chrome. Või siis võibolla Firefox I, Võibolla kes oli vaja Niukene veel et Tahaks midagi ägedamalt kasutada.
Õpetaja: Ja siis, ee, tema kasutas. Esiteks, ma nägin endiselt veel. Ee,
Õpetaja: istusin ta kuskil selja taga või nägin. Vaata, ta Hakkas midagi guugeldama Ja siis ma nägin oma silmadega, mis moodi
Õpetaja: tegi? Internetiks lahti, Seab mulle juba oli niimoodi. Oh, my God,
Õpetaja: ee, Miks Arendajad vihkavad. Seda on, sellepärast. Et ee. Kui sa oled fronte enda. Arendaja.
Õpetaja: Kui sa teed mingit arendust ja sulle makstakse selle eest, siis Üks ee asi, mida arutatakse, on see, et milliseid brausereid
Õpetaja: lahendust peab toetama. Sellises mõttes, et kõikjal on asjad nagu enamvähem ühesugused nähtavad,
Õpetaja: ja Siis tavaliselt, mis tehakse, võetakse statistika lahti. Vaata, et vaadatakse, et ee, mis on see nagu. Vaata, kas siis ee. Konkreetses riigis või üle, maailma mis iganes. Ja siis tuleb välja, et, noh, kroom on seal. See number. Üks Ja siis tuleb safari. Noh, see safari ka on ju
Õpetaja: ja Firefox ja mida iganes ja kuskil, siis tuleb ka see oma mingi kümne protsendiga mis. Iganes
Õpetaja: ja. Siis tol ajal kuskil veel Oli ka interneti seal, oma ühe kahe protsendiga maamuna, kasutajatest või riigi kasutajatest.
Õpetaja: Ee, suurkorporatsioonid. Alati on nagu need. Vaata, näiteks, kes, kui nad on tellijad, siis nad või üldse mis? Tahes Tellijad, kes maksavad raha mõtlevad. Neil on ju hästi lihtne seda öelda. Peab toetama kõike
Õpetaja: kolm protsendil. Jah, nemad ka.
Õpetaja: Noh, aga see arenduses nagu on päris keeruline. Mingit
Õpetaja: kihvtid Asjad tulevad peale need vanad asjad nagu neid kihvte asju väga hästi ei toeta, on ju? Ja siis on mingisugune tobeda kolme protsendi pärast. Vaata, nagu peab nagu tegema seal ka nagu mingist optimisation It asja.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ma vaatasin. Okei, ta on see inimene. Ta on see kolm protsenti.
Õpetaja: Ta tegi selle lahti. Tal ei olnud isegi Homepage.
Õpetaja: Või See homepage läks, Aga see läks tal mingi töökeskkonda.
Õpetaja: Siis ta läks ee sinna.
Õpetaja: Tal ei olnud isegi pandud favoriks, et
Õpetaja: kirjuta sinna. W W punkt neti punkt, e e siit. Okei,
Õpetaja: läks Neti punkt. E e le neti punkt e l oli isegi Google integratsioon, Kui sa väga tahaksid. Sa vaid seda tripleüüs saad valitada ja valida. Vist Vist oli nii? Ma ei ole kindel selles osas ma ei ole kindel, su võimekus siis oli. On või? Mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Ta kirjutas sinna neti punkt E, E, siis otsingumootorisse. Ta läksin ära, entriga tuli üldse leht lahti. Tead ikka, nagu vanasti oli see sinine lehekülg. Klassikalised, ajalehed ja sellised jututoad. Ja mis need rubriigid seal kõik on, onju Ee, täiskasvanule.
Õpetaja: Erinevad rubriigid,
Õpetaja: uudised ja Tema läks siis sinna. Search I alati. Ja siis ta kirjutas sinna ma ei tea, otsi
Õpetaja: Siis Tulid sealt linid lahti. Siis ta vajutas linki. Siis ta maandus. W. W. Google Dot com.
Õpetaja: Ta läks pani sinna, mida ta tahtis otsida. See päris sõna et ma ei tea, mida ta tegelt otsa tahtis.
Õpetaja: Ja jah, siis ma mõtlesin. Selline See inimene ongi midagi teha ja kõige Hullem on see, et ma, ütlesin, et kuule, aga
Õpetaja: kas sa nagu Chromi oled mõelnud kasutada või kui ei tohi olla nagu Google toode, et peab olema Microsoft siis kasvõi Edge, mis on põhimõtteliselt chromium või Basil. Niikuinii on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja siis ma, ütlesin, et ta, Tead, ma Näitan, et sa lähed sinna, paned sa otsima sõna ja ta läheb lihtsalt. Ja otsid kohe kuuks selle ta. Ei, ma ei taha. Mina Olen koguaeg niimoodi teinud Ta on nagu väike vanainimene.
Õpetaja: Ta ei taha uuendustega kaasa väga minna. Ta on terve elu Niukene all, aga siin on üks väikene vimka. Ka
Õpetaja: talle ei meeldi muudatused. Ta tahab teha kõike asju. Ta Kasutas aastaid. Aastaid, kasutas ee niukest asja nagu ova, Keegi ei tea niukest asja ova.
Õpetaja: See on Outlook läbi Veebibrauser i Mailbox.
Õpetaja: Mitte et sa loogid kuskil sisse või tungi. Niuke keskkond vaata Kus nagu peegeldab. Nagu näeb välja nagu outlook. Nagu standard on enamvähem. Näeb.
Õpetaja: Ma olen ka küsinud seda, et nagu sa vajutad siia alla, Lihtsalt poiss käest tuleb lahti. Ei, ei, ei, niimoodi. Miks ta lõpus pidi loobuma? Sellest internetist hiljem ka ovast. Asjad Lihtsalt lõpuks ei töötanud
Õpetaja: Katki
Õpetaja: lahendus oligi see, et pidi lihtsalt minema mingi normaalse asja peale. Täna nad vist toimivad kasutada ainult seda teostada Maksuamet, Aga aga üks Asi, mis ma muidugi tahtsin, siin muidugi rääkida. On see, mis on märkimisväärne, on see,
Õpetaja: kui tuli Chat Ibt ta kohe alguses seda ei kasutanud,
Õpetaja: Aga, ee, väga ee, kiiresti ja märkamatult juhtus see, et temast on saanud nagu, ee, nagu kasutaja.
Õpetaja: Ta kasutab seda üsna palju igatepidi Ja see näitab midagi.
Õpetaja: Ee, minu arvates see näitab midagi, et et isegi need inimesed, kes ei taha, vaata tegelikult uusi asju kasutada, on saanud aru, et siin on mingisugune väga suur väärtus ja mingi väga suur abivahend.
Õpetaja: Kuskil need tõrksad inimesed, kes tahavad innovatsiooniga kaasas käia,
Õpetaja: juba mõistavad, et. Oi, see on mingi hea asi. Siis ilmselt see on hea asi Ja ilmselt see on ee, tähtis asi ja ilmselt kõik lähevad sellega kaasa. Isegi need kolm protsenti inimesed lähevad lõpuks kaasa. Noh, väga hea. No minu ema veel Ei, kasuta.
Õpetaja: Võibolla on taustav.
Õpetaja: Ma Ei tea, ma pean uurima, kas see tegelikult ei ole selline arengukurb. Isegi nagu olemas, et sul on tegelikult need innovatiivsed inimesed on populatsioonist Mingi siuke. Kümme. Viisteist prossa need. Kes, võtavad mingi asja kasutusele isegi, siis kui, ta alles on mingi no. Ma ei tea mingi test Või ma ei tea, mingi periood.
Õpetaja: Siis teine teine tsükkel tuleb see, kust tuleb see niiöelda. See
Õpetaja: mass tuleb järgi ja siis sellel sellel Sabal ei ole nagu mingil hetkel. Noh, enam varianti, et. Noh, selles mõttes, et
Õpetaja: selge on see. Vaata, noh, seda on nii palju räägitud ka ju. Vaata, et. Ee, siin Nüüd see Ai tuleb peale. Isegi arendajad on mingid arendajad, kes võitlevad selle vastu nad ei taha kasvatada, Ai, tegelikult endal on ka vahel natukene nagu kohati on. See on nagu vastutuslikud tunded. Vahel mul endal on ka natukene, see oksemaik hakkab tekkima sellest Ai. St.
Õpetaja: Kõik on nagu selles mõttes. Ma ei viitsi mingit videot enam vaadata. Vaata, kui see on justkui nagu üritatakse teha See on nagu mingi päriselt juhtunud õnnetus või asja tegelt. See on fake, Vaata, onju. Iga pilt, mida sa näed, on Sa pead juba kahtlema tekst. Mida sa loed? Sa vahel isegi saad? Aru Vaata, et
Õpetaja: kurat, see on Ai ga tehtud. Vaata, et nagu ja waste of Time. No sisu tühi. Vaata, Ee,
Õpetaja: No teate ikka seda sõna. Islop. No eesti Keeles võiks olla jama, on ju? Olete kuulnud juba seda? Workshop
Õpetaja: Võrks loppu. On see, Kui sa saad meili, saad meili.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis kirjutab midagi. Ja tegelikult on sisu tühi ja tähendab seda hoopis Kuidagi ühel või teisel viisil. Sinule hoopis nüüd tööd juurde,
Õpetaja: Niukene. Asi on ka olemas, et et keegi, nagu on pannud mingi mahuka asja kokku
Õpetaja: Põmm teele. Kui sa vaatad tegelikult sinna sisu inimesena sisse, siis sa näed, et seal tegelikult sisu pole. Nüüd sa pead hakkama selle jamaga tegelema. See on probleem,
Õpetaja: Jah, aga vaata, Nüüd on veel eriti hull. On nüüd see. Vaata, et kui sa nüüd hakkad kolleegilt saama Seda Workshop. I, vaata, onju. Tema pani mingi paar rida. Vaata kirja. Sülitas sulle mingisuguse asja. Vaata, sina pead tegelema. Mis siis vastu hakatakse? Sa oled mingi pika kirjast.
Õpetaja: Ee, teie kokkuvõte ei vasta ära ka minu eest. Vaata. Noh, kuhu me jõuame? Niimoodi. Vaata, et kohati mul on natuke niukene oksetunne nagu nendest asjadest. Aga teisest küljest. Kui ma progen selle asjaga, siis mulle nagu jällegi, nagu meeldib aga siin, on, Mul on ka selles osas Tegelikult hästi. Natukene Vastakad tunde.
Õpetaja: Ma just rääkisin siin ka siin natukene aega tagasi. Ma tean, et ei kasutust, et meil oli siin niukene Ee, erinevatest gruppidest. Inimesed said kokku ja mul oli ka privileeg olla ühel õhtusöögil.
Õpetaja: Aa, siis seal oli huvitav inimestega arutada ja oli nähagi, et seal mõned, kes on nagu, väga pro, ja siis on mõned, kes on tegelt vastu mul endal hakkab natukene ka tekkima. See tunne. Vaata, et okei. Nüüd oled sa dirigent. Orkestreerija, mis? Kohati? Tundub nagu lõbus on ju. Ja nagu tore, sa Saad kõik väga palju korraga ära teha. Liikuda edasi ja nii edasi. Sa pead seda tuima koodi kirjutama.
Õpetaja: Aga natukene on isegi kurbus ka, Kui päris aus olla,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, et selles mõttes, et see tunne, kui sa ise kirjutad mingisuguse raske koodi, valmis et sa näed rämedalt vaeva. Sa teed seda tõesti ilusat ja hästi, et sa vajutad nuppu ja siis fucking töötab see feeling, et see töötab, see see vanasti tähendas midagi nagu päriselt emotsioon.
Õpetaja: Iga kord, kui mul siin klassiruumis vanasti õppisid. Kui tiimitööd on. Kuule, keegi hüüab. Jess,
Õpetaja: võibolla see on said Mingi lotovõidu või vaatad? Yes
Õpetaja: töötas. Ma võtsin nuppu. Esimese korraga töötas. Vaata, see on emotsioon ja nagu tunne, aga. Aga seda emotsiooni nagu Väga ei teki. Kui kirjutad, et tee see asi valmis. Vaata, Ninety Nine Times, see töötab. Vaata. Okei? Võibolla ei tööta. Ka siis ütled, et tee nagu veits korda, on ju? Aga sa ei teinud seda ise. Sa ei näind seda vaeva. Vaata ja ei ole nagu seda Nagu
Õpetaja: nii palju.
Õpetaja: Noh, jah, ma ei teagi. Ma ütlen nagu, et seda on nagu öeldud. Vaata ma olen lugenud ka neid artikleid, kus inimesed. Noh, mul tuleb hästi palju Feed I tulema kuidagi. Mida sa loed? Seda seal, Feed I Tuleb Onju, et inimesed on nagu olen näinud neid nagu artikleid, kus inimesed kirjutavad juba põhimõtteliselt niimoodi,
Õpetaja: kui nüüd meil ettevõttes nüüd ongi niimoodi, et Aa hakkame, teeme, tegeme tööd, onju? Siis see on see hetk, kus mina. Nagu progejana panen. Nagu töö maha. Vaata
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et ta inimene tajub. Vaata, et tegelikult ta ise Nagu Ei loo nagu sellist väärtust. Ta ei tunne enam seda naudingut. Vaata selle. Ta ei tunne naudingut. Aa progemisest
Õpetaja: ta Ei tunne. Mõtle, Sa oled mingisugune Sa oled mingi hull, proff. Sa oled hull proff. Sa oled nagu niuke koodigeneraator. Sa teed nagu brilantseid nagu ilusaid arhitektuurilised Mustreid ja lahendusi ja kõike neid vaata.
Õpetaja: Ja. Ja see ongi see sinu väärtus. Vaata, mina oskan, mina teen ja ma olen uhke selle üle. Ja siis ühel hetkel, nagu see läheb ära. Et siis ongi nagu see, et vaata. Noh, kes tahab, seda teha on? Inimesed, kes Tahavad sinna kuidagi arhitekti rolle kuidagi ülevalt ja meeldibki see orkestreerimine. Timm aga on tegelikult need inimesed, ka, et see
Õpetaja: see on nagu, noh,
Õpetaja: Kujutame ette, et ma olen mingi World Class. Mingi juuksur. Mingeid miljoneid makstakse. On ju midagi taolist,
Õpetaja: aga kui see kuidagi elu muutuks selliseks, Vaata, on ju, et ee. Inimene tuleb sisse ja ma oska võibolla kuidagi disainida. Arvutis. Vaata, et milline see inimesel soeng tuleb ja sa Vajutad nuppu, siis toob mingid laserid
Õpetaja: lõikavad. Ära. Vaata, on. Valmis. Vaata, et siis on nagu see, Vaata aga, noh,
Õpetaja: ma ju olen, see ma Ju oskan Vaata teha. Ja see natukene nagu kaob ära. Jah, samas ega mingi artriit. Ja asjad nagu ei taha. Vaata, et seda töö. See on nagu. See on natuke. Minu jaoks on see ka natukene vastakas. Ma ei oska ma praegu. Ma pigem naudin seda. Muidugi, Loomulikult, kui ma teen asju. Vaata aga ma natukene nagu tajun ka, et midagi on jälle nagu vähemaks.
Õpetaja: See on sama tunne nagu kunagi Ju Põllumehed ei töötaja. Kui seitsekümmend protsenti rahvastikest töötas põllul. Ühel hetkel tulid. Noh, igasugused. Ee, masinad Täna töötab vist vähem inimesi põllul, kui Vangis istub. Nii et, ee, selles mõttes, ee.
Õpetaja: Robotid panevad vuravad, teevad undega. Sa lähed nagu poodi ja ostad selle toidu, mida Sa Vanem Oled kogu aeg nagu.
Õpetaja: No jah,
Õpetaja: jah, aga noh, progressi vastu ei saa. Ee, minu naine on, ee, juba ikka üsna. Noh, sõltlane ei ole. Ei ole aga ikkagi kasutav. Ja see on. Ma ütlen, see on näitaja.
Õpetaja: Paneme nüüd edasi, teeme natukene midagi ja siis pausile ja Siis aitab jahumisest. Ärge küsige mult. Mitte midagi ka, Ainult kui Ee on kuidagi seotud progemisega.
Õpetaja: Ee, mida ma tahtsin üldse näidata. Selle teeme lõpuni, siis teeme pausi ära. See on niuke. Loogiline koht. Midagi muud ei hakka teha. Kuidas kiirelt Rainil järgi saada? Mis esimene punkt oli? Ainult sellest oleme rääkida. Kõik on ju? No tehke teie ka. Me teeme selle läbi,
Õpetaja: siis. Ee, järgmine asi, mis te teete, on see.
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd Seda ma pean korra testima. Vaata, sest et ma. Ma tahan näha, et ma kindlalt saan aru. Ärge praegu, Jumala eest vajutage, Alates sellest hetkest, kui ma nüüd ütlen Praegult,
Õpetaja: ma. Teen ma. Lähen korra sinna. Õpetaja Haru peale. Ee, tähendab, okei, tehke korra.
Õpetaja: Ma saaks seal samal pildil olla.
Õpetaja: Ee, see Fetch ei ole harupõhine peegeldus.
Õpetaja: Mäletate? Fetch, See on nagu see, et saage aru, on, see mis toimub, Mis toimub? Ee, Kitarris
Õpetaja: Oled siin haru peal. Vajutad Fetch I. Oled mujal haru peal. Vaata sellist optionit. Vot iga haru peal on, mingi et kui ma vajutan, on mingid optionid, mis on seotud selle haruga. Kas ma lähen õpetaja peale? On mul niuksed valikud, Kui ma lähen Masteri peale on mul niuksed valikud. Kui te vaatate. Siin ei ole kuskil niukest asja nagu
Õpetaja: sellepärast ta ei ole haru spetsiifiline, Nii tegite ära.
Õpetaja: Väga hea, mina olen ka nüüd. Ee, selle haru peale tagasi õpetaja Haru peale. Ja ma nüüd teen ühe muudatuse meelega, nagu mis Oleks lihtsalt jälgitav kergelt.
Õpetaja: Ee, kus meil see indeks saate? Meil on.
Õpetaja: Ma tulen kohe siia algusesse.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan, et saaksite ühest asjast aru. Vaata, ma tahan, et te saaksite aru, et iga kord, kui te tulete mulle järgi, te peate vajutama. Fetch, I, See on see eesmärk, Mida ma üritan praegu teile selgitada. Ma teen siia nagu.
Õpetaja: Ja ma selle ära kontroll ka. Kusjuures, saad selle paneeli avada. Mis on, Commit?
Õpetaja: Ee, ma panen siia ka. Lihtsalt. Aa, praegult.
Õpetaja: Ma panen komitee buss nii kui mitte buss.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, kui ta läheb läbi, tegi selle ära.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, ee. Minu mõte on nüüd selline, et kui te tahate mulle kiirelt järgi tulla, tegite nii. Nüüd peaks tegema Fetch I. Aga ärge Tehke Fetchi, sest just on. Demonstreerime seda. Vaata, Mis läheb valesti. Siis
Õpetaja: Tahate ruttu mulle järgi tulla? Rain, tee üks Committee. Teen, Teen Comiti, Teen, ütlen, võid. Anna tuld. Vaata, onju. Teie olete juba seni kaua Roll Back inud. Ja mis te nüüd tahate teha, on siis see, et tule. Te võtate ee, selle õpetaja pealt
Õpetaja: ja ütlete. New Branch From Origin Õpetaja,
Õpetaja: Tehke ka. See on kaasategemise koht
Õpetaja: Nii, ja te Panete oma nime sinna uuesti suurte tähtedega.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma panen isegi. No ma panen õpetajaks jälle
Õpetaja: õpetaja, Kuna teil on juba selline enda nimeline haru olemas. Mille peal te praegult ka ise istute? Vaata Ilmselt
Õpetaja: siis te panete lihtsalt siia mingi sidekriipse ja mingi, noh, mingi vee kaks
Õpetaja: me pärast muretsema. Mis sellest teisest aurust saab ja nii edasi. Me tahame kiirelt järgi tulla. Me tahame klassiga edasi minna. Me tahame Rainile öelda, et võid minna nüüd edasi. Vaata, et ee, sain tehtud.
Õpetaja: Te panete lihtsalt oma nime mingi veekaks ja vajutate Create ja panete. Ee, No see on peal alati Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd kui te tulete ja teete oma indeks Html I lahti, siis palun öelge, mis te näete Real Kaksteist. Kas te näete seda A D või ei Näe,
Õpetaja: ei näe.
Õpetaja: Miks?
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et tema tegelikult tegi selle Branch I selle õpetaja viimasest Peegeldusest
Õpetaja: ta ei. Kui te ütlete. Isegi kui lähed siia Remote võtta. Õpetaja. Ta ei lähe pilvest seda haaru. Tegema
Õpetaja: Ta toimetab ikka ainult Selle Põhjal, mis siin on.
Õpetaja: Kui te oleksite teinud Fetch, siis oleks see teil olnud olemas.
Õpetaja: Ja see mõte ongi see, et te jõuate mulle ju järgi. Mina teen.
Õpetaja: Tee just seda, mis mina, Push Isin, Kui te lihtsalt teete roll, Back, kaotate kõik oma harud ära, tulete, Valite minu haru ja teete endale kiirelt ühe uue haru. V, Kaks või kolm. V, neli, V, viis. Mis iganes on ju siis see on Sellest hetkest, kui te viimati tegite.
Õpetaja: Ta ei lähe päriselt pilve.
Õpetaja: Miks mul läks see haru välja?
Õpetaja: Ei, meid ei huvita see asi. Üldse. Me peame õppeasjadega edasi minema. Praegu see ei huvita tõesti.
Õpetaja: Ee, nii.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma tegin seda B kaks ja see on nüüd Vale ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, vot nüüd me saamegi üldse vaadata. Päriselus Oletame, kui oleks õigesti teinud. Nüüd saaks lihtsalt edasi kütta õppima vaata teeme. Edasi on ju. Mistahes te ei saa, Mäletate, Ei saa kustutada seda oksa, mille peal istud, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ee, siis mina saan iga kell minna Niiöelda tagasi
Õpetaja: mingisuguse aru ma nüüd. Te ei ole enam selle omanimelise aru peal, on nii? On ju omal vabal ajal mitte siis, kui Me Kütame edasi on, ju te hiljem saate. Lihtsalt minna suvalisel hetkel kui, on väike paus
Õpetaja: minna oma vana haru peale ja öelda delete on nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui teid väga häirib see V kaks seal.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis te saate aru, mille peal te olete. Saate tulla ja öelda lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Kui ta on juba pilve pussitud, siis ei saa.
Õpetaja: Aga kui ta on lokaalselt teis, siis saab väga ilusti.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta ei, miks Ta peakski kohe olema. Teil pust. Vaata, just tegite. Aga tegelikult Kas seal. On vahet, et seal on see V kaks.
Õpetaja: Kui te olete Niukene, Siis see võib olla teid häirib Ja tegelikult ülisavi. Meil on tähtis. Ärme unusta ära meie missiooni meid kõige rohkem huvitab see, et Me saame võimalikult palju õppida neid teemasid, mis siin on ees olemas, tulemas. Ja siin on veel palju, palju palju asju, See on kõige tähtsam. Kõik ülemuu on tilulivu. Ülisavi näitab täpselt
Õpetaja: mingisugust asja Küsida, et Kit Logist nad näevad mingit asja erinevat Neid ei huvita, see meid huvitab see, mis asi on Csss, me pole sellest rääkinud.
Õpetaja: Meid huvitab, mis asi on. Meid huvitab, mis asi on Single Page Application. Meid huvitab, mis asi on.
Õpetaja: Meid huvitavad niuksed. Asjad, mis on Mis on Props? Mis on komponent? Mis on vaade, mis on rada?
Õpetaja: Kõik need Asjad huvitavad meid. Neid me tahame õppida.
Õpetaja: See on kõige tähtsam, Ee, nüüd teeme pausi ja tuleme tagasi. Teeme? Noh, tuleme kuskil enamvähem pool tundi. Jah, pool tundi. Seda polegi vaja.
Õpetaja: See. See on point. Vaata, kui on. Teinud. Noh, teeme siis korra uuesti. Vaata, minge korra mast. Minge korra mastori peale
Õpetaja: Ee, tehke siis kõik Masteri peale. Minge korra, kustutage see V, kaks. Aa, ära.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd kujutame ette, et te tegite Teeme. Nüüd, Fetch. Sellepärast, et praegult teil teil ei ole seda. Tulge korra siia. Kui te teete selle lahti, onju Ja vaat Või vaadake. Noh, te peate enda ekraanilt vaatama. Kui te vaatate praegu õpetajat, siis teil ei ole seda viimast komitee, on nii veel, Kui Te vajutate, Fetch,
Õpetaja: siis ta tuleb sinna, kui ta Fedzi on ära teinud, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nii? Kui te nüüd võtate sellest ee, õpetajast, võtate Uue haru. New Branche õpetaja
Õpetaja: ja panete oma nime. Ja, noh, V. Kaks jälle.
Õpetaja: Mis iganes, V. Kolm, V, Neli üksteist puha. Te võite neid harusid nii palju teha. Teie arvutis pole kuhugi läinudki. Te pole Push I teinud.
Õpetaja: Haru läheb esi esimese Bushiga välja.
Õpetaja: Edaspidi lähed lihtsalt seal on. Vaata, on ju ka nii kreit.
Õpetaja: Kui te nüüd kreedite, siis te näete seda. Ad on nii?
Õpetaja: Ehk. Siis nüüd me kordame Ülevaate, mis on vajalikud sammud, et. Ee. Esiteks, esimene samm on Rain T, üks Committ.
Õpetaja: Noh, teen kui mingi bussi ütlen, et buss,
Õpetaja: siis Mis te teete samal ajal, kui mina teen oma teie juba. Rolback. Ite
Õpetaja: kõik, mis teil on seal tehtud, et ei oleks midagi rippumas,
Õpetaja: Siis tootate ära nii pea. Kui mina ütlen, et on pust, vajutate teie. Ja mida, Fetch?
Õpetaja: Niipea, kui Fedžo on ära tehtud, mis te Teete New Branch?
Õpetaja: Jah, ja panete, et ei saa panna teist korda. Noh, Artur ei saa panna teist korda. Artur, vaatas, et haru on juba olemas. Tal see sama haru peal ongi juba. Vaata, onju et lihtsalt paned. Ee. Artur V. Kaks oma nimi V. Kaks vee, kolm, V. Neli
Õpetaja: tee palju tahad, ei pea, siis saad kiirelt järgi tulla. Peaasi, et meie jaoks on see. Vaata, et kelle iganes järgi me Ootame. Soovime võimalikult ruttu jälle saada liikvele.
Õpetaja: Ja siin ongi see reegel. Mis me räägime? Me ei tulnud siia õppima seda. Ee, kus sul On mingisugune ee, koma või mingi asi puudu. Siis on katki, kui sa. Tahad. Noh, sul on ju see sama haru alles, Vaata endal Siis kogu oma töö ära. Isegi messegesis savi. Mis pealkiri läheb,
Õpetaja: kui mitte ära Sul on mingisugune süntaks on katki. Ee, liigu asjaga edasi. Või sind lihtsalt huvitab, et kust mul katki läks või kas ma olen võimeline seda vea vea üles leidma pärast oma vabal ajal, palun Väga checkout tee. Sellele harule
Õpetaja: tuleb jälle see sama seis ette. Kus sul oli mingi kaka on ju. Ja saad, vaadata, et kas ma Saan sellest jagu, et isegi kui sa tahad nagu õppida. Vaata, oi, ma ikkagi leian ülesse selle. Tee seda, aga tee seda omal. Ajal,
Õpetaja: Et, Ee, me ei tee seda nagu klassiruumi eest. Nii, noh, ei, ma juba rääkisin. Seda Kus sa oled olnud?
Õpetaja: Ei ole haluspetsiifiline Ee käs.
Õpetaja: Kui sa klikid mingisuguse haru peale, vaatad, mis käske saad käivitada selle haru peal, siis seal ei ole klikkida. Näitab mida sa, Masteri peal klikid selle auru peal, kus sa oled? Vaata, näiteks ta näitab, mis variante saad teha kuskile. Näita, sest, et see on niiöelda projekti ülene. Mida teeb? Fetch? Ma küsin ühe korra veel. Mida teeb? Fetch
Õpetaja: tekitab peegli sellest meie arvutisse. Mis on seal kõik Thats It klõbistab, palju tahad. Kas teeb mingeid muudatusi? Nagu meil koodis? Ei, me Working koodis. Ta ei tee, mis teeb muudatusi. Meie Working Cloud Is
Õpetaja: pull Jah, no siin menüüs on. Update Vaata, on ju. Update? On see?
Õpetaja: Kuidas
Õpetaja: Jah, jah, nii sai ka vaata aga. No ma tahtsin lihtsalt näidata, et et nagu kuidas oleks. Nüüd teeme küll pausi. Ee, siis tuleme tagasi. Ee, Ja siis proovime jõuda edasi asjadega.
Õpetaja: me teeme Viisteist Pizza Pausi Siis, kui te varem tagasi tulles. Kui te hakkate kogunema, Kui üle viieteist pinsa ei lase alla. Aa, panen, panen taimeri peale
Õpetaja: on taimeri, peale, et siis, kui te kuulate prääksumist
Õpetaja: kuskilt siis tähendab seda, et tulge tagasi,
Õpetaja: et ma mäletan, kuidas.
Õpetaja: Ahah,
Õpetaja: okei, potipiid, Kuulge, poisid, ma panen pausi peale rekordi. Ee, aidake mul meeles hoida
Õpetaja: mingi recording väiksemaks Ee, selline asi. Artur, Ee, Kuna Raine ei ole, Vaata, Siis pärast sinuga kasutame sinu läpakat.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis pärast teeb. Korra. Mängime selle setup i läbi. Vaata ja ma põhimõtteliselt lihtsalt näitan sulle Mida, nagu teha. Vaata, me tahaksime teha niimoodi, et. Ee. Kogu sellest, Ee, hetkest tuleb täiesti eraldi videoklipp,
Õpetaja: kus iga esitlus on peal ja Pausid on sealt nagu väljas. Vaata ja siis meil jääb see endale. See videoklipp täiesti eraldi. Alles sellest päevast, kes tahab kodus pärast vaadata. Et kuidas üks või teine asi oli. Vaata, et mis see klass on. Mis see meetod on? Noh, siis ei ole enam ühtegi. Vabandust,
Õpetaja: Mine vaata videot uuesti sellest asjast Ja ongi asi, mida vaadata kodus veel nädalavahetusel Korralikult, Rahulikult üle. Ee, ma nüüd räägin seda ka, et Need teemad, need teemad, mis ee, sai enamvähem valitud, on muidugi osa teemadest üldse kontseptsioonidest, mis
Õpetaja: ee niiöelda objektori tervitusprogemisest on, aga need on Ühed kõige tähtsamad.
Õpetaja: Ja siin on. Selles mõttes on pointi ee panustada aega energiat. Aa, et need tõesti need kontseptsioonid võimalikult selgeks õppida? Ee, Mis te arvate, miks ma ütlen niimoodi, et on? On väga suur point neid selgeks õppida.
Õpetaja: Miks, Miks tuleks panna väga palju rõhku, et need asjad endale tõesti hästi selgeks teha.
Õpetaja: Mis see präänika on? Kasutad igapäevaselt. Ja nüüd ma toon siia veel juurde. Vahet pole, mis keel
Õpetaja: Ma Mõtlen, kirja. Viis küüt on mida iganes. Need kon Need on konseptsioonid. Eelkõige
Õpetaja: kirja viiskib sinna juurde. Kuidas jaavas meetodit. Teha. Väga tore, Aga mis asi on meetod, Kuidas ta töötab? Mis asi on sisend? Mis asi on tagastus? Mis asi on, Flash? Mis asi on Kõik Need teemad on üleüldised. Kontseptsioonid
Õpetaja: Pole vahet, kuhu te lähete. Need on A, B, C.
Õpetaja: Meid ei huvita veel Seal Z, Y ja nii edasi. Need on hilisem teema. Nice to have abc.
Õpetaja: Ee, need on põhiteemad,
Õpetaja: et siin on mõtet nagu teil niigi saab olema. Raske Ärge Unustage ära, teil saab olema see Cloud Code ja igast muud asjad ei saab olema nagu niigi. Asi, mis võtab teil seda ee, praktikat Vähemaks seda nagu asjadest arusaamist võtab vähemaks.
Õpetaja: Teil on taas ka head. Te peate päriselt õppima programiskontseptsiooni ka ära ja samal ajal kasutada, ma ütlen siin. Te võite väga hästi saada hakkama nende tööriistade ja asjadega I asjadega.
Õpetaja: Aga kui te asjadest aru ei saa, siis on paha lugu. Te peate ikkagi Productionis. Te vastutate iga rea eest
Õpetaja: Ja väga piinlik Oleks ka tegelikult, kui oled juba mingisugune. Ma ei tea jupp aega olnud juba kuskil Ja, juba. Noh, praktikad juba on nagu olnud ka asja valmis ehitanud. Ja tegelikult ikka ei saa aru mis kuradi Asi on klass. Mis asi on meetod? Milleks on need getterid ja setterid,
Õpetaja: mismoodi töötab If lause. Ja kui neid asju ei tea, siis nagu,
Õpetaja: Ee, see. See ei aita teid. See ei aita teid. Teid aitab kontseptsioonid selles mõttes. Ee, kindlasti. Ee, Jah,
Õpetaja: Videatus on hästi.
Õpetaja: Aa, No teeme selle asja ka lahti. Vaata, et ee. Paneme siis esimese video ära. Ee, ma näitan kuidas.
Õpetaja: Jaa, ma näitan ära. Kuidas. Ee, Ma panen ühe video, siis sinna Lingi jagasime või? See oli padlet. Is oli, onju.
Õpetaja: Ee, see spreadshit mäletate?
Õpetaja: Ma korra vaatan ka üle, Kas ta on anne? Valiti padat. Mul on. Pange ka endale. Siia. Fo seal. Näete, et te saate vajutada niukest tärnikest
Õpetaja: panna. Teate, see Zoom Recording Ud.
Õpetaja: Ja siin on see Zoomi video. Et Huvitav, kas seda Share ides ta jätab. Meelde ka tabi või mitte, Mis te Arvate jäta või? Jäta,
Õpetaja: aeg pole. Suudate selle klõpsa ära teha? Ikka on ju? On meeles. Zoomi videod on siin. Ee, tänane kuupäev. No See võibki eilne kuupäev jääda. Ma lähen nüüd kohta, kus teil ligipääsu pole.
Õpetaja: Aga minul on.
Õpetaja: Ee, lähen siis Tänase. Ee. Eilse Miitingu. Eile Ju tegime mingi recordingu.
Õpetaja: Nii, Ee, nüüd ma näitan seda. Vahet ee, palun. See on nüüd tähelepanem. Sind pange tähele ka. Vaata, et te Siis teaksite.
Õpetaja: Ee, see oli Eile, onju
Õpetaja: Kaheksa minutit videot. Amazing Ee, kahes Recording Us. Üks on üks minut ja kolmkümmend üks. Seda pole isegi vaja. Ma arvan, et see oli lihtsalt alguses. Kui panin käima midagi. Vaata, onju kuidas
Õpetaja: Aa, siis on ikka vaja. Ee, ühesõnaga. Aa, Mina panen. Ma pean natukene meenutama. Vaata praegult, Ma saaksin võtta eraldi lingi. Video. Üks ja video kaks.
Õpetaja: Nii, aga mina tegelikult tahaks saada Hoopis ee.
Õpetaja: Coopi Link With Password, mis tegelikult on Mõlemale vaatame, kuidas see töötab. Ma teen korra Inko gnita lahti.
Õpetaja: Incognito. Windo. Teate, mis Incognito tähendab, et mingid sisselogimist asjad siin sellel lehehetkel ei ole. Ei toimi. Ee, vaatame, kuhu see läheb. Bad Request. Noh, väga kasulik siis Ja
Õpetaja: Copy link. Või? Ma loetsen seda Ja midagi. Siin on ju Bad Request. Anyone, mitte link.
Õpetaja: Ee korra Ma mõtlen, kus kohast sai, Nagu niukest. Vaata, siin on kaks videot. Ma ei taha nagu niimoodi teha. Video, eks? Ja video kaks
Õpetaja: Ja ma tegingi vanasti niimoodi, ma mäleta. Äkki siit saab selle hoopis Share Copy link või
Õpetaja: üldse ei taha nagu asjata. Ee,
Õpetaja: kuule, ee, korra. Ma tean, milles on asi. Ma teen korra tekstidokumendi lahti. Siis tuleb see asi nagu ee nähtavale. Ta Teeb seda kahes osas.
Õpetaja: Näete, Parool on siin eraldi tekstigaud. Link on Siin Ma oleks pidanud ta siia. Vot see on see link, mida ma peaksin jagama. Ma proovin nüüd selle. Kõigepealt Ära
Õpetaja: küsib i Mille ma alati panen. Sinna Spreadsheet. Ile ka. Näete, siin on ee. Videot kasutatakse. Kas siin on ära peidetud? Ei ole
Õpetaja: Abcd, ei ole Insert. Kolm tude leht.
Õpetaja: Huvitav, vanasti oli. Ma olen lihtsalt ära kustutanud. Ee, panen sinna juurde.
Õpetaja: See sama on
Õpetaja: nii. See sama on link. Ee, copy link. Panen selle siia juurde. Noh, te saate juba idee järgi. Proovida siis seda ka. Kes tahab. Ee, kui läheb sinna Nii, Aga nüüd ma saan ise proovida Mul oli see leht. Oli lahti.
Õpetaja: Budge Recording.
Õpetaja: Siin oli kaks videot. Oli nii,
Õpetaja: on ju? Me nägime siin. Nüüd on niimoodi, et näete. Ta mängib seda esimest. Ee, videot lõpuni. Siis ta läheb järgmise juurde. Kui te tahate teist videot vaadata, Kohe on siin Niukene nupp. Nagu
Õpetaja: aru, meil hakkab tulema alati hommik ja õhtu hommik. Ja õhtu tänase päeva kohta Teeme hommiku õhtu ja Presentatsioonid, me teeme seda kolm korda. Kolm videot, kaks korda Vajutan stop. Ja ühesõnaga,
Õpetaja: enne kui mina. Kui ma ära lähen, vajutan stop, siis Sellest tekib üks video. Ee, et ee, Selle nupuga on võimalik Siis nagu minna järgmise peale. Näed, Recording kaks
Õpetaja: saab minna. Rekordi ongi üks Saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Ja, ee, kui ma, ee. Kui see renderdamine võtab aega ja ta arvestab seda sellest hetkest, ta hakkab ta tegelikult neid põhimõtteliselt tegema, kui ma vaitan. Stop. Aga ta ei näita seda asja ennem, kui viimane video on ära. Niiöelda renderdan,
Õpetaja: et, ee, kui ma Näiteks koolituse lõpus siin. Ütleme päeva lõpus. Panen lingi siis ta alguses. Võib olla niimoodi. Et midagi ei näita, sest et siis,
Õpetaja: noh, tänast Videot saab vaadata juba meil praegu Rekordid on nii?
Õpetaja: Ee, et ma saan juba praegu täna tegelikult minna. Nagu näed processing tulla siia alla mõttes vale asja. Aa, Siin oli see. Sellel ee, esilehel on see lingikene Share? Ma võtan siit Copy link With Code. Tulen Panen endale korra kuskile. See on tänane video
Õpetaja: copy link.
Õpetaja: Ma saan juba tulla. Panna selle ette. Ära
Õpetaja: põmm ja tulen panen selle parooli ka.
Õpetaja: Noh, Vastikult ujub siit üle ääre ma. Panen niimoodi et, ära tee keskele vaid tee vasakule nii.
Õpetaja: On video. On link
Õpetaja: kus, see nüüd mängib Aga sa mängib siin sellest teisest aknast.
Õpetaja: Ja
Õpetaja: nii, ee, et ee, Eilne hakkas mul taustal mängima. Mul see teine lahti Onju Ee, Nüüd, Ee, ma saan selle üle kontrollida, kui ma võtan selle lingi. Ma teen korra jälle uuesti. Ja nüüd vaatame videot, mis ei ole veel ära renderdanud, et saaksite aru, et kuidas. See näeb lihtsalt välja.
Õpetaja: Ee, võtan selle siis ta näitab niukest asja. Recording is processing. Ehk see tähendab seda, et peate tulema tagasi.
Õpetaja: Noh, nagu palgapäeval saate
Õpetaja: F viite toksida, et kas tuleb palk üle või ei. Tule Tänapäeval tuleb notification Id. See lõbu on ka kadunud. Töötab, mis? Ma mõtlen ikka? Jah,
Õpetaja: F. Vi S on browser is Refresh,
Õpetaja: kes ei oleks istunud seal oma Statementil. Nagu et
Õpetaja: Kurat, on ju esimene. Mis süsteem on?
Õpetaja: Tuleb, Ei, tule. Vanasti. On eid ka.
Õpetaja: No neid videosid. Vaata, Gif Id on? Vaata, klõbistab või on ära kulunud F viis, et näitab keyboard. Il Üks nupp on nagu kiirelt saab Refresh Ida, Te saate mõttes aru on ju praegune Video ei ole process. Siis ta näitab midagi niukest. Teilselt saab vaadata. Ee, videos Käsitletud teemad. Sellega Ma tegelen, Ee, Ma täna ei viitsi sellega tegeleda. Tegeleme sellega homme,
Õpetaja: et seal tekiks mingid noodid ja tekiks ka mingi kokkuvõte.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis sai
Õpetaja: Ma lihtsalt, Aeg on Täna natukene vähem. Võibolla vahetunnil. Ma panen selle asja käima. Võibolla näitan ka. Vaatame nii. Ee, siia. Siis tuleb lihtsalt järgmine kuupäev. Mis on tänane kuupäev?
Õpetaja: Noh, ei tulegi niimoodi. Automaatselt Hakkasid seda tegema, mis? Täiesti?
Õpetaja: Oh, aastad. Okei, ta ei võta seda kui kuupäeva miks, Sellepärast, et see formaat ei ole tema jaoks õige. Neliteist punkt. Ee, null, Neli punkt. Kakstuhat Kakskümmend kuus.
Õpetaja: Siis ta muutub kuupäevaks ja kui Ma tõmban uue rea.
Õpetaja: Siis ta peaks nüüd mitte aasta numbrit muutma, vaid kuupäeva klaverit.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuidas ma saan lihtsalt teid panna?
Õpetaja: Noo,
Õpetaja: aga Mis mind see aitab, siis ta teeb, lihtsalt, kurat. Noh, okei Now.
Õpetaja: Oo. See formaat tundub ka natukene liiga.
Õpetaja: Oota, aga ma tean vanasti Kui ma copy pastein otse siit video pealt, siis ma tean, et ta alati võttis kuidagi teksti. Ta teeb kindlalt ümber See siin
Õpetaja: niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Aa,
Õpetaja: vot väga hea. Eile oli neljateistkümnes põmm, tõmm, tõmm.
Õpetaja: No värv ei meeldi nii. Ee, Nüüd kui teen
Õpetaja: aga vist saaks seda formaati muuta ka Mm, kus on formaat?
Õpetaja: Noh, Excelis, ma teaksin, aga ma ei oska format. Äkki vä number automatic date Aa. Usa on ju?
Õpetaja: Ah, persse. Las olla Nii mõttest saate aru. Kuupäevad on siin.
Õpetaja: Sobib. Tšau, ee. Seda rohkem teemat ei käsitle, et siia siis tulevad. Need Ee, videod hakkavad tulema. Ja mis teil siin veel on olemas? Mida me homme? Mida ma kavatsen homme näidata? Mis me teeme, on see, Ma võtan, mitte Cloud Koodiga Kavatse oma token it selle jaoks kulutada.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin on võimalik. Siis Vähemalt minul on võimalik alla tõmmata Aa Eraldi ka. Ee, no siit on ka võimalik põhimõtteliselt alla tõmmata. Download, Ib. Kõik siis vist. Alla Ee, ma mõtlen, et, ee. Minul on veel võimalik. Download Ida alla transkrit.
Õpetaja: Mis asi on transcript?
Õpetaja: Kas keegi?
Õpetaja: See see, mis ma kõik olen päev läbi äppinud, Palun väga.
Õpetaja: Noh, Eile mis ma selle esimese video jooksul jääb? Isin, teeme lahti.
Õpetaja: Teeme selle not Bad I ka lahti, et lihtsalt näidata.
Õpetaja: Jah, jah, noh, Las ta siis rekordib. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, las ta siis rekordib ka selle osa peale. Ma tean, et Screenshot
Õpetaja: teeme siis korda, blabla Saate ma tast aru. Subtiitrid.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta. Oo, ta. Isegi ütleb õpetaja, Sest et ta ta näeb, kui erinevad inimesed vestluses nagu räägiks, siis oleks see Ka peal oleks mõnus on ju
Õpetaja: nii? Mis ma kavatsen homme teha on see, et ma ütlen, nagu ma võtan selle faili panen selle Projekti juurde ütlen, mitte. Siin on nii palju ridu. Vaadake, kui palju ridu siin on.
Õpetaja: Minu arust paremini. Siin on kaks tuhat kuussada. Rida. Tähemärkidest ei oska isegi mõelda. Ja ma ütlen, et ole hea. Palun tee lihtsalt kokkuvõte, et mis teemat siin on käsitletud. Oot, oot, see On üks osa tee ka õppematerjalid.
Õpetaja: Mida iganes siin räägitakse, tee õppematerjalid. Ta teeb Md Faili. Me topime oma toksi alla. See selle on projektiga kaasas. Palun väga
Õpetaja: Tahate vaadata midagi, mis asja arutasime? Materjalid on olemas.
Õpetaja: Teemad on olemas. Leiad õige video ülesse. Teil ei ole ühtegi Vabandust,
Õpetaja: ee. Mäletate, ma rääkisin seda, et see hobuse teema. Sa saad hobuseveeni viia.
Õpetaja: Aga kas ta joob? On juba hobuse enda teha? Ta ei saa sundida teda,
Õpetaja: et ee, kellel on seda aega, energiat ja võimalust Te saate tööd teha.
Õpetaja: Te peate tööd tegema, kes tahavad saada kuhugi selles sektoris. Selles asjas see ei tule tasuta. Ma ei räägi seda kuidagi pahast tundest, vaid ma räägin nagu seda, et kui ma Olen näinud siit samast kursuselt. On Ääretult palju edukaid inimesi
Õpetaja: aga. Millised need inimesed alati on on? Ee? Niuksed, jooned. On nende sees töökus
Õpetaja: Töökus on Ee, see ühine asi. Neil kõigel.
Õpetaja: Need, kes, nagu, ee, mõned on imestavad nagu, et neil ei lähe nagu nii hästi, Ei, Tule nii kergelt.
Õpetaja: Nad ei tee tegelikult sellist tööd.
Õpetaja: Mul on inimesed, kes lähevad koju ja nad lihtsalt nagu võtavad lahti ja teevad, nad lähevad praktikale. Nad iga päev õhtul Midagi teevad nad nädalavahetusel Midagi teevad alguses
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et alguses on vaja ennast tõestada, on vaja jõuda kuhugi joonele
Õpetaja: ja need inimesed oskavad. Ja kus need musternäidised on ka kui ringi tee. Need, kes toimivad seal jätkukoolitusele. Nad on nüüd ühe tüdruku Slaid
Õpetaja: Omg. Ta käis meil rääkimas. Ee, oma kogemustest. Ta ei olnud minu grupis.
Õpetaja: See oli Niukene. Ma olen nüüd tööloomasid näinud ka, muidugi Aga ma võin ühte asja öelda Ka
Õpetaja: Ee, ma olen näinud. Ma olen ka näinud ka muidugi nihukest näidet. Ee, üks tüdruk tuleb mul kohe meelde minu esimesest grupist.
Õpetaja: Monster monster töökas, inimene, tohutu distsipliin ja jaks proovida ja pusida ja teha asju aga ta ei jäänud lõpuks programmeerijaks. Ta läks ja ta tegi veidi aega, aga ta lõpuks ei jäänud selle peale. Sellepärast Ta leidis, et see pole ikkagi tema jaoks. Ma Ei, mäleta, mis ma Rääkisin sellest kirest
Õpetaja: töökus. Lihtsalt töökus. Niukene. Ee, seal tõde Ja õigus. Sa võid seda kraavi kaevas
Õpetaja: niukseid, inimesi on ka vaata kes võivad mingit ajuvaba kraavi kaevata aastaid
Õpetaja: ja teha seda. Ära. Vaata, on ju? Aga see ei ole jätkusuutlik. Võibolla selles mõttes, et see ei ole see, mida nad teha tahavad. Aga lihtsalt. Tavaliselt see kipub nii olema. Kui sul ongi kirg,
Õpetaja: siis tavaliselt on ka töökus.
Õpetaja: Aga sul võib ka kirg olla. Aga sa võid panna laiska nagu. Noh, me saame hakkama ja kõik ära Vaata,
Õpetaja: kui see töötab, siis see töötab veegitil ju meikid.
Õpetaja: Aga kui sa tahad saada kuhugi tasemele kunagi ja kuskil olla kõva vend ja teenida kõva pappi, Siis ilmselt peab ikka tööd tegema. Kas Sa kohe pead tegema? Tööd Hiljem pead tegema tööd. Vahet pole kuskil. Sa pead selle töö Ära tegema.
Õpetaja: Mina olen ka väga palju tööd teinud. Ma olin eile tegelikult kell kaheni üleval.
Õpetaja: Ee, tulin siia ikka. Ma teen asju tegelikult mul Lihtsalt oli üks projekt. Oli, mõtlesin. Ma ei saanud magada Mul Chatiga telefonis toksin. See oli kohutav, lihtsalt. Nii see selleks.
Õpetaja: Ee, teeme siis tööd
Õpetaja: rekordi. Vot see jäi peale Väga tähtis Eraldi punkt. Ee chat. Kui sa teed sellest pärast kokkuvõtet, too eraldi punkt välja. Tööd peab tegema.
Õpetaja: Pane see sinna ee ülesse Summerisse.
Õpetaja: Juhendid on antud.
Õpetaja: Ma räägin põhimõtteliselt iseenda Chat i käsuga. Tore Liigume edasi.
Õpetaja: Nii. Ee, saite kõik Joonele. Olete täpselt seal, kus mina On teil see Aa?
Õpetaja: Mitte et meil seda Ad on vaja, aga vähemalt ülejäänud asjad võiksid olla. Ee, Paneme Frontence serveri käima.
Õpetaja: Ee, vaatame, kuhu me jäime. Ee, meil on siin. To do olemas.
Õpetaja: Ee, Selecti. Kas me jõudsime ära? Teha? Tegime Niukse Selecti Näete. Nüüd on täpselt. See paneb Brauseri käima, Kui mõnus on, kui on olemas kuskil link, Mis on Local Ost? Kaheksakümmend kaheksakümmend. Üks,
Õpetaja: kui ei ole, noh, siis te saate loomulikult rannimise käigus
Õpetaja: Scrollida ja otsida ülesse selle lingi,
Õpetaja: sest käsi püsti kellel on see favorite seal olemas.
Õpetaja: Käsi püsti. Kes paneb selle nüüd favoritsi?
Õpetaja: Väga hea, käsi püsti. Kes ei kavatsegi panna seda
Õpetaja: Väga hea, õige suhtumine. Tirige see Kohe siia, Esimeseks
Õpetaja: seal. Localost. Kaheksakümmend. Kaheksakümmend, üks. Te võite selle nimeks panna Pank me hakkame niikuinii panka tegema.
Õpetaja: Enamus ajast pärast saate seda. Muuta. Issand, mis teil on Niimoodi kah? Mis küll juhtus? Mis asja?
Õpetaja: Kaks panka, kaks lehte. Nii, ee, okei. Me jõudsime nupuni.
Õpetaja: Tegime ära Nupp lisaklientsüsteemi.
Õpetaja: Vaata, mis meil. Ee, nüüd järgmisena siin on
Õpetaja: Texteeria.
Õpetaja: Ee, paneme siia enne seda nuppu. Te ei pea. Noh, see on siin On ka see koht. Te võite vaadata, kui te tahate
Õpetaja: ise. Kuidas tunnete, kas kirjutate või mitte.
Õpetaja: Ma panen siia lihtsalt ühe H viis Headeri väiksema headeri ja panen. Ee, minu tutvustus
Õpetaja: ja siia alla. Ma tahan teha niukse asja nagu texteeria,
Õpetaja: mis ma siit valin, Loomulikult selle Templi.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ta pakub Id Sid. Need atribuudid tihtipeale. Kustutame ära. Ee, päriselus oleks neid justkui rohkem vaja. Aga voes ei ole. Vaja
Õpetaja: poes Ei ole vaja, Id, Sid ja Name asju. No name. I. Mõnes kohas on vaja. Kui sa tahad grupeerida. Ee, all in good time, Mis Võiks jääda? See kols. Kolmkümmend võib jääda. Rose. Kümme. Võib jääda ja teksteeria las. Ta praegu olla korra tühi aga, siia saab tegelikult kirjutada. Kohe vaatame,
Õpetaja: mis nüüd juhtus, On Niukene Texteeria.
Õpetaja: Võibolla paneme prei ka siia.
Õpetaja: Nii, on siin kastikene. See on teksteeria, mis on selle Ja selle vahe?
Õpetaja: No ei ole. Mõlemasse. Saad sama palju teksti kirjutada. Sisuliselt lõputult.
Õpetaja: Midagi muud on siin.
Õpetaja: Kuidas mitme rea peal Siin ei Ole võimalik minna rida alla.
Õpetaja: Tee, mis tahad, Siin on võimalik. See on see vahe.
Õpetaja: Oi, kui ma näen niukest vormi, kui ma olen, näinud. Tavaliselt inimesed teevad alati selle. Googel. Ee, mitte. Vabandust, Sharepoint. Vorms iga mingisugune vorm Andke. Meile infot mingit tagasisidet ja edasi.
Õpetaja: Ja nad panevad sinna tavalise kasti, kus läheb palju teksti
Õpetaja: Ma kirjutan palju tekste. Ma jõuan lõppu. Ma tahaks. Nüüd vaataks nüüd nagu taipad üle tegema Hakkan Mm, plaatsi alguses. Sa ei hakka niimoodi ee liikuma.
Õpetaja: Jah, super. Aitäh, et tegin niukse vormi. Ee, ma kahjuks ma ei jäta kunagi meelde. Mu naine oli eile ülimalt Fisk. Ma kujutan ette, kui Fisk ta oli. Ta ei ole nagu see. Talle ei meeldi niigi.
Õpetaja: Tal Oli vaja tegeleda ühe kalmistu administratiivtöötajaga. Ee, ajades mingit paberimajandust korda. Nemad kogu aeg Ee, viitasid et minge meie süsteemi Audi Audi Audi mingi Vana mutt oli tal vastas.
Õpetaja: Ja probleem. Oli see, et seal ei olnud nuppu ega vaadet, millega saaks seda toimingut teha. Inimene ei saa aru.
Õpetaja: Ei, ei, mine sinna. Ütle, Naine palus. Palun lihtsalt võtke see dokument läbi meili vastu allkirjastatud kõik asjad. No problem, pange see ise süsteemi Ei, meil on see Audi. Kõik peab audist läbi Audi käima. Vaata, Audi. See auditor.
Õpetaja: Ja siis nüüd tuleb.
Õpetaja: Seal oli siis kontroll peal, et kõik väljad peavad olema täidetud väljast korrektsed ja mis iganes nõuetega. Nüüd tuleb brutal koht nagu ma pooks ülesse selle inimese,
Õpetaja: kes Selle Tegi
Õpetaja: ma. Ma. Nagu selles mõttes ma vahel näen vorme. Ja ma mõtlen, et mu mu õpilased ei tõi ka niisugust pahna,
Õpetaja: kui Sa teed ühe vea, siis ta ütleb sulle, et sa tegid vea
Õpetaja: ja teed kogu blanketi tühjaks. Kõik välja.
Õpetaja: Gay, make you pay
Õpetaja: ja Ma kujut. Noh, mu naine oli Jumala piss. Ta rääkis mulle. Ta oli juba närvis. Ma kujutan ette, kui närvis ta oli, ta oli Juba nagu ta oli juba tegelt kaotamas juba aruannet. Hästi Ta ütles, et ta ütles ilma naljata. Illustra illus ilma nagu liialdamata, ta ütles, et
Õpetaja: ta tegi kolmkümmend korda. Seda ma küsingi Copy Base, et kuskile mujale seda ta ei teinud. Vaata, mina oleks juba läinud teise lahenduse peale, aga täpselt nii, Vaata on ju.
Õpetaja: Ee, et mis miks oleks küsimus? Mis eesmärki? Kas on meelega nii tehtud?
Õpetaja: Kui see on meelega niimoodi tehtud, siis ma mõtlen, nad on täitsa napakad, nagu lollakad.
Õpetaja: Ja kui nad on kogemata niukse teinud, siis ma ütlen. Ma ei suuda uskuda, et nagu. See on ju kuskil mingi rahade eest tellitud. Keegi ei maksnud selle Või siis. Tõesti. Mingi suvaline vend koha sealt sellest Kalmistun mingisugust mingis mõttes Audi keskkonna. Ja siis tegi mingi niukse kägi kokku kolmanda klassi.
Õpetaja: Ja ma ütlen, ma päriselt minu õpilased ka ei ole kunagi niukest jama teinud, Aga ma ei. Ma isegi. Ma ma programmiliselt isegi ei kujuta ette, kas
Õpetaja: kui sul siis nagu näitab dialoogi Ja ta teeb lihtsalt refresh page,
Õpetaja: et kuidas see käsk sinna sisse läheks või miks, või nagu kuidas see kogemata saab tulla. Ma lihtsalt Ei saa aru, kuidas kogemata saab tulla. Mina nagu praegu proge. Progendajana ei saa aru, mis, kuidas
Õpetaja: tuleb välja nagu jah ja põhiline oli see. Vaata, kui ta kogu aeg suunati. Vaata, nagu, et ee. Ja siis seal on mingi nupp ja tuleb mingi vaade. Ma
Õpetaja: siin ei ole. Seda
Õpetaja: te vajate Lihtsalt juhendamist. Mul on vaja mingisugust kuradi juhendamist. Siin ei ole nuppu. Kas teil on juhtunud seda? Minul on ka. Ma olen olnud nendes probleemides, et ma. Räägin klienditoega ja nad jäpivad mingisugust asjast. Siis mul on nagu see, et ma panen neile kohe Meili täiega. Mul on üldise abi.
Õpetaja: Teil tuleb Screenshot. Näidake mul. Kus see on, Siis on nagu suur vend täis öelda. Oi, jah, teil on õigus. No mida? Ma üritan teile öelda. Miks te ei usu mind?
Õpetaja: Valetan niisama või Mul on vaja mingi toiming lõpuni teha, ma Tean oma elu põnema, eksole? Jah, siin on mingi nupukene. Ja te viitate sellele alati võimalus, et ma olen pime, onju? Ma olengi pime, Ma ei leia kunagi asju. Kodust. Ülesse. Nina all, on aga päriselt vormilt. Ma leian nupu ülesse.
Õpetaja: Noh, ei leia. Tähendab, siis kui ei Ole
Õpetaja: Jah, võiks, küll. Jah,
Õpetaja: Jaa, võib. Jaan, jagan kontakte. No, kui sul on mingi kuuekümne aastane mammi seal teisel pool siis you can You can Imagine it.
Õpetaja: Ee, on siis üle mitme rea Kirjutamine.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mina toon korra näite siia.
Õpetaja: Aa, mis on selle ja selle value Erinevus, saate aru? Nimetatakse illustratiivsem
Õpetaja: Saate aru on? See mis ei ole tegelik väärtus siin kasti sees, vaid lihtsalt vihje.
Õpetaja: Ee, nagu ee siia Kirju ta pikemalt.
Õpetaja: Kui tore inimene sa oled. Bla blabla, Blabla Mida iganes. Ee, ma võtan nüüd selle väljuse It ära
Õpetaja: saate aru, on ju see on.
Õpetaja: See Ei ole päris tekst siin sees vaid. Kui kõik on tühi, siis ma näen,
Õpetaja: mida see nagu peaks kirjutama või Mida iganes, Nii, Nüüd ma näitan ühte asja veel. See tuleb meile mängu. See tuleb meile mängu nagu arenduses.
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele, et kui Mina kirjutan siia sisse, Pbb, Siis see on seal kastis. Selles interaktiivses elemendis väärtusena olemas on
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui ma kasutan selle siit ära Ja võtan üks atribuudi nagu valuaeg. Ma ei mäleta, kas sealt ikka saab
Õpetaja: palve? Sa ei taha mulle pakkuda seda praegu Põrsas, Ee Võibolla Ikkagi ei tohi siin, Sest ma näitan kuskil mujal seda välju ja panen Ccc.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, see element seda ei toeta. Ma võtan siit Ülevalt See input John C siin.
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen siia atribuudi value, pöördub, rain
Õpetaja: siis See väärtus on siin. Sees. Saate aru, Enamus enamus Interaktiivsetel elementidel on on olemas tükki atribuut nagu value.
Õpetaja: Nii Hoiame seda meeles. Ja see tähendab, seda, et selle välju abil selle välju atribuudi abil on meil võimalik siis tegelikult kahte asja. Vaata selle välju abil. Me saame anda väärtust, Aga hiljem mis meid huvitab, on hoopis see, et selle abil saab ka võtta. Väärtust. Väärtus on eraldi atribuut.
Õpetaja: Nii, okei, lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, on tehtud.
Õpetaja: Mul on üks küsimus. Noh, tagasi võtta. Millega ma saan uuesti?
Õpetaja: Jah, ee, nii, lähme edasi. Ee, kui ee. Järgmisena, Mis me tahame vaadata, on Checkbox
Õpetaja: Ee, mis vahe, on? Checkbox ja Radio Keegi teab.
Õpetaja: Kõigil on jah. Ee. Esialgu teeme siis. Ee, teeme.
Õpetaja: Teeme esialgu radio. Ee, see on input Input I asi, Mäletad, input? Il on erinevad date ja tekst. Ja number on olemas ka niisugune asi. Nagu,
Õpetaja: Ee, praegu ei taha. Checkboxiot,
Õpetaja: imp ja R Põhimõtteliselt toob teil selle radio siia lähedusse noote nooleklastega. Tule tulge. Valige radio.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis. Mina panen hetkel need Id ja Names on kustutan Ära Hetkel mind see ei huvita.
Õpetaja: Nüüd siia alla Tuli Mummo tuli.
Õpetaja: Ee, kohe Vaatame, et seda oleks parem aru saada. Siis paneme siia otsa. Näiteks label.
Õpetaja: Ja ma panen siia kirja. Mees on siin all, mees.
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen nüüd nendest kahest asjast tublikaadi, panen alumisele, naine.
Õpetaja: Nii, Noh, paneme ühe breigi ka vahele. Lihtsalt ilma silmale. On nagu parem näha üksteise all. Mees, naine,
Õpetaja: see ülesse. Võibolla tulen. Panen siis Korra H. Viis ja panen labelina sugu,
Õpetaja: Saate aru? Ma lihtsalt saad valida, Vaata, et kes ma. Kes ma olen, mees või naine
Õpetaja: tänapäeval On Eesti muid asju ka veel. Ee, keegi on seda saadet vaadanud. Alasti ahvatlus, kus nad tulevad Kastidest
Õpetaja: Üks haaval välja. Seal on alati Igasugused põnevad inimesed Alati ei olegi nagu väga
Õpetaja: defineeritud, et kes nad nagu täpselt on, Ee, väga vahva saade.
Õpetaja: Vahel ikka on seda huvitav vaadata, Eriti kui on Soome Special So Need Soome osad, Siis soomlased on ikkagi naabrid ja mõtlevad, et Issand, kus seal on huvitavad inimesi Ülevabameelsed inimesed üldse nagu julgevad tulla teleka ette.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis ma nii, ee, meesnaine.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui me praegu vaatame, kuidas see tegelikult peaks töötama, on see, et saad ühte või teist valida.
Õpetaja: Meil on Refreshiga, et kui ma olin naine, mees, siis tundub, et nad nagu
Õpetaja: nad ei Ole nagu kuidagi omavahel seotud. Vaata, ta ei saa aru et on üks prukk
Õpetaja: siis siin. Aa, vahel. Kui te tahate mingisugust grupeerimist teha Nendel kahel asjal.
Õpetaja: Siis tuleb kasutada niukest atribuuti nagu name mitte Id. Vaid name.
Õpetaja: Mina panen siin näiteks name Gender. Panen selle nimeks
Õpetaja: ja Tulen siin, inputis, Panen samamoodi, et tema nagu. See on ka enda. Nagu grupeerimine.
Õpetaja: Siis Nüüd Html Browser vaatab seda asja natuke teistmoodi,
Õpetaja: nüüd Ta vaatab, et need on kuidagi omavahel seotud mõndame. Trade. Kui ma tulen siia ja vajutan ühte,
Õpetaja: vajutan test, siis on soovitud Tulemus saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen mingisugused checkboxid juurde ja ma soovin, et see oleks osa sellest valikust, siis sama
Õpetaja: name on see, mis aitab
Õpetaja: Nii järgmisena paneme võibolla Breigi ka siia. Ee, järgmisena
Õpetaja: ee, siis. Ee. Teeme siia alla. Input, imp ja checkbox, c,
Õpetaja: ee, checkboxist Ma kustutan Ära need name ja It atribuudid, Need mind ei huvita. Hetkel
Õpetaja: nii tuli siia mingi mummu.
Õpetaja: Panen korra võibolla siia Headeri ka ülesse H Viis näiteks, et mingi kirjeldav tekst. Ee,
Õpetaja: tingimused
Õpetaja: on tingimused.
Õpetaja: Ee, panen siia järgi. Kuidas ma saan panna, kui ma panen praegult lihtsalt siia Mingit, ee, teksti. Näiteks. Ee. Mingi paragraafiga.
Õpetaja: Ärge tehke siin korra vaatamiskoht.
Õpetaja: Siis ta tuleb sinna niimoodi alla.
Õpetaja: Kuidas Ma saan garanteeritult panna teksti, Aga niimoodi, et mul on võimalik stiili ka muuta, kui ma panen lihtsalt praegu siia teksti. Ma panen korra. Ma ei mäleta, kuidas input töötab. Ma panen teksti niimoodi, et see ei ole ühegi elemendi sees. Nii saab ka teha, Aga see ei ole väga, väga soovitatav tava, Ta jääb siia järgi.
Õpetaja: Mis on, Fine? Ma saavutan selle, mis ma tahan. Vaata, et ma tahan siia panna. Nagu teksti. Olen nõus tingimustega
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: mõttest saate aru, on ju? Aga see ei ole õige käitumine. Sellepärast, et ma ei saa Csss iga talle mingisugust stiili anda, värvi Muuta paigutust või mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Aga mis on see element, mis Ee võimaldab kirjutada meil tekstidega niimoodi, et ta ei tee mingisuguseid line break E. Põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: spänn.
Õpetaja: Paneme korra siia spänni.
Õpetaja: Spanja tab ja paned selle teksti? Noh, kogemata. Mul on mingi vale asi. Mälus Olen Ee Olen,
Õpetaja: ma olen, olen. Ma panen meelega niimoodi. Olen tingimustega nõus.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd, kandja siis see tikpoks. Siis tähistaks seda. Vaata, et olen, nõus,
Õpetaja: võibolla See lisaklientsüsteem. Ja selle ma nüüd üldse koristan. Siit ülevalt kuskilt ära, et oleks kogu aeg all, tulen võtan mingid Breigid ja selle patani ära, et see tunduks kuidagi loogiline. Vaata, ma panen täitsa Body lõppu. Esialgu,
Õpetaja: Ee, las ta olla siin kogu aeg siin kuskil all,
Õpetaja: mõni Break. Võibolla juurde. Umbes nii. Saate aru, et lõpus kanda nagu inimene. Nagu meie pank Üheksakümnendate stiilid. Pank meie kontorid, Rain Ee, kus sa Checkbox, Kus sa oled? Ripp Menüü kadus. Vahet pole, ennem oli. Aa, siin on linn. Kand uut inimest lisada. Pangasüsteemi. Oletan, et sa mingi Admin tööriist või mida iganes,
Õpetaja: Nii jõuame alla poole
Õpetaja: me oleme tagasi. Ülesanne Meid huvitas see, et meil on siis mingid tingimused et järgmine Samm oleks ka enda juba, et. Noh, saad siis nuppu vajutada, Onju,
Õpetaja: et siin saad valida, kas sa oled või mitte, aga nüüd ma Tahan näidata, et ee, kui input il oli meil. Mäletate see välju Katribuut, Kus mul see rain on? Kuskil ta on siin First Name, Näed, ta on siin
Õpetaja: sisse kirjutatult, onju? Nüüd Checkboxil on olemas Niukene atribuut nimega Checked
Õpetaja: ja Tšeck Tähendab põhimõtteliselt Kas on siis ta on truu.
Õpetaja: Sisuliselt, Kui teda ei ole, siis. Noh, võib öelda, et on foos saate mõttes aru, et me saame survestada, et see on sees Kui päris süsteemis. Sa ei sooviks seda sisse panna.
Õpetaja: Aga sellepärast, et sa soovid, et inimene taotlikult vajutab seda nuppu, et olen kõigega nõus, On ju? Aga mõttest saate aru? Tal on Niukene atribuut, mis tema jaoks on, on, ei ole, on, ei ole. See tähendab sees väljas Sees väljas ei ole. Vaata, Checkt on
Õpetaja: mõte, on selge? See tuleb hiljem kunagi mängu.
Õpetaja: Nii, Tal on siukene atribuut.
Õpetaja: Ta on Niukene interaktiivne. Vaata, tema on ju input. Taip On tal checkbox siis temal, et need. See tüüp määrab ka. Mis see atribuute on, et kui ma Tulen näiteks selle sama raini juurde.
Õpetaja: Input Box ja tekst.
Õpetaja: Ma tulen siia ja panen näiteks. Ma ei tea kas ta isegi, lubab või Joonib alla.
Õpetaja: Noh, kogemata. Nüüd kustutasin ära. Selle Mm,
Õpetaja: ma saan kirjutada. Aga noh, mida? See tähendab, Checkt?
Õpetaja: Noh, polegi midagi nagu sind. Noh, Ta Ei, muuda mitte midagi, saate aru? Siin on nagu mingi koostöö. On ju
Õpetaja: koostöö selle input typeiga ja atribuut Value Siin midagi teeb. Check. Te ei tee siin ööd ega mütsi. Ma võin ju vastupidi ka teha. Tulen, otsin selle Ee Checkboxi ülesse ja tulen panen siia Value.
Õpetaja: Välju, Rain.
Õpetaja: Noh, pole siin selles kastis mingit raini. Saate ma lihtsalt aru,
Õpetaja: et nad mängivad omavahel kokku. Ma ei tea, kas välju truu saab panna. Aga ta on. Peaks olema ikkagi see, et see ei muuda mitte midagi.
Õpetaja: Sa ei muuda mitte midagi. Siin mängib rolli. See ainuke asi, mida sind saaks kasutada. Interaktiivsuse mõttes on see, kas on sees? Või Ei ole
Õpetaja: nii Okei, lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Link.
Õpetaja: Ee, link Ei ole link, vaid on A
Õpetaja: Aa, rehv. Ma ei tea, kas ta pakuks ka a varianti.
Õpetaja: Aga Ta teeb kohe ise kui te Panete A ja tab.
Õpetaja: Väike A, loomulikult.
Õpetaja: Ee, on peal.
Õpetaja: Ära.
Õpetaja: Aa ja tuli. Niukene asi teil
Õpetaja: nüüd See siin on. Ee, lingi nimi.
Õpetaja: Paneme korra lihtsalt huvi. Paneme lihtsalt tingimused. Ee, tingimused.
Õpetaja: Ei, paneme Tingimuste ka. Võib ette nägeliku. No paneme tingimuste Seega muudame kohe ära. Siis Link tuleb. Si. Kuidas
Õpetaja: Aa, et app Intellige teeb meile auto compliiti ära.
Õpetaja: Nii et see on lingi nimi.
Õpetaja: Hetkel ta ei tee mitte midagi. Kui põhimõtteliselt viib meid siia samale lehele, ehk ta kuidagi automaatselt hüppab ülesse. Nüüd see koht, on, et kuhu me tahame siis kasutajaid viia.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, alustame välise lingiga Sa võibolla vaatamise kohta võite järgi teha. Te võite mis iganes lingi panna. W, w Google dot com on ka link.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga mina panen siia. Näiteks ma Google Sse Panen Lhv Ee tingimused.
Õpetaja: Neil on eraldi lehekülg. Tingimused ja hinnakiri.
Õpetaja: Kopin selle lingi siit ülevalt.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma tulen, panen selle siia. Arf I.
Õpetaja: Siis ta kainda nagu töötaks niimoodi, et kui ma lähen nüüd Sellele lehele olen nõus. Olen tingimustega nõus. No see tingimused on praegu siin. Lõpus. Vahet pole. Tõstan selle õigesse kohta kaarsti. Kui ma klikin Sellele siis mis juhtub?
Õpetaja: Ma lähen sellele lehele. Mis on seal lingi sees ehk? Siis Noh, see ongi. Kogu point, onju?
Õpetaja: Koodi kood on Siin
Õpetaja: Ee Punkt, aadressi lõppu
Õpetaja: Sul on. Sul on Niukene Link nagu W. W. Punkt Lhv Punkt E, E Ja läheb mujale.
Õpetaja: Jah, Ee, ta töötab Vaja on seda ka.
Õpetaja: Ühesõnaga, pange igal juhul kogu link kuskilt, onju? See on niikuinii. Me muudame seda kohe niikuinii. See See on nagu ajutine asi Nüüd kogu selle asja tegelikult võiks võtta. Ma ei tea, kas saab otse nüüd tingimuste asemele panna või või peab Võibolla veel ühe spänni tegema. Kohe Vaatame,
Õpetaja: minu meelest peaks saama nii ka. Ee, et nüüd on. Niimoodi. Vaata, et olen tingimustega nõus, see on See mõte,
Õpetaja: aga me. Me lihtsalt. Kogu see asi läheb prügikasti. Ärge nagu pead liiga vaevake. Kui te ei tule välja, mida iganes Siin see ei ole tähtis.
Õpetaja: Mis on tähtis, on see, et saate aru. Vaata, et ee, et see link, kuidas ta nüüd töötab, on Ju ma isegi korra panen ta praegu sealt endal tagasi, et on lihtsalt kuidagi lihtsam on vaadata seda linki nagu visuaalselt koodis. Nüüd, mis Siin Arf. Il on veel.
Õpetaja: On olemas. On praegu. Kuidas ta töötab, on see, et ta avab selles samas staab Is ja läheb uuele kohale, et kui ma tahan tagasi minna, ma pean tegema. Mida Ma pean Pack I vajutama,
Õpetaja: kui ma tahan seda Aga avada peaasi ei tea, Mingi Target on. Ee, Target Blank Niuke Attribuut. Nagu Target.
Õpetaja: Ee, Siis vist avab ta uue tabina. Võibolla ma midagi muud sinna sisse kirjutama. Ma ei tea peast kohe vaatama.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tegi uue. Tab I lahti. Tegi Packi ei saa minna, aga see. Mul on endiselt, Ee, siin alles
Õpetaja: nii palju asju lahti. Ma korra panen. Ee.
Õpetaja: Ee, rohkem asju kinni, et on vähem segadust, et näed, mul on üks tab lahti. Hoitan. Tingimused
Õpetaja: tuleb uuel lehel lahti. Saate ma tast aru. Ka Niukest asja peab alati mõtlema.
Õpetaja: Te ei taha minna kummagagi Overboard I
Õpetaja: Te ei taha ee tingimata alati teha niimoodi et ta avab selles samas lehes, nagu soovite.
Õpetaja: Aga tuleb hetki. Vaata, kus te soovite, et Ee, kasutajale jääks võimalus, et tal. Ta liigub kuhugi uute kohta meie süsteemis edasi. Aga te tahate tegelikult, et ikkagi jääb mingile, et ta teeb seda uues aknas
Õpetaja: ja ta saaks kinni panna ja kuidagi lihtsalt tagasi tulla. Back muutub kuidagi ebakonviinentiks, aga kindlasti ei taha teha ka Niukest lehte, kus Iga Jumala. Kord, kui sa vajutad kuhugi Lingile, tuleb uue akna ette. Ma toon näite demo.
Õpetaja: Kui ma otsin mingisugust toodet Search. Iga
Õpetaja: siis ta veel ei tee uut. Tab I lahti. Kui ma vajutan mingi tootele, ta teeb uue Tab I lahti.
Õpetaja: Kui ma Nüüd searchin jälle ja vajutan mingi toote, siis ta teeb uue. Mina ei tea, mina ütlen. See on ju. Ee, et mina, kui ma Mul tekibus alati ülipalju neid hakkama.
Õpetaja: Nad üritavad seal kuidagi, et sa oleksid mingil lehel ja sa shopleks, et see on nende point. Vaata, Nad üritavad kuidagi niimoodi, aga mind isiklikult ärritab see. Nagu Ee. Teil tekib see professionaalne ka. Vaata ühel hetkel, et hakata panema tähele idiootsusi,
Õpetaja: Mida ma üle kõige näiteks vihkan, on see, et kui sa on uue konto loomine.
Õpetaja: Parool on varjatud.
Õpetaja: Teil on see kakssada boksi. Vaata, Ee, parool on varjatud. Vaata jah, Registreeru meile. Pane oma email ja parool.
Õpetaja: Parool on varjatud ja pole seda nuppu ka, vaata, et saaks, et too nähtavale ja üks kast
Õpetaja: pole seda, Retyp I et. Noh,
Õpetaja: et ma toksin mingisugust, siis on tähenõuded ka. Sul peab olema kuusteist tähemärki. Üks peab olema suur. Üks väike üks number ja üks ekstra karakter ka. Mingi ihumärk või tegeles,
Õpetaja: Toksid sul mingi kuusteist tähtaja üritad panna midagi. Jõuad lõpusse, nagu niimoodi. Eriti telefonis teed.
Õpetaja: See on nagu. Mis ma selle porueriks panin, nagu.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui sul on vähemalt see, et sa pead uuesti toksima. Siis On võimalus, et sa pead uuesti selle koleduse toksima ja paned paika. Noh, võibolla võiks jätta lihtsalt selle Nupu ka, et kui ma tahan, võtan riski ja korra. Noh, hästi, ei ole selle taga. Ma võin vaadata, mida ma kirjutasin,
Õpetaja: aga see on? Ma olen sattunud niisuguse kohta. Mis sa siis teed? Siis on nagu see, et ma hakkan, Ma teen mingi lahti, kirjutan visuaalselt mingisuguse parooli valmis. Ja ma copy Based in selle esimest. Ainult siis ma saan kindel olla, et mul läheb sinna täpselt selline parool, mida ma Pärast ise ka mäletan,
Õpetaja: et nagu ma olen näinud, siis ma olen mõelnud, nagu. Kes. Selle välja mõtles,
Õpetaja: et kui sa ära Id ja Nähtavaks ei ole võimalik teha, Siis peab olema. See on just muid asju. Hakkad ka märkama? Ee, kui ise teed disaini,
Õpetaja: et siis hakkad palju rohkem urle hakata ka passima. Urle, hakata passima kogu aeg. Jah,
Õpetaja: saab nagu samal ajal.
Õpetaja: Jah, Jah, saab ikka, aga tuleta meelde kui Rain, pane pilt tagasi.
Õpetaja: Jah, Davai Margarita valvab
Õpetaja: Ee ja ee, et, ee, selles mõttes. Ee, te hakkate märkama igasuguseid asju, mida varasemalt ei märkand, See juhtub
Õpetaja: nüüd. Aa, mida ma tahan järgmisena. Ma ütlen jälle nagu teha ja vaadata on tähtis meile Hiljem, kui me hakkame siin Voest ja asjadest rääkima.
Õpetaja: Ma teen juurde. Praegu on meil siin Niukene fail. Nagu Indeks Atml.
Õpetaja: Ma teen juurde ise ühe uue Html i Kuidas ma. Ma tahan, et ta on juurkataloog Ja siis ta tuleks kuskile kõrvale
Õpetaja: või kuskile mujale panna, aga mul lihtsalt praegu on kuidagi lihtsam see siia panna
Õpetaja: Päris elus. Ma paneks selle ja vanasti istus ka indeks. Atml istus all.
Õpetaja: Ma panen siis siia kõrvale, austa võite vaadata. Võite järgi teha. Ma võin lihtsalt kirjutada mingi fail
Õpetaja: ja puna panna lõppu Html Aga Mõistlikum on kui. On vastav tüüp ee olemas
Õpetaja: Siis tasuks seda valida, sest ta teeb mingi põhja ära.
Õpetaja: Html fail. Nüüd ma seda punkt Html lõppu ei pea panema.
Õpetaja: Ma panen lihtsalt Ee, tingimused, tingimused. Vajutan entrit
Õpetaja: tajtel. Ee, ta küsib, kas ta on Kit I. Noh, Pane pane niikuinii läheb roll. Back või kustutan ära, Ütlen siia siis. Ee, tingimused.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, ee. Sa paned lihtsalt ühe paragrahv ühe.
Õpetaja: See. See on niuke tilulilus. Niiöelda Ee, noh, ee, meie tingimused,
Õpetaja: Ee, üks paragrahv. Ma ütleks Loore. Ipsum on olemas või ei ole siin
Õpetaja: väga hea.
Õpetaja: Võibolla Bluginaga saab
Õpetaja: kas intelli võimaldab ademel ee failis genereerida loore noore ees on.
Õpetaja: Ma nagu mäletasin, et seda sai kuidagi teha. Ma ei ei ole kunagi kasutanud.
Õpetaja: Noh, aa, see ka võime koodi panna.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd ma ei näe. Ma Saan nii ka muidugi teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, selles mõttes me leiame kompromissi ka niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Lorem ja tab Davai vaatame.
Õpetaja: Aa, väga hea, Mis see on?
Õpetaja: Mis asi, See Lora Ipsoman kuidas teksti imitatsioon. Ee, see tegelikult on ladina keeles ka mingi tekst.
Õpetaja: Vaatame talle, See on täide. Kohe proovime edasi. Veel ka lihtsalt huvi. Pärast panen tõlgi.
Õpetaja: See tekst on. Ma pole kunagi ujunud tal ei olegi sisulist tähendust,
Õpetaja: aga tõlkida mõtteliselt Valu ise on tähtis. See on peamine asi, kuid mõned tagajärjed tekivad paratamatult. Vahel ka ebameeldivad või keerulised. Mõnikord tuleb ette raskusi ja ebamugavusi, kuid need olukorrad
Õpetaja: võivad samuti olla ajutised ja möödavad. See on mingi mõttetu bullshit tekstid sealt no See mingisugune. Midagi siin on ka. Vaata, on ju see mõte on Siis see. Ma võtan tagasi, et kui ma kirjutan siia, see on Standard tekst, mida pannakse lihtsalt kuskil. Me. Me keskendume disainile. Meil on vaja siia paragrahvi, paragrahvi ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, kus on vaja lihtsalt teksti siis Tavaliselt on see sama tekst.
Õpetaja: Ja nagu näha, Lorem Kümme tahab teeb
Õpetaja: noh. Või oota Vaatame, korra mis. See sündaks oli paragrahv Lorem. Kakskümmend
Õpetaja: kahekümne sõnaga. Okei, ma mõtlesin, et ta korrutab neid. Ee, noh, paneme siis teistmoodi Ee lorem tuhat tuhande sõnaga ja tee mulle mingi tekst lihtsalt. Ja nüüd ma saan siis seda seal Html is. Niiöelda Mingi väga pika paragrahvi näha, onju? See on see mõte ta kordades saad sama asja
Õpetaja: nii las ta nüüd seal olla. Ja nüüd meie mõte on see, et meil on need tingimused siin. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Selles eraldi failis. Ja nüüd me selles Hrf Is ei taha kuskilt välisest keskkonnast viidata, vaid me tahame hoopis viidata.
Õpetaja: Ma igaks juhuks teen Selle siit ka mina. Jälle ei tea kuidas seda siin korrektselt kirjutada on? Ta on public kaustas.
Õpetaja: Ma tirin ta siia, aga tegelikult ta läheb kuskile. Body lõppu.
Õpetaja: Näed Ta siia tuli, aga ta tegi avas. Selle
Õpetaja: Ma tegelikult tahan viidet ikkagi. Noh, kurat, proovime siis kuidagi hakkama saada. Ee, huvitav, kus ta tema arvates juur ka osta on? Ma proovin mingi tähe kirjutada. Ma vaatan, mida ta praegu näeb.
Õpetaja: Ta näeb igasuguseid koledusi. Ta peaks ikkagi siin olema. Ehk siis, kui mina kirjutan Kaldkriips Public, siis see peaks olema esimene ka ost. Lähme vaatame, kas Ta pakub. Aga Tahate veel? Noh, Davai, vaatame. Ma proovin ise ära. Siis vaatame, kas Syntax on õige.
Õpetaja: Ee, ennem ei ole mõtet
Õpetaja: avab Väga hea, Ehk siis, kui te panete siia. Hrf. I. Kaldkriips tingimused. Punkt Html. Ta peaks juba ise pakkuma. Siis see, Viitab et siin on Fail meil selles projektis tingimused. Html, Mis on selles kaustas. Vabandust, public ongi tema kaust.
Õpetaja: See on tema juurkaost
Õpetaja: Siin on ta kogu Aeg oma rajaga Kui me tahame viidata failidele. Kui tahaks indeksile, vali. Kui ma tahaks seda indeksfaili valida, näiteks või
Õpetaja: või mida iganes, onju, Siis ma peaksin tegema. Niimoodi ma korra näitan. Ärge teie muutke. Kui mina tahaksin valida, siis praegu tema mõttes. Juurkaust on koguaeg public. Mina Pean minema üks samm ülesse ja siis saan valida. File vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Siis ma teeksin niimoodi. Kuidas Oli tagasiminek, Punkt punkt, üks kaust ülesse Ja read me.
Õpetaja: Mm, no ma kirjutan täpselt välja. Vahet pole, ta ei paku mulle Reed.
Õpetaja: Nii, punkt Md. Siin on natukene keeruline olukord, et tegelikult me oleme voe projektis. Kuidas Aiway?
Õpetaja: No ma kohe näen, kui ta teeb selle lahti, Teeb ju
Õpetaja: nii, et kõik on õige, Nii et tema jaoks on, ee. Niiöelda siis niiöelda lähtekataloog tema jaoks. Okei, ee,
Õpetaja: nii. Räägi
Õpetaja: Sa tulid. Võtsid niimoodi seda koppisid? Kuidas
Õpetaja: Mhmh,
Õpetaja: Okei, see töötab. Seda vaikimisi võtab ee. Faili nime. Ma näitan, kuidas teistmoodi oleks saanud teha.
Õpetaja: Ta Ta peaks nii ka töötama, Aga kas Ta kaldkriipsu tõesti ei vaja.
Õpetaja: Ei vaja. Siis ta suudab selle ise ära panna, on ju? Aga vaata, see ei tööta nüüd igal pool. Ma Tulen näiteks kuskile mujale. Ütlen, et näed. Tahan seda Css faili. Kui Ma tulen. Panen lihtsalt copy praegu. Ta paneb faili nime. Vaikimisi
Õpetaja: see. Noh, kui ma tulen siia, siis ta ei lähe sinna Css faili.
Õpetaja: Aga sa andsid mulle mõte. Ma nüüd ei tea kas me Siin seda saame proovida, aga saab kohe teada, Kui ma tulen, võtan parem klõps ja nüüd ma panen hoopis Copy Bath Reference.
Õpetaja: Ta pakub Erinevaid variante. Absolut arvuti mõttes. C Project. Nelikümmend asi see meile ei sobi File Name ei sobi. Nüüd Ta pakub erinevad variandid nagu Ee, Mis hakkab sellest juurkataloogist?
Õpetaja: Kas sa mõtled, Source, et siit ikka kahjuks seda õiget asja ei tule. Aga kui me jõuame kuidagi otsapidi lõpuks Voesse päriselt, siis siit juba Enamvähem on abi. Pluss, kui Me Cloud iga suhtleme, siis ma teen kogu aeg seda Copy File name, et Kuidas
Õpetaja: ma räägin siis, kui me Cloudiga midagi toimetame? Ee, praegult, vaata. Noh, okei, Praegult See vahe on see, et see asi meile copib Vaata terve faili nime. Aga justkui meie arvuti mõttes. See Project grupp, Mida iganes
Õpetaja: see rada meile ei sobi. Meil on nagu see, et Anna mulle fail Koos tema rajaga on selle Ee, mõte. Nagu. Vaata, et ma võtan. Anna mulle see fail. See Css fail, Siin Copy Bart Reference anna viide sellele Absoluut. Pacht oli siis selline. File Name on kui lihtsalt Copiks
Õpetaja: Parfum Context, Ruut kontekst. Root On see
Õpetaja: siis Ta ütlebki. Vaata, näed, kui siit vaadata ütleb, et mine Kõigepealt see Source kataloogi Mine kõigepealt. Source kataloogi. Coldkriips, assets,
Õpetaja: kaldkriips, ee. Punkt Sees, Saate aru, see on rada.
Õpetaja: Aa, asjad. Need muutuvad. Miining Rohkem miiningfull iks. Siis kui meil on mingi päris asi. Vaata ja nüüd seda Seda asja saab hästi palju kasutada. Ma kasutan seda väga, väga palju.
Õpetaja: Aga pigem kui ma suhtlen. Nii,
Õpetaja: okei, paneme edasi Ma taastan selle Tingimuse, et. Noh, kui olla korrektne, siis võibolla niimoodi, on ju
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta avastab olema tingimustega nõus ja teeb uue lehe lahti, on nii
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Minu küsimus on see, et mitu Html faili on meil projektis?
Õpetaja: Kaks tükki Millised. Need on?
Õpetaja: Indeksitingimused on nii onju?
Õpetaja: Ma teen ühe Faili veel juurde. Panen lihtsalt nimeks linnakiri.
Õpetaja: Mitu faili? Mitu Html. Faili on meil arvutis.
Õpetaja: Control, C, control, V.
Õpetaja: Mitu faili nüüd on? Oota, Meil faili
Õpetaja: kolm, on ju? Ee, ma saan neid. Ee, nüüd korra ma tulen tagasi. See sama tingimused Ma teen juurde. Ee, lihtsalt tublikaadi. See on vaatluse koht. Teen hinnakiri.
Õpetaja: Ma lihtsalt muudan siit selle hinnakirja all Ära ka headeri, Lihtsalt et oleks lihtne näha seda,
Õpetaja: Ee, paneme siia hinnakiri ja teisele paneme tingimused.
Õpetaja: Ma Võibolla ka siis panna niimoodi, et need matšivad.
Õpetaja: See, kus me seda näeme, Me oleme siin, onju, et Mul on nüüd kaks linki. Vaata, tingimused, tingimused, hinnakiri.
Õpetaja: Kas ee. Ja ma. Ma korra nüüd, ee, muudan ka selle ära, et ma ei taha et nad avavad eraldi lehes, vaid et samal lehel
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: ma seda palun. See on nüüd pikaajaline mälu. Vaata, palun mäletage kõike, seda praegu. Palun jätke kõik meelde, mis me praegu teeme.
Õpetaja: Mitte nagu tehniliselt, vaid lihtsalt. Mida? Et meil on mitu faili, on ju nii Vastab tõele, et siin on ee, link tingimused.
Õpetaja: Kui ma vajutan siia peale, siis meie jaoks vaade muutub, on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui Me vaatame seda Urlist. Me näeme, et siin on tingimused. Punkt Html.
Õpetaja: Ta viitab sellele failile. Me näeme seda, Html Faili vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tulen Packi, Siis tegelikult noh, ma tulen veel Packi korra. Panen uuesti. Ma teen niimoodi nullist. Ee, tingimused. Vajutan Oleme siin. Kui tuleme tagasi, siis tegelikult Me oleme indeks Atmail is indeks. Atmaili kuvatakse, Kuvatakse tingimusi meie jaoks, mis muutub, Vaade muutub, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ja see vaade muutub, sest need on erinevad failid. No vaatame nüüd hinnakiri.
Õpetaja: Ee, mul on vist et siin Lingis on viga sees.
Õpetaja: Tegin selle korda ka.
Õpetaja: Võtan korra siia Refresh I jaoks. Üks jälle uuesti. Nii, ee. Tingimused Hinnakiri vaade muutub,
Õpetaja: on nii ja on erinevad failid vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Ja mitu Html I on hetkeseisuga meil projektis
Õpetaja: nii väga hea. Selle juurde Tuleme tagasi, kui hakkame vaatama. Voed ja Single Page Application. Nii, ee, olen nõus tingimustega Hinnakirja asjad. Mis iganes,
Õpetaja: Mis meil siin edasi nüüd siis tuleb.
Õpetaja: Ee, Dv. Id. Me juba vaatasime läbi bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, button, Ee, seda input I. Seda saab nii Mit, Vaata, meil oli input. Type on checkbox. On See nupp,
Õpetaja: nagu see on. See see on Nüüd See nupp. Siin lisaklientsüsteemi.
Õpetaja: Aa, on Niuke Button. Seda saab tegelikult teha ka niimoodi imp. Ja
Õpetaja: Ma ei mäleta, mis meil oli. Täpselt See ei ole kaasategevuse koht. See on vaatamise koht.
Õpetaja: Ee panen välju Mingi nupp on Nii On mõlemad nupud
Õpetaja: päeva lõpus. Nad on mõlemad Selles mõttes nupud. Neil on samasugune funktsionaalsus, Aga elementide mõttes Lihtsalt üks on input. Button. Teine on nagu Button. Vahet pole
Õpetaja: saab tehniliselt teha ka nii
Õpetaja: nii nup.
Õpetaja: See on Link Lihtsalt on.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ei ole kindel, kas mul kohe toimib või mitte, Me räägime sellest Ee, Juba varsti. Tegelikult ma ütlen,
Õpetaja: Ptn ja panen Ptn. Ee, mm, Noh, mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Ee, lähen meta alla, Okei, ma Põhimõtteliselt ma tahan öelda, et Css Iga on võimalik lingist ka teha. Nupp,
Õpetaja: No kõik kolm nuppu. Võiksid samad olla. Üks on input,
Õpetaja: teine on patt, on kolmas on link. Vaata aga, Css. Iga saaks teha täpselt niukse nupu. Ideeliselt jälle. Seal on mingid väiksed nüansid on aga suures pildis pole vahet, nagu Mida, kasutada.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui tahad Batonit teha. No kasuta batonit. Vaata, kui on mingil põhjusel input Taipega tahad, siis võid seda ka teha Vaata, kui sa vot selle lingiga on. Isegi on nagu reaalselt põhjust, et seal on. Ee, on nagu momente. Vaata, et miks ma tahaks Lingina kasutada. Aga,
Õpetaja: ee, võibolla mingisugune. Sest seal on võimalik hästi lihtsalt kasutada seda et Lingil on Näiteks see, et Ava uue staab is.
Õpetaja: Platonil ei ole nagu, et. Noh, sa tegelt kuskile programmi lihtsalt lähed
Õpetaja: Väga uues staab is. Vaata, seal on nagu ühesõnaga sisse kirjutatud funktsionaalsus, Mida atribuudiga saad määrata juba ära, et seal on nagu mingi niukseid väikseid asju. Näiteks oleneb, mida sa tahad teha aga see ei ole tähtis.
Õpetaja: Ee tähtis on meie jaoks praegult. Ee, lihtsalt see, et meil on siin see üks nupp. Ee, eelistaks. Loomulikult. Nagu ma ütlesin, siis Ee, kirjaviisis on ju kõige parem. See ikkagi. See patt on.
Õpetaja: Aa, Okei, nii järgmine teema.
Õpetaja: No mis asjad on stiilid?
Õpetaja: Võtame ette.
Õpetaja: Ee, Võtame need Chat. I Mitte Chat I vaid Cloud I Ütlen, et ee, tee.
Õpetaja: Ee, mul, ee. Üks
Õpetaja: winerfriendli materjal.
Õpetaja: Aga tüüt Kas teile Tundub, et on tüütu, et ma kirjutan koguaeg nagu samalaadseid asju uuesti uuesti. Ma mõtlen, nagu et siin mõtleme, mis me praegu teeme, ma Kirjutan seda, et tee mulle üks materjal.
Õpetaja: Nii, järgmisena ma tahan öelda. Pane see.
Õpetaja: Mm, ee. Nii, Vaatame, paneme, paneme, paneme, paneme. Oi, this Is so amazing. See on vist alles hiljuti. Avastasin.
Õpetaja: Aa, kus meil olid? Need materjalid?
Õpetaja: Ee, kuskil oli Toxkaust, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma tahan öelda, et pane. Näete, nüüd ma juba praegu teen. Ma saaks siin ättiga ka selle ära lahendada. Muidugi ätt. Ja kirjutaks näiteks ee, materjals
Õpetaja: Vaid ta nentrit. Ta valis selle raja. Materjal valis.
Õpetaja: Ma panin selle kaldkriipsu kuidagi teistmoodi, et tema jaoks, et noh, ma valisin nagu kataloogi Mitte faili, Onju, et siin faili pole. Ee, kuidas ma seda veel teen? Ätt I abil. Ma saan seda lihtsalt konsoolis kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Teine variant, mida ma teen väga, väga tihti. Sellepärast mulle meeldib nii teha. On see, et kui mul on mingi fail juba siin olemas, see kaust, Ma teen just, mis ma sellest natuke aega tagasi rääkisin. Teen parema klõpsu ja panen from.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis sellest.
Õpetaja: Mingi alamkataloog. Ma tahangi öelda, Pane alla uus õpetus. Mingi asja kohta
Õpetaja: saate ma tast aru, et kas ma teen seda ätiga või tulen? Panen see niimoodi näiteks
Õpetaja: või Panen lihtsalt alla. Lihtsalt juba ta saab aru, et see on rada,
Õpetaja: Mis ma nagu mõtlen, on see, et kas vastab tõele, et praegult Iga kord, kui ma tahan mingisuguse asja kohta mingit teooriamaterjali siis ma pean kirjutama. Tee mulle üks. Pane see.
Õpetaja: See on tüütu.
Õpetaja: Ma nagu Pean kirjutama seda, mis on minu võimalused juba praeguste teadmiste kohaselt, mis ma saaks teha? Vaata, kuidas ma saaksin oma jalava vähendada. Ma ei pea põhimõtteliselt kirjutama nagu pikalt välja midagi.
Õpetaja: Ja. Okei, mis Md faili ma võiksin midagi praegu teha.
Õpetaja: Aa, mida see on? Ära nüüd, ole Niuke Pro. Me teised inimesed, mida me oleme õppinud praeguste teadmiste kohaselt. Mine ära seda
Õpetaja: Md faili. No praegult võiks mõelda seda, et me võime. Mäletate seda reeglit?
Õpetaja: Meil on siin Niukene fail. Nagu reeglid. See fail annab Claud juhisele selle repositori koodika töötamisel. Käsud, arhitektuur,
Õpetaja: koodistiil keel. Me oleme juba kõik rääkinud. Dokumentatsioon kogu. See asub seal all. Nii, ma saaks põhimõtteliselt siia ka lisada midagi, et et kui sa lood Mingit materjali tee. Saate innerfriend I. See on üks võimalus. Me saame siia panna. Aga mida Artur nüüd mainis? On see mida mina tegelikult Mõtlen Skills.
Õpetaja: Ee, see tuli. Cloud Code. Mitte. Ee. Minu meelest
Õpetaja: nad. Ja kaua ta on öeldud? Sa võibolla te paremini
Õpetaja: ossa Kurat, ma Olen maganud kuskil.
Õpetaja: Aa, mina ei tea, millal see tuli, Aga kuskil Newspeed I Ta jooksis mullas nagu mingi enam vähem, nagu mingi, mõned kuud tagasi. Aa, mis oli tegelikult vale. Viga
Õpetaja: Mõte on see, kui me kirjutame ühe taolised prompte all The Time. Mina vanasti tegin. Võibolla Ma tegin niukest trikki, et ma hakkasin salvestama erinevaid. Ee, tegin mingi suvalise eri. Panin mingi erinevad prompid. Tegin Md faili.
Õpetaja: Kui Ma tegin Mingisuguseid tegevusi. Siis ma aegajalt ütlesin. Klopp, Salvesta see promp. Vaata, nagu kuskile. Alla. Vaata, on ju, et, ee. Ma saan teinekord seda kasutada. See on mingi keeruline. Ei viitsi seda ju biljon korda. Ma võin. Copywace kindlalt ei hakka tegema. Mul on mingi oma väike tekstfime, kuskil
Õpetaja: Copy Based. Mingisuguseid ägedaid pronte, millega saab väga palju mingit asja väga täpselt ära teha. Vaata, ühetaoline tegevus on siis võtmesõna, on ju
Õpetaja: Ja Mul oli niuke. Mingi erinevad prompid olid seal all on ju? Ja siis üks hetk, kui ma tegin, siis selle ära, sest ma ei viitsi seda uuesti kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Me kopime praegu selle kuskile siia.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuhugi tekstifaili. Nii, Ja ma saan. Selle siit ära kustutada.
Õpetaja: Ma tegin koguaeg Ee, siis mingit prompte. Ja siis aegajalt. Ma ütlesin, et salvesta see kuskile erinevad prompide alla Ja siis, kuidas ma kasutasin, oli see, et et Võta
Õpetaja: ät Erinevad promptid failist. Ja siis mul oli nende promptide juures ka mingid pealkirjad, et see prompt. Ja nüüd käivite see
Õpetaja: ee, Siis ma tegin seda idiootsust seni kaua, kuni ma lihtsalt üks päev otsustasin, siis vaadata ta kogu aeg räägib, et vajuta kaldkriips ja siis Saad käivitada mingi käsu, Näiteks see kaldkriips, Usage ja nii edasi. Ja siis mingi hetk. Ma võtsin nagu ette selle, nagu, et, ee,
Õpetaja: vaataks Siis nagu. Mida siin kõike saab teha Mäletan, ma ütlesin, et tehke see läbi. Kui te Cloud Code endale juba ära nagu regate
Õpetaja: ja Tegin erinevaid asju ja siis, kui jõuda siia tähestiku järjekorras kuskil S I juurde.
Õpetaja: No ma natukene Aitan.
Õpetaja: Skills Lisk, available Skills. Hetkel ta ütleb.
Õpetaja: No Skills
Õpetaja: ei ütlegi midagi või? Ma ütlesin tegelikult. Sa peaksid liste näitama. Aga siin pole midagi.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis, kui ma jõudsin veel Parema. Täheni, mis on tegelikult juba ennem. Siis ma sealt kuidagi avasin. Ma läksin ja ma jõudsin sellise asjani. Vaata, Discover Cloud Code Features Through Quick. Interactive Lessonce.
Õpetaja: Mina olen need rohelised läbi teinud. Nagu näete, ma pole aega isegi need paar viimast aega läbi käia.
Õpetaja: Kui ma Jõudsin siiamaani. Siis mul saigi mahtu otsast. Ma sain aru, et. Kuule, ma pean midagi muud tegema. Vahepeal
Õpetaja: automate your worklow ja mida ta räägib. Skills and Hooks on selle peale.
Õpetaja: Ee, on events, et sa oled
Õpetaja: mingi tööriist käivitub ja siis automaatselt on seal konks käivitub midagi muud.
Õpetaja: Ee, see skill kohta. Ta kuskil rääkis ka. Midagi
Õpetaja: Näete siinsamas kohe üleval. Tegelikult ta alustab
Õpetaja: No natukene vajas natuke siis uurimist, mis see on.
Õpetaja: Ma saan teha Special Md failid, mis peavad olema punkt Aa Cloud I kataloogis Kataloogi Skills. Mingisugune nimi. See deploy osa on Siis asja nimi ja Skill Md fail. Kui sa teed niisuguse Skill I promp I, siis edaspidi mina saan sellele panna. Nime näiteks, et Ee,
Õpetaja: aa. Selle skili nimeks Panen näiteks. Ee, uus Aa Lesson. Uus teooria. Mida iganes ma saan selle nimeks panna
Õpetaja: ja nüüd edaspidi Ma Saan väga mugavalt lihtsalt panna. Kaldkriips. Uus teooria. Ta juba pakub. Vaata mulle seda valikut Ma veel Teeks niimoodi. Alati alustaks Skills, sest see on lihtne. Vaata mingit Skill I käivitada Skill sidekriips. Ja siis tuleb uus teooriaõpetus või mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Kui sa käivitad selle siis sinna, teki Sa tekitad juhendi.
Õpetaja: Sa tekitad ise juhendid, et.
Õpetaja: Hei, juhend on selline, et iga kord, kui ma selle käivitan, siis minu eesmärk on, see et sa teed innerfriendly. Ee, niiöelda õpetuse. Palun lisa sinna igasuguseid skeeme, pilte ja muid asju. Tee see võimalikult mulle lihtsaks, nii edasi, on Ju bla, bla, bla, blabla. Salvesta see sinna kausta. Mõtle välja mingi nimi. Kui sa tahad mingi formaati kätte anda,
Õpetaja: sa teed sinna juhendeid Ja Siis sa ütled ka. Ee, lihtsalt küsi minu käest, mille kohta ma tahan juhendit teha. Mina hüppan, mida tahan teha nüüd, kui ma Käivitan selle, skill. I Tema küsib, mille kohta sa tahad juhendit teha.
Õpetaja: Cssi kasutus Ja, mingi. Noh, mis iganes veel, mis teema teemana on, ette. Mina Vaata,
Õpetaja: Enter. Kogu see pikk jutt on seal stiilis. Saate mõttest aru
Õpetaja: nii kui mõnus. No sa oled Artur. Sina teadsidki, sa Sellepärast sa ütlesid, kasutas keeles või kogu aeg. Ja ma leidsin ühe veebilehe, kus need juba ette tehtud ja erinevaid. Ja see on nagu Hästi, lahe teed ja mugavaid.
Õpetaja: Kas sa viitsiksid, Ee, mingid oma parimad ee leiud kuskile meile panna? Veel parem väikene ülesanne järgmine nädal vaata Nädalavahetus on ees ka, onju? Viitsid veits aega investeerida. Tee meile väikene presentation
Õpetaja: nagu niuksed. Mingid niuksed, lemmikumad ja asjad, vaata onju Keep it Short short. Aga Aga samas nagu nagu Kata. Ära nagu vaata onju? Ee, mingid pildid asjad. Aa, mina ütlen. Me oleme siin, et koos õppida
Õpetaja: presentsiooni pärast Vä, Mis lehte?
Õpetaja: Jaa, loomulikult See on osa presentatsioonist.
Õpetaja: See on osa presentatsioonist, kust neid leida. Ja mis sina oled leidnud? No siis saame veel uurida ka. Vaata Ja siis. Mingi aeg, kui keegi leiab veel midagi põnevat,
Õpetaja: sest et see, on, ma, kas ta Mäletan, ma rääkisin. Ma avastasin mingit asju. Vaata, mis on nagu Game Changer Id. See on Game Changer. Mina ei viitsi enam mingisuguse chatbot iga veebis tegeleda. Unustage ära,
Õpetaja: ma. Isegi kui ma tahan mingit üldist vestlust teha. Mina ei viitsi seda enam. Ma teen seda terminalis,
Õpetaja: sest et siin on mingisugused võimalused. Kas veebist saab ka? Vaata, neil on ju seal ka praegu. See mingi top, See desktop, Mingi variant seal, Nad on ka enda loonud niukse asja, et sa saad isegi läbi veebi Brauseri määrata enda arvutisse. See on beeta. Praegult sa määrata ära mingisuguse kataloogi. Sul on mingid asjad arvutis ja Brauseris toimetad ja teed ka. Ja nad on mingisuguseid funktsionaalsusi sinna ka enda ühel või teisel viisil toonud. Ma ei tea, kas seal ma pakun.
Õpetaja: Sealt saab ka midagi. Niukest saab teha Kindlasti,
Õpetaja: aga, noh, ma ütlen minu meelest Terminalis A king I love It,
Õpetaja: et. Ee. See on nagu, väga, väga hea.
Õpetaja: Aga proovimegi siis. Ma tõesti ei viitsi iga kord seda teha, et. Ee. Nüüd me teame. Vaata, et esiteks, ta peab seda tegema sellisel kujul. Ma olen selles mõttes, et siin ongi see, et ega me nüüd käsitsi ei hakka seda tegema. Me ei hakka ise tulema. Siia. Tal pole seda kaustagi. Praegult. Ma just vaatan. Cloud on või ei ole vene punkt. Cloud
Õpetaja: pole.
Õpetaja: Me ei hakka ise tegema. New Directory punkt, Cloud ja nii edasi ja tegema sinna skill. I kindel Ei, ee, me saame ju ise talle öelda. Palun tee,
Õpetaja: kuidas see on kataloog. See on kataloog. Vaata, ee, siin peavad hakkama olema Skill Id.
Õpetaja: See peab iga kord. Minu meelest see formaat on see, et siin on siis see Deploy sõna. Vaata kaldkriips Vaata, ma võtan selle teksti nagu ära. Ee, mul ei ole ühtegi skill i ees, Aga ma varastan kuskilt selle ka. Ta võib selle teha korrektselt, aga ta Hakkab mingit dokumentatsiooni ja asju lugema. Ma annan talle ühe näidise parem ette.
Õpetaja: Ma lähen varastan. Ee, ühe näidise Ee oma Glass Money projektist.
Õpetaja: Ee, panen. Ee, New Window
Õpetaja: projektide kallal. Ma toimetan. Ee, mul ei ole siin väga palju skille ega midagi siin juba on ka tekkinud, hakkab neid juurde tekkima. Näete, Skills.
Õpetaja: Ee, Skill, pull request. Vot Võibolla see niukene skill. Mille ma võtaks?
Õpetaja: Ee, siis ma tulen ee ja Võtan selle Md faili.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: okei, nii palju pean tegema. Ja Name Request. Oota Ma võtan parem. Lihtsam on kogu kataloog võtta ja kustutada vähemaks.
Õpetaja: Ee, jällegi. Ma ütlen, et nüüd mina saan seda ja te saate selle ka varsti endale. Ühel või teisel viisil. Kui te tulete järgi
Õpetaja: on Control V. Cloud.
Õpetaja: Ee, ütlen, et. Noh, lisa kõik siia.
Õpetaja: Ee, skillide alt. Ma jätan ainult praegult. Siis Lihtsalt selle pull Requesti
Õpetaja: Kustutan ära. Miks sul see tähtis on? See nüüd, et siin on mõned väiksed seigad. See struktuur on hästi tähtis
Õpetaja: et ta, on niuke Kataloog. Niisugune kataloog. Ja siin Md Failis, mäletate? See on see visuaalne pool Näete siin esimene lause, mida me näeme, on ja nii edasi, Onju? Kui me vaatame, kuidas see tegelikult tekstina siin taustal on,
Õpetaja: siis sellele osale eelneb see osa siin Näete, siin on nimi
Õpetaja: ja siin on Description. Seda on käivitamisel võimalik näha.
Õpetaja: Saate mõttes aru. Tal on oma formaat. Nüüd on mul võimalik ee rääkida. Cloudiga juba selles Skill I vaates ütlen. Capi referents.
Õpetaja: Vot siin olekski halb. Vaata, kui ma hakkaks lihtsalt siin. Mul on ainult üks kill. Ma võiksin siin ka Ee, talle põhimõtteliselt öelda. Nagu At Skill suure tähega. Ja ta juba pakub seda. Faili on ju? Aga mulle meeldib vahel niimoodi toimetada, et Kas mul on see fail Siin lahti? Parem klõps.
Õpetaja: From Repository Root. Või Ma tulen või Mul on päriselt siit lahti. See on üks Sama Kama, Jälle
Õpetaja: põhiline on see, et mul on see rada olemas. Ja nüüd ma saan rääkida temaga nagu normaalse inimesega. Ma korra nüüd Ee, võtan selle olemasoleva teksti ka, Kus ma lihtsalt siin üle lihtsalt. Ee.
Õpetaja: Jah, okei, ma kirjutan uuesti niikuinii.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ütlen. Ee. Lisa Üks uus kill
Õpetaja: näidise. Saad siit,
Õpetaja: ee. Teeme selle koos Ee samm sammult.
Õpetaja: Nii isa, üks uus. Ma panen võibolla nii palju ette ka Cloud Loud. Code Skill.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: ma. Ma. Ei. Ma ei viitsi kirjutada kogu teksti. See on jälle, seal et ta editida saaks. Ta vajab lugeda kirjutada. Ta võib olla teeb selle valmis.
Õpetaja: Ee, vaatame esmalt olemasolevaid näiteid. Mõista struktuuri. Palun.
Õpetaja: Ee, vaatab selle struktuuri Ära selle näidise pealt.
Õpetaja: Ee, hea struktuur on selge. Nüüd teeme skiili. Samm sammult. Mis Teemal soovid uut skill i Luua mõned ideed. Vaata, juba pakub, Vaata, on Ju ma ei soovi tema ideid. Ee, soovin.
Õpetaja: Soovin. Ee. Soovin sellist skill I
Õpetaja: kus ee luuakse mingi uus Ee Back Inner rendli õppematerjal
Õpetaja: õppematerjal Nii,
Õpetaja: Ee, nii, ma kirjutan lõppu talle, et ta teema mulle küsiks, ma võiks. Vahet pole, kuidas selle ee ära kirjeldab. Ee, õppematerjal
Õpetaja: Õppematerjal olgu alati eesti keelne.
Õpetaja: Noh, saab aru küll sellest, kuidas kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Ee materjali õppematerjali
Õpetaja: Ee, Salvesta alati.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma Otsin, selle kausta ülesse. Kus on meil see toks on? Nüüd, siin.
Õpetaja: Tox theory materials Kausta Upin you.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ma tegelikult natuke teen paremaks selle ka ettevaates, tegelt, Ee, jäähoki. Las ta olla. No ma. Ei. Mul ei ole mõtet enam kataloogi teha. Ma mõtlesin, et voet ja pärast ma teen natukene, ümber. Las ta praegu olla nii nagu on alati siia kausta. Parem klõps.
Õpetaja: Nii õppematerjali salvestab üks ee kommand ka. Mida ma, tükk aega Ajasin taga. Ma ei saanud aru, kuidas neid üldse küsidagi. Kontrolli Ott tuleb uue rea. Noh, on mida meeles hoida, Aga lõpuks, kui sa Tahad seda, teha, sest mul on raske lugeda teksti vasakule paremale.
Õpetaja: Ee, mida ei saa, teha on see et Control Shift enter, näiteks kus Paljudes programmides teeb taanrea. Kui niipea kui paned entrit tema siis tema jaoks on. Vaata, noh,
Õpetaja: pronkt on alles poolik, onju, et ee natukene Tuleb mõelda.
Õpetaja: Ee, soovin. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, selli Ee Luua Sellist, kus luuakse mingi uus õppematerjal. Olgu alati eestikeelne. Kontrol J. Õppematerjal Salvesta taipadon savi tegelikult alati kausta.
Õpetaja: Nii Nüüd on nüüd tuleb tähtsad osad ka. Ee, palun tee alati võimalikult lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Ee. Noh, algaja. Ma panen seda eesti keeles algaja sõbralikult.
Õpetaja: Ee, te, ee, teematerjalid Tee need materjalid. Ma ei mitmuse suhelda saad. Mõtlesid aru niikuinii? Materjalid Alati võimalikult lihtsalt
Õpetaja: algaja sõbralikust Üks sõna, kaks sõna.
Õpetaja: Tallimine ka vale. Ee, nii. Ja ma panen ühe lisa võimalusel juurde juurde.
Õpetaja: Skeeme
Õpetaja: näidiseid, analoogiaid.
Õpetaja: No ma panen isegi juurde. Päris eluga.
Õpetaja: Ee, seonduvaid. Noh, kuidas te tahate seda? Skill I. Täna juba ma arvan.
Õpetaja: Ah,
Õpetaja: ei, kasuta seda päris eluga. Seonduvaid, analoogiaid, Seonduvaid analoogiaid.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, teema jaoks.
Õpetaja: Küsi alati minu käest,
Õpetaja: Millisel
Õpetaja: teemal soovid,
Õpetaja: mis? Kuid nüüd see lause võiks olla enam normaalne. Vaata. Et Seda ta ise väga ei mudi. Arvatavasti. Millisel teemal soovid
Õpetaja: uut materjali
Õpetaja: luua? Midagi? Taolist saad. See on promp, Ma ütlen, talle, mina käivitan tegevuse sinu küsimus saate mõtteliselt aru
Õpetaja: kuidagi, et see võiks olla nagu enamvähem mõistlik. On ju millisel. Toomil soovid uut materjali luua millisel teemal Soovid uut materjali luua?
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, natuke. Võiks ta. Ta hakkab nimesi ka panema. Vaata, ma mäleta siin on.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis ma tahan öelda. Vaata seda ka. Ma jätan selle lõpu korra siia. Ma teen vahepeal Ee, kontrolli. Ott,
Õpetaja: Kontrolli Otti, Tulen siia.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma tahan talle veel seda öelda ka, et ee, name Ee, formaadi
Õpetaja: osas. Kasuta alati prefix. Prefix tähendab faili alguses.
Õpetaja: Või noh, mingi teksti alguses.
Õpetaja: Prefix.
Õpetaja: Ma panen ette. Skill sidekriips,
Õpetaja: Ee, formaat name faili nime ja name osas.
Õpetaja: Ee, formaadi osas kordub alati Prefix skill, Ee,
Õpetaja: Ma olen seda ka nimi. Pigem las ta olla Eesti keelne. Vaata, ma ise kasutan inglise keelt. Aga tegelikult,
Õpetaja: miks mitte? Kohe läheme, sööme. Ma ei tea, kaua ma Jälle Oleme koos järjest töötanud. Mul on lihtsalt nagu pandud mingiks üheksa kaksteist või midagi, mis ta
Õpetaja: landstaime? Enamvähem on ju?
Õpetaja: Kannatate veel?
Õpetaja: No Nii, nii kirjutan, onju Vaatate? Teeme selle põneva osa ära ja siis lähme proovime ära. Vaata kuidas. Ta teeb ja siis nagu läheme uhke tundega nagu. Vau, meil on niuksed võimalused, kas saate aru? Te olete. Te olete võimelised seda ise, tegema,
Õpetaja: et et see ei ole niimoodi, et ma pean hakkama seda faili ise käsitsi kuidagi kirjutama. Te saate seda teha, kui te tahate,
Õpetaja: aga te saate seda sama tööriista kasutada, et palun aita mul luua see skeel Nagu raske
Õpetaja: ehk olla arendaja ja konkurentsivõidlane.
Õpetaja: Aga Vaata aga, nüüd ongi see vahe. Vaata, et Artur juba teab, Skill I, vaata, onju. Ja siis on see mingisugune teine algav vend. Vaata, kes ei oska seda tööriista kasutada on eelis,
Õpetaja: Noh, Teil saab olema ka eelis. Ju Te saate kõik õppida. Võtame. Teil on parim võimalus üldse saada arendajaks. Jah, see sisenemine saab olema keeruline. Täna ma lähen sinna miitingule arutelule. Ma tahan kuulda, mis nad siis räägivad. Selle kohta, et kuuleme, on ju
Õpetaja: Kõik võivad oodata kõike, ei oskagi seda nimi nimetada. Kuidagi kui tõesti. Skills on nii kaua olnud. Poolteist aastat
Õpetaja: Mina, kes tegelikult seda tööriista olen juba kasutanud päris kaua Ma ei tea, kui kaua ma. Ei, ma ei oska öelda. Ma ikka olen nagu terminali. Ma mingit Chatist Võibolla leian ülesse, kus mult Esimest korda tuli see mõte ja ma hakkasin seda kasutama.
Õpetaja: Ka mina nagu ei teadnud. Ma ei jaksa. Vaata, nagu noh, praegu. Vaata, on ju, aga. Aga siin ongi see. Vaata, et, ee,
Õpetaja: te saate tegelikult sellelt kursuselt väga head tööriistad. Noh, ma rääkisin. See ei ole niikuinii Ja Ta on ikkagi uus asi. Vaata selles mõttes. Ee,
Õpetaja: et. Noh, mul on. Ma tahan käsule, et ta paneb selle skill.
Õpetaja: Jah, need on üks ja see sama. Vaata, kas sa näed seda kataloogi siin ja sa näed seda siin.
Õpetaja: Seda seda ma üritangi talle öelda,
Õpetaja: saad aru, Need peavad kattuma.
Õpetaja: Nad peavad katuma ja seda ma üritangi öelda, et mida? Skilli peaks tegema. Ja see Skill I sees, Ütled, et Skill peaks looma nimetama alati
Õpetaja: ee. Stilli algusega.
Õpetaja: Jah, aga sa praegu. Ta kirjeldab, mida Skill peaks tegema aga Skill loob teisi õppematerjale.
Õpetaja: No Saad aru? Vaata, mina praegu ütlen, et juhend. Ma tahan öelda. Tee mulle juhend ja ma tahan öelda seda, et mina annan sulle teema, Mis iganes see teema ei ole, vaata, on ju
Õpetaja: sina loo üks uus skill. Aga üks osa sellest on see, et ta peab panema sellele niukse nime nii või naa. Mina tahan öelda, et ma. Vähemalt ma ei taha seda Niimoodi
Õpetaja: Ta See parem pool on tema suva, Selle mõtleb tema. Välja Mina ütlen Prefix, palun. Iga kord, kui sa mõtled välja mingisuguse nime,
Õpetaja: siis pane sinna. Selline. Asi Ma panen nüüd näidised juurde, sest see muutub talle ka nagu selgemaks Või Kas te loete kuidagi erinevalt või ma saan midagi valesti aru
Õpetaja: Materjali kindlasti,
Õpetaja: Oota, Ma vaatan. Okei, ma tulen korra. Lüh, aeg. Soovin luua sellist skilli, kus luuakse mingi õppematerjal õppematerjal. Olgu, alati eestikeelne. Õppematerjali salvesta alati Palun Tee need. Ma tõstan korra selle poole, et. Aa, ma ei saa. Copy Based.
Õpetaja: Ma tõstaks natuke ülespoole. Vaata, et, ee, Palun tee need Materjalid alati võimalikult lihtsalt alga sõbralikult lisavõimalusel juurde. Skeem, näidised ja päriselusega seonduvad analoogiad faili nime ja formaadi osas kasuta alati prefiks Skill Kaldkriips.
Õpetaja: Või? No mitte, kaldkriips. Sidekriipsustasin jälle selle punkt ära.
Õpetaja: Mm, ma ei saa aru kuidas ta. Mina. Mina ei loe seda niimoodi välja, Kas Keegi loeb kuidagi veel muud moodi välja.
Õpetaja: Siin on kõik täpselt kirjas.
Õpetaja: Vaata, temal on see kontekst ka, et ta saab aru, Vaata, et Ma mõtlen nagu seda.
Õpetaja: No vaatame.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, noh, ma teen siit. Ma. Ma aitan teda. Igal juhul ma panen näited juurde. Siis on Nagu kindel pauk. Vaata, et saab. Aru. Vaata, on ju nii?
Õpetaja: Kui teed mingi materjali bla blabla, Võimalik, Olge sõbralikud disainid ja siis ma Panen siia juurde koma. Näiteks
Õpetaja: Skill?
Õpetaja: Jah, no vahet pole, Tema võtab seda kompotina. Noh, mis me paneme? Mis me tahtsime. Ee, Css,
Õpetaja: Ee, Cs Ss
Õpetaja: üles.
Õpetaja: Oota, hüüdma ei paneks Nüüd siia. Vaata. Ee, Css skill. Sest et selle ta mõtleb ise välja Ee, s,
Õpetaja: struktuur.
Õpetaja: Oi, Oot, oot, oot, oot, oot, oot, see. Mul läks puitu endal. Nüüd praegu. Näete, Toetasite mind sassi? Vaata, praegu endal.
Õpetaja: Oot, oot, oot, oot,
Õpetaja: Ma annan ju kogu asja talle ette. Vaata, ee, ma ju ei loo praegu prompti, et ta uut skill I looks, vaid, et ta looks uue õppematerjali. Fuck, ma nüüd saan aru.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma saan aru. I was wrong you will right.
Õpetaja: Ee jõudis kohale. No näete, ei Ole ka minul lihtne. Vaata siin orienteerida Ee faili
Õpetaja: nime ja name osas kasuta.
Õpetaja: Ma annan ise nüüd nime. Vaata sellele, skill. Ee, loo Uus
Õpetaja: õppe. Noh, ma ei oleks õde julge kasutada,
Õpetaja: Sobib nüüd. Olen õiges, Kurat küll, nagu,
Õpetaja: Ah oota, aga võibolla peaks ka selle jaoks tegema, et järgmine kord, kui Skill luua, et siis nagu peab veel vähem kirjutama ka Skill I loomiseks, onju mõttekoht Ee. Nii,
Õpetaja: ee, teema jaoks. Ee, Küsi alati. Minu käest. Millisel teemal soovid uut materjali luua?
Õpetaja: No, siia võib panna näiteks. Vaata nüüd näiteks.
Õpetaja: Aa,
Õpetaja: aa noh, näiteks Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Css, Cssi struktuur.
Õpetaja: Nii midagi taolist. Ma tahan veel ühe rea panna. Veel nagu. Vaata aga mis? Millega ta arvestaks?
Õpetaja: Ee, iga kord, kui ma seda teen, siis potentsiaalselt. Ee, ma juba mingisugust asja niiöelda progemises olen teinud. Mul on seal ees midagi. Ma arutlen, onju Mida iganes, et ma ütlen talle seda ka, et ee, arvesta, et. Et selles selleks hetkeks chat is, juba võib olla sellel teemal meil mingisugune vestluse kontekst,
Õpetaja: Et ta arvestaks sellega ka,
Õpetaja: et ma ei viitsi nagu niimoodi. Teha ka. Vaata, ma. Ma küsin midagi, näiteks sa koodis, Vaata, et mida see asi teeb
Õpetaja: Ja siis. Ta ütleb mulle kiirelt. See teeb sellist asja. Vaata ja siis ma otsustan tavaliselt. Vaata selle Ära vaata, et kas ma tahan nagu õppematerjali või mitte. Ma tahaks, et siis ma. Kui ma ütlen, et käivitan selle niiöelda skill I Ja selle nagu küsib, mis teemal soovid vestelda. Vaata, on ju. Siis ma ütlengi, et noh.
Õpetaja: See asi. Vaata, mis me just nagu põhimõtteliselt Rääkisime vaatas. Saad kiiresti selle teema kätte. Nagu, et
Õpetaja: arvestaks kontekstiga ka. Vaata, onju. Ma proovin midagi niukest panna. Ma ei tea, kas see on tingimata. On vajalik, aga ma panen ikkagi
Õpetaja: nii.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma panen selle niimoodi. Lihtsalt Ja lakooniliselt, on ju Ee, selle küsimuse
Õpetaja: ja vastuse juures.
Õpetaja: Ee, vaata ka.
Õpetaja: Ta niikuinii teab seda. Aga vaata, ma ütlen ka. Arvesta aasta ka meie senist.
Õpetaja: Jah, kuidagi tuleb väga imelikult vestlust,
Õpetaja: Vot siin on nagu see. Vaata, et ma nagu ei oska. Nagu seda eesti keeles öelda. Vaata, siis ma ütleks niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Too That point vestlust.
Õpetaja: Ma ei oska seda. Lihtsalt vaata, kui hea on, ma saan miksida. Vaata, ah?
Õpetaja: Ee. Tegelikult eelnevat vestlust. Eelnevat senist vestlust siis on Nagu kindlalt meie eelneenud senist vestlust.
Õpetaja: Selle Küsimuse juures. Ma ütlen selle teema juures. Pigem.
Õpetaja: Ee, vaata, siin on see. Ka Tegelikult, et. Ee. Kui me nüüd teeme selle ära, me näeme, mis ta lõpuks. Nagu. Kuidas ta need juhised kokku paneb? Vaata, on ju? Tema ju teeb Nüüd juhised,
Õpetaja: Saame seda nüüd juhiseid vaadata ja siis saame seal öelda, et, noh, tee siit paremaks ja sealt paremaks ja. Ja siis, kui Me juba kasutame ja näeme, et kuskil on meil mingi puudujääk. Ja siis sa saad seda kogu aeg minna täiendama, et kuule, et seal On see skill, palun? Nagu seal on see koht nii nagu meil reeglitegi on. Cloud is.
Õpetaja: Saad kogu aeg öelda. Vaata, meil on mingid reeglid. Jälgi neid ja vahel on niimoodi, et saad aru, et ta tegelikult mingist väiksest nüanssist ei saa nagu pidevalt aru, ma ei viitsi kogu aeg seda asja parandada, Vaid ma lihtsalt lähen ütlen. Et palun, tee juhised korda. Vaata, on ju
Õpetaja: et see, peab olema,
Õpetaja: kuidas see Küsimus on väga, väga veig.
Õpetaja: Ee, sa Pane mulle mingi näide juurde, muidu ma ei saa aru.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta midagi teeks nagu teistmoodi või paremini. Ülejäänud Selle osa jätab nagu alles samaks. Või ta võib ka. Noh,
Õpetaja: vaata, siin on niimoodi. Vaata, et kui sa ütled, vaata ma Toon näi. Ma toon Ma toon näiteid. Näiteks vaata, Onju. Kui mul üldse Näiteks niimoodi. Mul oli mingi alginfo olemas. Mul oli seal promptis Kõik Kirjeldus, kus ta saab. Nagu Mingit informatsiooni Ja minu ülesanne oli see, et tee mulle taas kirjeldus. Vaata, mis peab toimuma, vaata onju?
Õpetaja: Ma ütlesin talle, et teed taaski, on ju? Ma leidsin. Vaata, et ta teeb taaski valmis ja ma näen seal mingeid ebatäpsusi,
Õpetaja: siis tihtipeale Ma hakkasin kõigepealt tegelema üldse selle probleemiga. Vaata, on ju, et. Et. Kuule, sa tegid taaski. Vaata, onju, Sul on siin mingid kirjeldused, aga Midagi on puudu. Ütleme, et palun, Lisa siia. Taski ka selline informatsioon.
Õpetaja: Siis ta tegi. Näiteks tegi taaski korda. Ja siis ma ütlesin, et Kuule, aga teeme nüüd niimoodi vaata, Noh, meil olid. Noh, juhised ju. Vaata, tegi ju selle skilliga, et ole hea. Vaata, täienda nüüd seda Skill I. Vaata, et ee. Kui sa uut taaski lood, vaata, et siis. Noh, lisa ka see info, siis tal on see kontekst olemas, Siis tal on isegi näited olemas. Vaata, kuidas. Oli nagu ennem. Kuidas oli pärast hiljem nii nagu minule meeldis.
Õpetaja: Ja ta saab selle kompotina kokku võtta ja siis minna sinna sellesse ee juhistesse. Ja siis selle osa lihtsalt ise ära muuta.
Õpetaja: Umbes niimoodi. See töötab kõige efektiivsemalt sellepärast, et ta teeb Ta teebki seda. Täidabki seda prompt.
Õpetaja: Ja vaata, teeb mulle tulemuse, Aga mitte nii, nagu minule. Meeldib mina. Nagu parandan ära
Õpetaja: Ja siis vahel on niimoodi. Ta ütles, et on nii. Clever, vaata. Vahepeal on teinud teistpidi. Ma vaatan, et kurat ta tegi selle valesti, Vaata, onju Või jäi nii hästi. Ma lähen kohe selle juurde ja ütlen, et. Kuule, ole hea. Pane sinna Skill I kirja, et noh, Lisa, see info ka. Vaata, on ju
Õpetaja: siis ta, mis ta tavaliselt teeb on ja ja teen selle korda ja ma Change ja sealt Ma ju näen. Vaata, mida ta muudab. Vaata, on ju? Kui kui hästi Kitt töötab selle asjaga kokku ja siis ta tavaliselt ise ütleb, Ma siis teen need parandused ka selles lahenduses. Just, ära vaata, et mis. Nagu läks valesti, et kumb. Vaata ja ta põhimõtteliselt on nagu Pretty Clever,
Õpetaja: et et juhised ei olnud piisavalt head. Okei, ta saab aru. Ma just käivitasin need juhised. See polnud perfektne. Ma täiendan juhiseid Ja ta, kas ta küsib üle või ta teeb kohe. Vot see on nagu veits. Niukene Fortuuna. Pigem, ta küsib isegi üle ka ma Tegin ära selle juhise, et Kas ma. Nüüd teen selle muudatused ka? Siin taskis viis That Clever vaatas ütleb ja ja tui,
Õpetaja: ja olgu See viimane kord. Ütled talle ka.
Õpetaja: Nii. Ee, selle teema juures.
Õpetaja: Ee, käsitluste käsitluse juures. Arvestagem eelne eelnenud senist vestlust. No Ma, ei tea, Aitab küll, Let s go. Tahaks juba lõunale minna, eksole?
Õpetaja: Kaua me nüüd järjest tegime? Ma mul. Ma ei suuda jälgida. Te peate mulle ütlema, kui asi läheb liiga pikaks.
Õpetaja: Tund nelikümmend. Aga jaksate praegult.
Õpetaja: Okei ja kohe lähme lõunale ka, nagu onju.
Õpetaja: No ikka jah, aga ma Tahan seda skill. Ma tahan käivitada seda nagu palju tööd. Ja siis läheme pausile Ja mingi ärevus. Ja närv on sees, nagu
Õpetaja: see on Nagu see, et kirjutaks nagu koodi välja. Ja siis nagu sa saad Play nuppu ka servereid käivitada, mõtled? Aa, ma lähen teil lõuna ära, Siis ma vaatan, kas üldse, töötab. Et näe nagu vaeva. No vaata, mis ta Tegi
Õpetaja: Ee, hea kaust on Nüüd olemas. Üks materjali on Olemas peab olema suurem olema Täielik pilt olemas. Ee, ta küsib, et kas ma soovin Editeid lubada. Jah, luba selles sessioonis ee teha Editeid Nii palju, kui tahad. Ma siin näen. Vaata, ta näeb. Ee. Lõi niukse Faili
Õpetaja: lõi niisuguse sisu. Ta teeb mingisuguse väikse. Viiskümmend viiskümmend seitse rida. Ta katab ära, onju? Või noh,
Õpetaja: Peidab ära. Annab mulle kokkuvõtte Skill Ist Ma võin kohe lähme vaatama. Ka seda faili Skill teeb järgmist. Kui sa seda käivitad, küsib teema, millisel teemal soovid uut materjali luua? Kontrollib Olemasolevad materjalid ei loo tublikaati. Noh, ise ei mõelda, sellele Vaata, hoiab stiili. Ühtsena
Õpetaja: arvestab vestluse konteksti. Kui oled juba Html I õppinud, seob mida iganes. Vaata koostab materjalid, skeemid näited, analoogid kokkuvõtte tabel Järgmised sammud.
Õpetaja: Salvestad teooria kausta. Teavitad tulemusest küsib tagasisidet. Ah, noh, viimane on okei ee, kasutamiseks.
Õpetaja: Ee, kirjuta lihtsalt loo skill materjal aga näed, Vot jah, kõik on õige. Nii.
Õpetaja: Aga midagi on puudu.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan nüüd päriselt ära. Mina tahtsin, et siin on skill. Kuidas see prefix Läks ikka kaduma.
Õpetaja: Näed, vot ikkagi. Ta ei mõistnud mind just oleks. Pidanud ikkagi ütlema tingimata ma. Tahtsin et, siin on see hakkab. Skill iga. Sellepärast me tahame grupeerida iga kord, kui sa paned kaldkriipsu. Kui üks asi hakkab Elliga, teine asi hakkab Teega kuidas sa mäletad kõike,
Õpetaja: Kui aga ma kirjutan Skill sidekriips Juba siis ma juba näen. Vaata, Taie Narratowni teeb mulle Ära vaata, et mis, killid Mul on, on Ju te saate joon jooksutada alati ka listi Skills.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ta näitab kõike. Aga ma ei viitsi Pole vaja tee kavaralt, onju? Ee, Nüüd see kokkuvõte on selline. Nüüd ma tahan korra vaadata nüüd seda päris asja ka, onju? Jällegi, kuidas leiab üli lihtsalt ülesse. Võtke oma tee, onju Aga idee järgi Unversion File.
Õpetaja: Kui mõnus on nüüd seda vaadata. Jah, hea, et on siin. Ta on õigesti pannud Skill loo Uus alguse õppematerjal. See võib olla isegi töötab korrektselt. Siin. Tal on see Kokkuvõte on jama
Õpetaja: kasutamiseks. Ma Ei, saa kirjutada loo uus õppematerjal kasutamiseks. Ma pean kirjutama Skill sidekriips loo uus õppematerjal. Niimoodi saab seda käivitada. See, et vot siin ongi see, et ta ajab paska mulle siin praegu
Õpetaja: pallukad ja. Aga vaatame, mis ta. Vaatame selles mõttes Natukene selle ära vaata. Niimoodi Saame edaspidi käivitada Skill loo uus õppematerjal loo Uus beginerfriendi õppematerjal eesti keeles ja Salvestad Tox teoria. Seda me näeme ka seal, kui me kirjutame selle asja sisse.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, nüüd võime minna selle visuaalse poole peale. Mina olen võrdlusvaates. Siin ei ole. Vaata seda Preview nuppu.
Õpetaja: Ma pean päris faili avama. F Neli tavaliselt seda teeb. Nüüd ma saan vaadata seda asja, nagu normaalselt onju, et ee, niimoodi viisakalt
Õpetaja: uus õppematerjal, loo alga sõbralik õppematerjal eesti keeles ja salvesta sinna ka osta. Steps küsi Teema. Millisel teemal. Soovin materjali luua. Näiteks Niukene. Oota vastust, enne kui jätkad kontrolli olemasolevaid materjale.
Õpetaja: Vaata, vaata kui Sama teema kohta on juba Olemas Teavita kasutajat ja küsi, kas uuendad olemasolevat või luua. Fail kõlab loogiliselt, onju, sest, et võib juhtuda ka, Niimoodi, et sul on nii palju neid materjale. Lõpuks, et sa oled juba tegelt juba püsinud. Sa lihtsalt
Õpetaja: ei töötanud mind materjale läbi, ei õppinud. Teid selgeks ja lihtsalt sinna see jäi. Vaata, onju? Juba jälle küsid? Noh, siis ta ütleb, et sa põmm hea, põhimõtteliselt onju, et Sa oled juba ühe korra õppinud seda asja Vaata ka eelnevaid materjale.
Õpetaja: Ee, näiteks saate meil sissejuhatuset hoida stiili
Õpetaja: ja Ra ta põhimõtteliselt ütleb, Et vaata nagu neid olemasolevaid asju, et hoida stiili ja raskusaste ühtne. Okei, nõus arvesta vestluse konteksti. Vaata, mida kasutan selles asju varem õppinud Ja küsinud
Õpetaja: kui materjalid soojendada eelnevalt käsitletud teemadega, viita sellele loogilisele järjekorrale. Materjal peab sisestama selget pealkirja lühike sissejuhatus
Õpetaja: Visuaalsed skeemid assiga tähtedega teeb Skeemi super sobib. Koodinäited päriselu analoogiaid, Võrdle tuntud asjadega Maja, retsept, liiklusruum või muu selline kokkuvõtte tabelina järgmised sammud mida edasi, õppida
Õpetaja: sobib ja
Õpetaja: Misasja Ta põhimõtteliselt ka nagu ta annab ideid. Vaata, ma isegi ei tea. Ta annab ideid. Noh, sa uurisid selle kohta.
Õpetaja: Uuri veel
Õpetaja: faili nime Valik teema. Alateema väiketähed sidekriipsuga Eesti keeles. Näidised Cs, sissejuhatus, Ccs, Flexbox ja põhitõed sobib salvesta fail
Õpetaja: bla blabla Md teavita kasutajat. Lõpus Ta näitab faili Asukoht. Lühike kokkuvõte. Noh, see, mis ta hakkab rääkima tegi. Küsi, kas midagi puudu vajab täiendamist. Kuidas tundub sellised juhised?
Õpetaja: Väga Super, onju? Mida ma ei. Kui ma tegelikult tahakski iga kord teha nagu perfektselt asju, siis ma peaksin ju iga kord seda prompt Is kirjutama. Pane sinna tee seda. Kasutajasõbralik. Lisaskeemid Näitad, analoogiad. No ei, viitsi, onju
Õpetaja: Seda see skill lahendabki. Ma Ütlen, ma ise. Tegin enda skill Süsteemi erinevad promptid, punkt. Panen mulle koodiploki, et ma saaks copy paste Ida, Siis ma mõtlesin aga ma saan ka pealkirja järgi et käivita see. Ja, noh, mõtle natuke. Ja siis, kui ma võtsin vaeva, et hakkasin, tutvuma nagu. Mis siin. Üldse on,
Õpetaja: Power Ups, iga. Avastasin selle Skill I. Tegin selle peale selgeks. Vaatasin, mida
Õpetaja: siis ma. Ütlesin. Kuidas ma selle teema ei oska? Seda skill faili teha. Vaata, alguses ta Kuskilt otsis võrgust dokumentatsiooni, tee uus skill ja tema ei tea. Vaata, ta ei saanud. Ta tegelikult tegi ühe asja valesti.
Õpetaja: Aga ta läks Netti otsis. Kõik teeb minu meelest ära, nagu otsin. Uurin dokumentatsiooni. Nii, teeme selle ära ja lähme siis. Ee, vaatame, kuidas sealt saab. Aa, Üks asi on see, et ma vaatan, kas ta kohe pakub nüüd või mitte. Ma tean, ta praegult ei öelnud seda,
Õpetaja: kui teed uue Skill I, et kas ta on koheselt kasutatav? Nüüd näeme,
Õpetaja: kui ma panen praegu siia Skill näete ei ole seda siin valikutes, Siin on Üks siukene käsk, mis on pluginitega seotud. Ee, kirjutan plugin ära, et veits vähendada variante Plugin
Õpetaja: kui selle käsu jooksutad ära,
Õpetaja: ta loeb selle Skill I endale mällu. Nüüd, kui ma kirjutan Skill, siis te nüüd saate aru, miks on tähtis et see mul on erinevad skill Id, Et Miks peab olema nagu see skilliga algama? Sest et neid tuleb palju.
Õpetaja: Ma võtan kohe selle Pull Requesti sealt Ära Vaata aga vaata, See loo uus keeles. Salvestad okse noh, edaspidi ma tean niikuinii. Vaata, saate mõttest aru,
Õpetaja: Nii ma vajutan. Seda
Õpetaja: Noh, sobib.
Õpetaja: No edaspidi kahjuks Nii hea ei ole. Aga. No aga saate aru, nagu
Õpetaja: ei ole ühtegi faili. Htm Materjal on juba olemas, mis tähendab, et kasvataja on Html. Iga tuttav Cs. Ta juba vaatas. Ära Vaata, et ee, et see on juba olemas. Css on loogiline järgmine samm.
Õpetaja: Noh, minu arvates ka loogiline. Ennem nagu ei lähe.
Õpetaja: Kuidas on Atml iga seotud? Nagu Aga näed, kui hea see on. Aga mida? Kui palju me pidime praegu kirjutama. Ja nüüd on see, kui ma tahaks mingeid muid asju praegu arutada. Uus asi on niukene asi by the way
Õpetaja: Ma. Saan hakata kirjutama mingit Aa Question, It Saan. Millestki muust rääkida et, ta oma vana protsessi paneb edasi põhiline asi. On see et, see vestlus ei jää talle konteksti,
Õpetaja: et et see see vestlus ei jää nüüd meie senisesse vestlusesse.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: kontekstis rääkides ka veel. Vaata kohe lähme vaatame tulemust läheks lõunale. Tegelikult ma täpselt kümne minuti pärast on pool siis. On nagu kuidagi loogiline jaksate.
Õpetaja: On põnev ka vä nii ee kontekst Selline käsk nagu kaldkriips Kontekst Seda tuleb natukene jälgida.
Õpetaja: Ee, teeme ekraani suuremaks. Oi, aga ta teeb praegu vana asja. Vaata, Ma ei pannud ette.
Õpetaja: Aa, mis tal praegult on? See, et ta teeb eelmise asja lõpuni.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis? Sest et ma hoidsin entrit seda kontekstis, ta ei ole veel, Ta ei ole selle materjali ära. Teinud.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta ütles mulle. Vaatame korra, Mis ta siis ütles? Ka materjali asukoht,
Õpetaja: Mis on Ccs. Kui te saate meile ka ühendada. Kolm, viis. Badding Marchin. Visuaalsed skeemid. Me vaatame, mis seal on. Värvide formaat, täielik näide, siis midagi jäi puudu. Kahjuks ma juba kontekst sisse, aga ma saan seda rääkida temaga nüüd edasi. Vaata, et. Jaa.
Õpetaja: Aga näete konteksti. Ta esitab niimoodi.
Õpetaja: See on. Meil on kuskil kakssada tuhat token It. On Meil jäetud ruumi ee hetke vestlus. Mida Ta suudab ee niiöelda hallata, ja niiöelda
Õpetaja: manageerida. Osa sellest on puhvrina. Ee, juba reserveeritud. Free Space Auto Compact Kui ta jõuab oma nende mummudega siia alla välja, siis ta teeb niimoodi, et ta võtab olemasolevase vestluse. Ta ei saa enam Kontekst on täis.
Õpetaja: Ta võtab olemasoleva vestluse. Ta proovib selle lükata kompaktseks kokku. Noh, Kõik, mis on tähtis, Ta teeb meile uue vestluse ja võtab selle kompaktse niiöelda vestluse nagu uue konteksti alguseks, et üritab nagu meeles hoida, Mida sa enne tegid?
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: midagi taolist, Ja Ühesõnaga. Ta hoiab nagu meeles ühtlasi. Ta annab graafiliselt siis meile nagu märku, vaata kuhu meie Asjad, nagu kuluvad Ee, kuusteist tuhat hetkel on meie omavahelised sõnumid. Mingisugune on Skill.
Õpetaja: Noh, mida iganes, mida on tähtis, teada, on see
Õpetaja: kontekst Põhimõtteliselt läheb iga Jumala käsuga enamvähem.
Õpetaja: Mis on mõte, on see, et kui me kogu, mida suurem on see kontekst, mida rohkem me suhtleme, Seda rohkem see kulutab kogu aeg.
Õpetaja: Ja meil on see Free Mitte Free Bland, vaid pro Blan Ee, Kus on niimoodi, et on niuksed Viietunnised Slot Id ja sa hakkad tööd tegema. Ja token. Id on piiratud.
Õpetaja: Ühel Hetkel tuleb ette, et Sa pead nüüd ootama mingi kuni kella kaheni,
Õpetaja: Siis saad jälle teha tööd. Siis me tahame olla nagu targad. Selles osas ka, et me hakkame natukene konteksti jälgima.
Õpetaja: Kus on Niuksed, loogilised kohad. Ee, kus? Aa, kus sul on mõistlik? Kontekst ütleme? On kohad kus, me soovime ja. Aeg et, kus me soovime et, ta kõike. Mäletame, mis me siiamaani oleme teinud,
Õpetaja: Sest et tal on see kontekst. Me teame mingi sarnaseid asju. Mida iganes, kus me teeme, Ta Kogu aeg saab aru. Vaata, kuidas meile mingid asjad meeldivad.
Õpetaja: Me tahame konteksti hoida, hoida hoida, aga näiteks siis päris arenduses Ja ka Kui mina nüüd projekti olen teinud, on see, et minul on üks käsk. Et Vaata, palun võta see. Küsi, ütlen, palun. Ee, loo Taaski lahendus Mul on taas kuskil Md failina olemas Mida sa pead tegema järgmise mingi teenus või asi
Õpetaja: Ja tema läheb nagu sinna sisse võtab selle sisu promptiga. Vaata ja hakkab seda taas implementeerima. Minu jaoks on väga loogiline asi, et vaata, et iga kord, kui ma hakkan uut taaski tegema, siis need vanad asjad on mul kaine kama, et tal ei ole vaja meeles hoida. Mida me siiamaani tegime?
Õpetaja: See nüüd muidugi Sõltub sellest. Vaata, et kui me just midagi tegime. Ma nügisin teda siia sinna suunas. Vaata, kui ta nüüd uut taaski võtab, et kui Tal on see kontekst olemas eelmisest. Kui me eelmise taaski tegime, siis ta võibolla teeb natukene. Paremini.
Õpetaja: Aga minu eesmärk on niikuinii jõuda sellesse staadioni sellisena hetkeni. Vaata, kui sellisena lahenduseni on. Niimoodi, et minu need skill Id ja asjad on nii ideaalsed. Minu need juhised on ideaalsed
Õpetaja: D ja D. Asjad on ideaalsed, et ma pigem on niimoodi, et kui ma ütlen niimoodi, sest siin on.
Õpetaja: Löö tühjaks.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on jälle Nüüd ei kulu nii palju Nüüd kui me chat ime. Meil ei kulu nii palju token. Eid, see on See pluss, et minu mõte on see, et mistahes hetkel, kui ma hakkan mingi standard asja tegema, et palun loo uus lahendus taski pealt. Ee, siis ma soovin seda, Vaata, et see kõik ongi nii perfektne,
Õpetaja: et ma. Ma soovingi kleerida. Ja ma soovingi, et ta teeks nagu puhtalt lehelt uuesti, kui ta Nüüd teeb jälle midagi, mis mulle ei meeldi, Siis ma hakkan mõtlema, Kas ma lähen parandan kuskil mingit? Skill I.
Õpetaja: Kas ma lähen oma nende Cloud juhiste juurde. Et kuhu see nagu kuulub. Vaata, on ju, et iga kord, kui ma puhtalt alustan ja soovin, et sa midagi teeks. Ta teeks täpselt nii, nagu mina tahan. See on see mõte, Sest et siis ma saan igal hetkel panna, põhimõtteliselt ta peale igat aastat saan vähemalt panna Clear
Õpetaja: hoida oma konteksti kokku. Ma ei viitsi tegelikult. Tegelikult see on. See on väga Nüri värk. Vaata, et kui Aa, sa saad Kontekst saab täis ja sul on niimoodi. Mine pekki. Ma olin just hoos. Ma olin just hoos.
Õpetaja: Mul on, mul on just vaja midagi tegelikult mahukat teha. Ja nüüd ta räägib, et ma pean mingi kuradi kell seitse tema juurde uuesti jutule tulema või mu Töö peab läbi juba, sõber.
Õpetaja: Ma tahaks nagu puhata, siis. Aga ma tahaks seda ära ka teha et kui me oleme nagu selle odava plaani peal. Aa, mis on siis? Kakskümmend eurot, onju?
Õpetaja: Siis, Vähemalt ee. Mõtleme nagu, seda Vaata, et mida me saame teha, et oma token Ega natukene jälgida. Mõttes saate aru?
Õpetaja: Kontekst maksab.
Õpetaja: Nüüd lähme küll lõunale. Aa, tähendab, mis asja? Vaatame materjali pilguga üle. Korra si sügavale ei lähe. Tuli siia uus fail juurde. Cse Struktuuri kasutamine tuli materials alla.
Õpetaja: Vaatame üks see välja Näeb. Ee. Vaatame seda jälle. Siit ei saa vaadata. Pole Preview Ds. Me pole tegelt päris failis. Me oleme nagu võrdlusvaates. Teeme selle asja suureks ja uhkeks
Õpetaja: struktuur algajale.
Õpetaja: Näita, et, noh, Me tuleme, vaatame siin mingid selgitused pärast. Aa, vaatame Covid.
Õpetaja: Näed, Ee, mina olen siis õpetajale. Oota nüüd ongi. Mida on kommit itud, kui Mina teen praegult Comiti, Siis mis failid sinna lähevad?
Õpetaja: Maksimaalselt saavad ainult minna. Need failid, need on määramata.
Õpetaja: Me Pole öelnud. Aa, et vaata, Kui me ise mingi faili teeme, siis ee. Küsi meie käest. Ad a kit.
Õpetaja: Ja me saakski tegelikult reeglitesse panna, et kui sa lood mingi uue faili. Pane sa kohe kitti. Aga mis meile ei meeldi? See on see, et me just näemegi.
Õpetaja: Tahangi näha, mis sa juurde tegid. Mõtled koodifaili juurde? Kuidas ma saan kiire? Overview? Ma tahan vaadata, kus on sinine
Õpetaja: ja kus on Punane
Õpetaja: roheliseks? Muutub see, siis kui Kui mina tõstan selle siia, Vaata, on ju ja ma ise. Kui ma ise teen tööd, siis ma tegelikult niimoodi käin. Kõik asjad läbi kõik muudatused, mis ta teeb. Ma lähen vaatan selle ära ja ma panen tiki iseendale et ma olen vaadanud.
Õpetaja: Ma olen vaadanud, ma olen vaadanud need asjad. Ma tõstan uued failid. Ma tõstan alles siia alla. Alles siis ma korra panen tagasi, mis ta tegi juurde selle ja
Õpetaja: Selle need kaks vist vä. Ei,
Õpetaja: Skill. Ja see on ju. Kui ma praegu panen Roll Back,
Õpetaja: Kui seda tikpoksi ei ole, et Eliit, Siis nad lihtsalt lähevad tagasi siia alla, et ma nagu rahulikult need asjad vaataks. Läbi paneks, tikikanda peale ja ma ennem siia ei lohista, Kui ma ei ole seda vaadanud, saate aru? Ja need, asjad mis olid muudatused, ma nende tikkidega jälgin päeva lõpuks, et ma kõik asjad Vaatan kenasti üle,
Õpetaja: mis ta tegi mulle. Ja siin on ka see, kus tuleb tegelikult kasuks. See, et olge kavalad ja tehke ka mitte Pigem võibolla tihedamalt. Miks sellepärast peale igat käsku sa saad siis, täpselt, vaadata. Mida ta just selle promptiga muutis
Õpetaja: et et kui sa muid, Kui ta mingi lõi mingi faili.
Õpetaja: Sa ei saa enam sammsammult nagu tagasi vaadata, et enne seda prompti ja nii edasi, okei, siin on Funktsionaalsus, mis muudab taga need tagasi need asjad. Aga sa ei saa ka enda vaadata. Et jälgimise mõttes on tegelikult mõistlik isegi teha prompte Vähe Tihedamalt,
Õpetaja: sest et asjad ei Tule perfektselt.
Õpetaja: Savi tuli asjad, nii, nagu tulid. Kui vaatad need üle ja kui sa nüüd ütled järgmise prompli. Siis sa jälle Change I seal. Kohe näed.
Õpetaja: Sul on nagu väga, viisakalt. Näed, ära et. Noh, mis nüüd muutus
Õpetaja: kas on mida, mida ma soovin alles jätta.
Õpetaja: Või nüüd on veel ideaalne võimalus, et kui ta tegi mingi täieliku saaste tegi meile,
Õpetaja: mulle ei meeldi, sa Saad talle öelda, et tee muudatused tagasi, Aga see maksab token eid.
Õpetaja: Noh, saate aru nii lõunale. Lets go Jaagu.
Õpetaja: Voh, Noh, kui tüütu seda ka teha on. Panen message. See saab olema meie järgmine tool.
Õpetaja: Ee
Õpetaja: Panid juba ära. Tubli Aa. Presentatsioonist Ta ei pääse enda. Need Lemmikud.
Õpetaja: Väga hea, mul on hea meel. Ee, Lähme siis sööme tagasi. Siis Neljakümne viie minuti jooksul Olete nõus käik?
Õpetaja: Aitäh sulle, ma panen Sa stop
Õpetaja: näha ka, palju, et läks selle
Õpetaja: seal all nagu jookseb ja. Ja seda saab Jälgida Ja on ka. Mingeid tööriistasid.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult
Õpetaja: praegu on seda raske vaadata. Sa peaksid seda teksti nagu jälgima Vaata, et see on pigem nagu tulevikus. Vaata, et sa saad nagu monitoorida token Eid, et. Ee.
Õpetaja: Kui sa paned selle kaldkriips used. Vaata, onju. Ja jätad selle numbri meelde. Vaata, et mis hetkel on. Token ide kogukulu Ja käivitad mingisuguse käsu. Võibolla sa tahad isegi küsida. Ma ütlen, ma ei tea. Vaata, ee.
Õpetaja: Umbes viiskümmend tuhat, aga võimalik. Kasutan selle.